ISSUES NINE THROUGH ELEVEN WHICH
ARE ALL RELATED TO CAL FRESH AND
FOOD ISSUES.
PART THREE WILL BE AFTER ISSUES
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
AND PARK FOR WILL BE AFTER THE
BALANCE OF THE AGENDA WHICH ARE
ISSUES FOURTEEN THROUGH.
SEVENTEEN WE'LL WORK THROUGH THE
PANELS IN THE AGENDA BEFORE WE
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR EACH
OF THE PARTS I'VE REFERENCED.
ALL PANELISTS ARE ASKED TO
MAINTAIN REMARKS TWO UNDER THREE
MINUTES [inaudible]
PLEASE.
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
RESTRICTED TO ONE MINUTE EACH
AND OUR STAFF WILL HOLD UP A
GENTLE REMINDER WHEN YOU ARE
CLOSE TO TIME.
IT IS A GENTLE REMINDER BUT
PLEASE HE THAT.
WITHOUT LET'S BEGIN WITH ISSUE
ONE I WANT TO WELCOME.
MY ONE COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
PLEASE BEGAN OR WHEN YOU'RE
READY ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RELATED TO CAL WORKS GRANTS.
AND THANK YOU ALL.
AND IF WE COULD DO IT IN THE
ORDER LISTED.
THAT IS SO MUCH EASIER FOR
EVERYONE TO FOLLOW.
DEPARTMENT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT KIM JOHNSON DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
I'LL START WITH JUST A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW AND THEN HAD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PLEASURE OF THE AT THE GROUP.
SO YES TEMAS CASELOADS ARE
DECLINING NATIONWIDE CALIFORNIA
IS ON A MUCH LOWER DOWNWARD
TREND IN OTHER STATES BUT SINCE
THE PEAK OF THE COW WORKS
CASELOAD ALMOST SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN JUST AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION THE TOTAL CASELOAD HAS
BEEN DECLINING.
ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA'S
IMPROVING ECONOMY.
AND THE GRANT INCREASES IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SLOW THAT
NATURAL CASELOAD DECLINE AND
ALLOWED FAMILIES WHO EARN MORE
INCOME TO STAY IN THE PROGRAM.
FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CDSS PROJECTS
THE BASE CASELOAD FOR THIS
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR TO DECREASE
BY 8% FROM THE PREVIOUS FISCAL
YEAR.
AND THE CASE LOAD FOR THAT
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR TO
DECREASE BY SIX POINT 9% FROM
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS.
THE CALIFORNIA TEN OF POVERTY
RATE IS THE HIGHEST RATIO
NATIONWIDE BY MORETHAN A 10%
MARGINS THE MEETING THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE STRONGEST
DEMONSTRATION OF ANY PROGRAM IN
THE NATION OF ENGAGING AND
SERVING FAMILIES IN POVERTY.
NARROWING FURTHER INTO THE CASE
LOAD TO EXPLORE CHILDREN POVERTY
CAO WORKS THERE'S EVEN MORE IN
TOUCH IS MORE THAN 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMPOVERISHED YOUTH
BUT WE STILL CAN DO BETTER.
EVEN WITH THESE POSITIVE TRENDS
IN FACT THE STATE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ONGOING EFFORTS IN
AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT WE
CONSTANTLY STRIVE TO BE THE BEST
POSSIBLE PARTNER FOR THE
COUNTIES AT AND PEOPLE.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO OVER THE
LAST YEAR WE HAVE FOCUSED OUR
EFFORTS I IN A GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL DOES
INCLUDE INCREASES TO THE CAL
WORKS GRANT LEVELS WE'VE ALSO
MADE SOME MODIFICATIONS TO THE
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY.
OF THE COW WORK SINGLE
ALLOCATION TO ENSURE THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE TO SERVE OUR
POPULATIONS WE'VE ALSO LAUNCHED
A TWO GENERATION APPROACH FOR
THE K. AND CAL WORKS AT IN OUR
KIDS AND SERVING FAMILIES
IMPLEMENTING THE COW WORK SOME
VISITING INITIATIVE.
AND WERE ALSO SET TO LAUNCH OUR
CAO WORKS OUT COMES AN
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW.
AT TO ENSURE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
ACROSS THE PROGRAM SO THAT'S OUR
OUR OVERVIEW AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND CAL WORKS.
AND AGAIN I'M HAPPY TO SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT TO THE GRANT INCREASE
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY IN THE
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA.
SURE.
YES PLEASE SURE SO WE ARE IT
JUST ACTUALLY THIS MONTH APRIL
OF THIS YEAR WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THE 10% ACROSS THE BOARD GRANT
INCREASE.
AGREED UPON THE LAST BUDGET
CYCLE THIS GRANT INCREASE
APPLIES TO ALL CAO WORKS CASES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THAT
ASSISTANCE UNIT LIVES IN REGION
ONE OR TWO AND REGARDLESS OF THE
EXEMPT OR NOT EXEMPT STATUS THAT
THE PARTICIPANTS.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES A
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
THE CALYX GRANT LEVELS BY 131%
EFFECTIVE OCTOBER.
OF THIS YEAR AND THAT WILL BRING
A MONTHLY GRANT PAYMENTS 250% --
FOR A PORTION OF THAT CASE LOAD --
THE QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA
SPECIFICALLY ASK ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE ON TO
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS AT THE LA --
AND AT DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES
THAT WERE APPROACHED --
SPECIFICALLY THE THIRD OPTION
I'M FOR THE GRANT LEVEL INCREASE
THAT IS.
COULD BE OPERATIONAL THAT WAS
THE QUESTION POSED TO US IT IS
AB ABLE TO BE OPERATIONAL IT IS
A SIGNIFICANT COST OVER WHAT THE
CURRENT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES -- IN TERMS OF THE
DISTRIBUTION AB ASSISTANT UNIT
SIZES ACROSS THE COW WORKS
CASELOAD THE GRANT INCREASE
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
LARGEST IMPACT ON THE LARGEST
PERCENT OF THE CASELOAD WHICH IS
AT ASSISTANT UNIT SIZES OF TWO
AND THREE WHICH IS.
ABOUT 50% 56% OF THE CASELOAD --
THE FAMILIES THAT WILL BE --
FURTHEST AWAY FROM 50% OF
FEDERAL POPULAR EVER AFTER THIS
THIRTEEN POINT 1% INCREASE ARE
THOSE THAT ARE SYSTEM YOU UNITS
OF SIZE OF ONE AND THAT'S ABOUT
2627% OF OUR CASELOAD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE ADDITION TO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
NO SIR STILL ON THE SHOW.
ONE SAID THE I THINK THE ONLY
OTHER QUESTION WE WANT TO GET
THROUGH THE GENDER BUT WE WANT.
TO ONE THANK YOU.
I THINK THE OTHER QUESTION THAT
YOU ASKED RELATED -- TO CASELOAD
IN PACKS -- WITH A CONCENTRATION
OF CASES WITHOUT AN EIGHT EIGHT
ADULTS SO IN.
EXCLUDING SANCTION CASELY AT
CASES THAT AGAIN IS THIS THE
ASSISTANCE UNIT SIZE OF ONE
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF THE
ASSISTANT UNIT SIZE OF ONE OR
21% OF THE OVERALL CASE LOAD OUR
CASES ABOUT NEEDED ADULT.
SO I THINK THAT ANSWERS THE
I THINK AFTER HERE FOR MR HELD
THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER
QUESTIONS.
BUT FOR NOW -- PLEASE MR HELD UP.
PARDON ME MADAM CHAIR THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM A LA OFFERS --
MY NAME IS MIKE CAROLYN THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT.
ON THE CONVERSE RAN CREASES --
MISTER AS LANEY AND WHO'S THE
OTHER WITNESS ON THIS IS GOING
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
SOARED ABOUT THE HISTORICAL
NATURE OF THE GRANT LEVELS --
AND HOW THEY HAVE KINDA EBBED
AND FLOWED WITH -- OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL AND ON YOU KNOW IN
TIMES OF RECESSION WE'VE HAD TO
DECREASE THEM -- AND OBVIOUSLY
IN THE PAST WE HAD GRANT LEVELS
OR MUCH HIGHER MUCH CLOSER TO
THEIR ACTUAL NEEDS OF OUR
CLIENTS SO THEY'LL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT IN A
MOMENT.
I'M MY COMMENTS THE WERE REALLY
GOING TO FOCUS MORE ON THE
STRUCTURE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND FIRST AT THE OUTSET --
I THINK -- WE JUST WANT TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE
ENORMOUS PROGRESS THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE MAKING ON
GRANTS I MEAN TWO DAYS AGO WE
INCREASE GRANTS BY 10% I'VE BEEN
IN THIS JOB I BELIEVE FIFTEEN
YEARS.
IT'S THE SINGLE LARGEST GRAN
INCREASE.
ABOUT I'VE EVER WITNESSED --
IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL IT WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS TO
GROUP OF CAL WORKS -- STUDENT
PARENTS A FEW WEEKS AGO AND THEY
WERE ECSTATIC WHEN I TOLD
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GETTING
GRANT INCREASES SO THISIS A
VERY IMPORTANT THING FOR
RECIPIENTS.
AND GOVERNOR NEW SOME IN HIS
FIRST BUDGET CAME OUT IN. TO GET
EVEN OF A BIG STEP FURTHER
INCREASING THE GRANTS PROPOSING
ANOTHER THIRTEEN POINT 1%
INCREASE IN THE GRANTS THAT
WOULD BEGIN THIS OCTOBER.
AND SO -- I YOU KNOW WE MADE AN
AGREEMENT ALL OF US LAST YEAR IN
THE BUDGET THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO IN DEEP POVERTY IN THE
CALLER'S PROGRAM.
AND IT WAS REALLY GREAT TO SEE
THE GOVERNOR KEEPING THAT
COMMITMENT -- AND SO WE WANT TO
JUST PUT THAT OUT ON THE TABLE
IS THAT WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET IS
A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD AND
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT REALLY
APPRECIATE -- THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS IN THIS REGARD -- WE
HOWEVER WE ALSO WOULD RECOMMEND
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE
RECONSIDER EXACTLY HOW WE
PROVIDE THIS THIS GRANT AMOUNT
WE IT'S US RATHER SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND THE WAY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TO DO IT IS TO
ESSENTIALLY DO THE WAY WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE GRAN INCREASES WHICH
IS TO DO IT ON ACROSS THE BOARD
THIRTEEN POINT 1% INCREASE. FOR
EACH OF THE HOUSEHOLD SIZE IS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE COLLEGE
PROGRAM -- AND ALL OF THOSE
FAMILIES NEED INCREASES THERE'S
NO QUESTION ABOUT IT THEY COULD
ALL USE ALL THIRTEEN POINT 1% OF
IT.
BUT WHEN WE ASSESS THE VARIOUS
NEEDS OF OUR FAMILIES WHAT WE
SEE IS A VERY LARGE GAP.
BETWEEN -- WHAT WE CALL A ONE
PERSON CAL WORKS HOUSEHOLD AND
THE TWO PERSON GRANT LEVEL --
IT'S IT'S A A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF ALMOST TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLAR DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A ONE
PERSON GRANT AND A TWO PERSON
GRANT.
BUT THE NOTION OF A ONE PERSON
GRANT IS REALLY KIND OF A
FICTION -- THERE ARE NO ONE
PERSON GRANTS THEY'RE ALL TO
PARENT THEY'RE ALL TWO PERSON
HOUSEHOLD THAT MINIMUM BECAUSE
WHAT ONE PERSON GRAN IS IS
ESSENTIALLY -- OF A CHILD ONLY
CASE WHERE WE HAVE ONE CHILD
ELIGIBLE IN THE HOUSEHOLD BUT WE
ALSO HAVE AN ADULT AT LEAST ONE
ADULT IN THAT HOUSEHOLD.
SO WE WOULD REALLY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE AN APPROACH THAT WOULD
TRY TO RAISE ALL GRANT LEVELS I
THINK THE ONLY -- MADE THIS
RECOMMENDATION IN THEIR IN THEIR
REPORT REYES ALL GRANT LEVELS UP
2408% ACROSS THE BOARD SO THAT
ALL THE GRANTS WE DISTRIBUTE THE
MONEY IN A WAY THAT WOULD GET
ALL THE VARIOUS HOUSEHOLD LEVELS
UP 240%.
INCLUDING THAT ONE SO CALL ONE
PERSON HOUSEHOLD SO THAT WE
REALLY GIVE A SUBSTANTIAL BUMP
TO THAT HOUSEHOLD INCOME BECAUSE
WE REALLY FEEL THAT.
I THINK IT UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I I COULD BE WRONG
SLIGHTLY ON THIS I THINK IT'S
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
DOLLARS A MONTH IS WHAT THAT
INCREASE WOULD GO.
TO THAT'S JUST IT'S IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A FAMILY A TWO
PERSON FAMILY TO BE ABLE TO
EXIST AND RENT HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AT SUCH A LOW GROUND
LEVEL.
I MEAN THE GOOD THE GRANT
INCREASE STILL WON'T GET US TO
THE PLACE THAT WE NEED TO BE BUT
I THINK WE WOULD STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THE REDISTRIBUTION
THAT WAS SUGGESTED BY THE LA L..
THAT WOULD MAKE THE GRANT LEVELS
HIGHER.
FOR MAKING EQUAL FOR ALL
CASELOAD SIZES HOUSEHOLD SIZE
AND THEN -- EXPRESSLY LIFT THE
AMOUNT THAT WOULD GO TO THE ONE
PERSON HOUSEHOLDS SO THAT'S OUR
PROPOSAL AND WE ALSO -- WOULD
CERTAINLY -- SUPPORT OF FURTHER
AUGMENTATION OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET -- TO BE ABLE TO GO EVEN
HIGHER BECAUSE AS GOOD AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS IT'S NOT
QUITE WHAT WE AGREED TO LAST
YEAR -- ON A BUDGET YOU'RE BASIS
I BELIEVE IT WOULD REQUIRE AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT OF ABOUT
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ACTUALLY GET US TO GO 250% --
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER A
FULL YEAR BUDGET FOR TWO IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THAT WAS
THE COMMITMENT THAT WE ALL GREE
TO LAST YEAR AND WHILE THE
THIRTEEN POINT 1% INCREASE IS
SUBSTANTIAL AND GOOD.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT SHORT OF
WHERE WE WERE HOPING TO GET IN
THIS BUDGET YEAR SO AGAIN WE
WOULD RECOMMEND TRYING TO HAVE.
TO LOOK AT HAVING WELL A
SLIGHTLY LARGER -- AUGMENTATION
AN INCREASE IN THE GRANT LEVELS
IN THIS BUDGET YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER HERALD AND
WHILE -- KEVIN A SLANEY IN -- IS
COMING UP.
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE ROLE FOR
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLACE?
MISS RAY IS HERE MISTER FRAZIER.
MR MATHIS MISTER PATTERSON.
MR RAMEAU'S.
MISS RUBIO.
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
QUORUM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR THE
THERE ARE SOME RESPECTIVE THANK
YOU MY NAME'S KEVIN AS THE NEW
THANKS FOR INVITING ME.
YOU SHOULD OPPORTUNITY.
I REPRESENT THE COLDEST OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
REPRESENTING BOTH OF YOU SIT
BINS.
SINCE THE PREVIOUS CENTURY OF
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND ONGOING.
THE FACT I WAS AROUND IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE OKAY A FDC
WE GOT A COST OF LIVING INCREASE
AND THE AND THE AND THE
LEGISLATION.
AND THE COOK AND WE GOT A COLA.
SINCE THEN FOR THE PAST TWO
CENTURIES -- ARC OF BENEFITS
HAVE BEEN UNDER ATTACK.
WE WERE ATTACKED I HAVE A TABLE
ONE OVER HERE THAT SHOWS.
THAT THE FIRST ATTACK CAME IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND EIGHTY ONE
WHEN JERRY BROWN BECAME GOVERNOR
HE WE JUST UP BENEFITS BY TWO
POINT 1%.
THEN IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO IT
WAS SO WITH THOSE THE BY FIVE
POINT 8%.
THEN AGAIN TWO POINT 7%. EIGHT
POINT 9%.
AND THEIR SCHWARZENEGGER REDUCE
THAT BY 4% AND FINALLY WIPED OUT
THE COLDER.
AND WHEN JERRY BROWN CAME IN.
HE WITH THOSE THAT AGAIN BY 8%
AGAIN.
AND THE PAST TWO THREE YEARS
WE'VE GOTTEN MAYBE 20% 225% BACK
SOMETHING LIKE THAT -- BIT.
THE AVERAGE CAL WORKS GRANT
TODAY. FOR A FAMILY OF THREE IS
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT A MONTH AND
WHEN I SAY TODAY I MEAN MARCH.
BECAUSE IN A POLL.
ED AND THAT'S REPRESENTS 32% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. FOR
THE AVERAGE CAL WORKS FAMILY.
IN A POOR ONE AND ONE UP 235% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
IN OCTOBER WANT THE NEW SIM
INCREASE GOES INTO EFFECT.
AND THAT BRINGS IT UP 238% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
SO WE STILL ARE WAY BELOW THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THE NEXT ROOM TABLE.
TWENTY SHOWS.
THE IMPACT OF THE MITCHELL
INCREASE AND THE NEW SIM
INCREASE.
THEN WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA TWO
REGIONS.
OF REGION ONE WOULD BE LIKE LOS
ANGELES AMPS THIS GOAL.
A SANTA CLARA DOES OF THE
EIGHTEEN COUNTIES THE REST OF
THE COMES ON REGION.
IN REGION.
ONE THIS.
THREE THE THREE CATEGORIES OF
FAMILIES THAT GO OVER THE 50%.
TWO THREE FOUR FIFTY TO FIFTY
ONE AND FIFTY FIFTY ONE THE REST
OF MUST DO UNDER.
THAT EVEN AFTER THE NEW SOME
INCREASE. FOR THE SECOND REGION
WHICH IS FRIENDS THOUGH
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
ONLY FAMILY OF TOOL MAKES THE
ABOVE ABOUT 50% THE REST OF OUR
BE LOWERED.
OUR PROPOSAL BASICALLY IS WHICH
IS TABLE.
FOR IS TO LOOK AT ONE PARENT
FAMILY IN A CHILD.
AND GIVE THEM WHAT THE FEDERAL
PUT 50% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL INPUT TWO PARENT FAMILIES.
IN A CHILD WHAT THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL WOULD BE.
IT WOULD BE BASED ON THE
CHILDREN AND THE PARENTS.
THEN YOU MAY WONDER WHERE WOULD
WE GET THE MONEY FROM.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT TABLE.
FIVE THIS IS THE ILLUSTRATION OF
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING WITH THE
CAL WORKS MONEY. FOR THE PAST.
TWENTY YEAR IS ABOUT THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN TAKEN
AWAY FROM THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM.
AND BEEN TRANSFERRED TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHAT
HAPPENED DOT COM IN THE GREAT
RECESSION EVEN WHEN THE CASE
LOAD WHEN UP.
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WAS
TAKEN AWAY FROM THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM.
THEY GIVE IT TO THE GENERAL FUND
STAY THE SAME.
SO THIS YEAR.
THE BUT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IS.
THAT BUFFY FIVE BILLION. FIVE
POINT ONE BILLION WOULD BE
USEFUL CAL WORKS TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION WOULD BE USED FOR OTHER
PURPOSES.
LIKE -- WHICH IS RELIEF TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS AT LEAST
A BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT YOU COULD FIND IN AND TABLE.
ONE THAT COULD BE USED -- TO TO
PROMULGATE.
TABLE.
FOUR AND IF THERE IS MONEY LEFT
OVER.
IN THIS PROGRAM AND AND AND THE
PROGRAM BETTER THAN GIVING UP
THE GENERAL FUND THE SHIP IN THE
RESERVE WHICH IS A SUBSEQUENT
ISSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
TYLER WOODS HAS NOTHING.
FINANCE AND NOTHING IN COMMON
NOT THIS TIME VERY GOOD -- LET'S
ELIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAZZ ALMA WITH
ALLEGE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M.
IN THINKING ABOUT THE DECISION
BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR.
IN OUR VIEW IT'S IT'S REALLY
ABOUT RECONCILING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THE MULTI YEAR PLAN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED LAST BUDGET --
FOR CAL WORKS GRANT INCREASES --
ULTIMATELY AND ARGUE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS A IS
CLEARLY CONSISTENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S SORT OF OVERALL
PLAN FOR OUR SPRING CREASES IT
IS A STEP IN THE IN THE SAME
DIRECTION.
BUT THERE ARE A FEW.
KEY DIFFERENCES ARM FIRST AND
FOREMOST -- THE LEGISLATURE'S
pPLAN ULTIMATELY WOULD ALSO
INCREASE GRANTS 250% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL BUT WOULD
DO SO. FOR A FAMILY SIZED THAT
IS ONE PERSON LARGER.
THAN THE THE COLORS ASSISTANCE
UNIT SIZE WE USE ASSISTANCE UNIT
TO DESCRIBE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE.
AND AND THIS IS A BY PRODUCT OF
THE REALIZATION OR THE REALITY
THAT.
IN MORE THAN HALF OF CAL WORKS
CASES THERE ISN'T AN ADULT IN
THE FAMILY WHO IS INELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE A SO IF YOU SET.
GRANT SAT 50% OF THE FPL AND
MORE THAN HALF OF CASES -- THE
FAMILY ITSELF -- WOULD WOULD BE
BELOW 50% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
I'M ANOTHER KEY DISTINCTION IS
THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN IS A
MULTI YEAR PLANS.
ARE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED A
GRAND INCREASE FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN AS
ADOPTED LAST YEAR WOULD HAVE
SORT OF A FINAL GRANT INCREASE --
TO TAKE PLACE IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SOME.
AND SO AND THINKING ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PLAN IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN OUR VIEW.
WE RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER WHAT WANT TO DO FIRST --
ONE OPTION IS TO CONTINUE THE
ACROSS THE BOARD APPROACH AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BY
INCREASING GRANTS BY THE SAME
AMOUNT.
ON ANOTHER OPTION IS TO TO TO
FOLLOW SORT OF THE THE INITIAL
STEP OF THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN
WHICH WOULD INCREASE GRANTS BY
VARYING AMOUNTS AND AND MR
HERALD REFERENCE TO THIS.
SPECIFICALLY THESE GRANT AMOUNTS
FOR THE SMALLEST A FEW SIZES
WOULD BE INCREASED BY A LARGER
PERCENTAGE AMOUNT THAN THAT FOR
OTHER GRANTS SOARED. TO BRING
GRANT LEVELS FOR ALL A U. SIZES
TO THE SAME -- PERCENTAGE OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL -- IN
THINKING ABOUT.
THIS OPTION WE POINTED OUT A
COUPLE ALTERNATIVES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER ONE OF
WHICH WAS THE THE ALTERNATIVE
THAT MR HERALD MENTIONED -- BUT
WE WOULD NOTE THERE REALLY ARE
MULTIPLE PASS FORWARD FOR THE
SUB COMMITTEE AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IT MAY NOT BE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE SPECIFICALLY
POINTED OUT -- ONE OPTION IS TO
SIMPLY CONTINUE ON THE PATH AS
IT WAS OUTLINED.
IN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT BY REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND CONTINUE IN THAT
DIRECTION.
ALTERNATIVELY YOU COULD WORK
WITH IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AMOUNTS BUT DISTRIBUTE RANTS
DIFFERENTLY AS MR HERALD
MENTIONED OR PURSUE SOMETHING --
SORT OF A COMBINATION WHERE --
ADDRESSING HOT SORT OF GRANT
AMOUNTS FOR EACH A YOU SIZE IS
NOT NECESSARILY 2408% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL BUT 250%
WERE A BUS ON THE REALLY IS A
GREAT DEAL OF FLEXIBILITY -- AT
FOUR FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MY MINISTRATION.
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION -- CAN
YOU TELL US WHAT THE REACTION IS
TO THE 55% OF A USE THAT WERE
ADULT.
IS UNAIDED AND THE CON AND THE
CONSTRUCT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HER WORDS I AT THIS TIME
I THINK OUR REACTION IS THAT.
IN THE CONTEXT OF A NATIVE
ADULTS IN THE HOUSEHOLD THAT'S A
CONSTRUCT OF ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND HI ANY
DISCUSSIONS AROUND UNAIDED
ADULTS -- SHOULD ALSO BE MARRIED
WITH A DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA ARE FOR THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM AND CURRENTLY
WITH THE THIRTEEN POINT 1% GRANT
INCREASE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THAT'S ADDRESSING A GRAND
INCREASE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY CONSIDERED ELIGIBLE
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE.
CAL WORKS CLIENTS IN THAT
HOUSEHOLD.
THE A YOU IN ONE WITH ONE CHILD
REASONABLY AND ON A DID ADULTS
HAS A FURTHER.
HAS FOR THIS TO GO AND I THINK
THAT WAS DISCUSSED -- EARLIER
AND I THINK THAT -- MISTER
HURLED TALKED ABOUT BRINGING
EVERYBODY UP AS PROPOSED BY THE
LA -- TO THE 48%.
OF THE POVERTY LEVEL.
EVEN WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THIS TO BRINGING OUR CHILDREN UP.
TO THE 48% OF FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL I KNOW THAT THAT THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND THAT IS
WHAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
HOW CAN WE FIX THIS? TO ASSURE
THAT NO CHILD IS DISADVANTAGED
IN THIS AREA IN THIS THIS EFFORT.
AND TO BRING CHILDREN. TO BRING
EVERY CHILD OUT OF DEEP POVERTY.
WOULD ONE OF YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS
THAT.
THAT HAS OUR AGAIN THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT APPROACH WAS WHAT
WAS EMBODIED AND DISCUSSED AS
PART OF THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED IN TRAILER
BILL THE MULTI YEAR APPROACH --
UNDER -- THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN
TO INCREASE GRANTS 250% OF THE
FPL AT A MINIMUM -- FOR ALL AGES
SIZES.
ACCOUNTING FOR A USE THAT MIGHT
HAPPEN UNAIDED ADULT ON AND SO
THAT WAS THE THE THE MOTIVATION
AND THE AND THE THE AIM OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S PLAN AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO GET
US TO THE TO THE 50%.
I JUST -- JUST AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I I RECOGNIZE WERE
TRYING TO WORK WITH FINITE
NUMBERS.
BUT THAT IS.
OF OF SERIOUS CONCERN YES MISS
REVIEW WOULD JUST HAVE A COMMENT
AND I THERE'S A ON PAGE TWELVE
THERE'S A CHART.
THAT SAYS IN A AYE -- A YOU SIZE --
ONE IS THAT 43%.
AND SO I THOUGHT THAT THE INTENT
WAS TO BRING THEM UP.
TO FORTY EIGHT OR AT LEAST 50%
BY.
THE A YOU ONE IS 43% ARE WE
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE.
SO IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
THIRTEEN POINT 1% WAS CONSISTENT
WITH AN ACROSS THE BOARD
INCREASE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
DID TARGET THAT INCREASED
TOWARDS -- A MAJORITY OF THE
CASES THAT FALL IN A YOU OF TWO
AND THEN A YOU OF THREE NOT.
SO WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE U.
ONES IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THEY
DID RECEIVE A THIRTEEN POINT 1%
GRANT INCREASE RIGHT YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT IT DOES NOT BRING
IT UP 250% FOR RIGHT AND SOUL IS
THERE AN INTENTION.
TO FIX THAT BECAUSE 43% IS NOT.
I EVEN IF YOU DO ANOTHER 13% OR
WHATEVER IT IS ACROSS THE BOARD
IT'S GOING TO TAKE AWHILE TO
BRING THAT EIGHTY ONE BACK UP TO
FORTY EIGHT OR 50%.
AND SO THERE IS IS THERE A PLAN
TO ADDRESS THAT SPECIFICALLY.
I'D I WOULD SAY AT THIS TIME.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WAS TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE ALL OF HIS
PRIORITIES WERE AND TO GIVE.
US THE BOARD FOR YES OR NO.
THERE'S NOTHING CURRENTLY
PROPOSED STAND ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THAT OKAY SO IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT WE COULD DO OR
WHAT CONVERSATION SHOULD WE BE
HAVING WITH YOU OR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIX THAT
BECAUSE AGAIN IT SOUNDS GREAT.
THAT WE'RE BRINGING YOU KNOW 13%
ACROSS THE BOARD.
WE DID GREAT THINGS WHICH IS
GREAT FOR THE REST.
I MEAN IT'S STILL NOT EVEN
ENOUGH BY.
ELLIE SAID SOMETHING BITES FOR
THESE FOLKS IN PARTICULAR IT'S
43%.
AND SOUL.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY IS STATE
AIDS -- THESE ARE CHILDREN
CLEARLY THAT.
IF IT'S IN A YOU ONE THAT MEANS
IT'S THE TILE THAT'S RECEIVING
THE 42%.
BECAUSE THE PARENT IS MOST
LIKELY NOT.
PART OF THE GRANT SO WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS.
THAT A YOU ONE IS A CHILD.
THAT WE SAID 43% IS GOOD ENOUGH.
SO IN THE IN THE CONTEXT OF
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AS BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS PLAY OUT AS MR
HERALD AND MISTER ALMA NOTED
THERE'S A NUMBER OF WAYS THAT
YOU CAN PROVIDE A GRANT INCREASE --
BUT IT'S ALL IN THE CONTACT IS
ABOUT THE NEGATIVE OF OF LIMITED
RESOURCES THE WAY I'D LIKE TO
YOU KNOW I MEAN IF WE COULD DO
TRADE YOU KNOW JUST WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT IF WE COULD DO TRAILER
BILLS.
FOR YOUR NAME AND HOW MANY
TRAILER BURIALS WE'VE DONE IT
THIS IN PARTICULAR AGAIN AND
JUST -- MY CONCERN AS I SHARE
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY IS
AND I'M SURE THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE IS THE E. U. ONES WE
KNOW SPECIFICALLY THAT THERE THE
CHILDREN.
I MEAN I I UNLESS THERE'S A
DOUBT THAT THAT THE A YOU ONCE
OUR CHILDREN.
RIGHT AND SO WE'RE KIND OF DOING
IT.
NOT BACKWARDS BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE BUT THIRTEEN POINT 1%
BUT WE KNOW THAT THE THE A. YOU
ONE IS A CHILD.
AND SO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE BALANCE THAT
BECAUSE IT'S SPECIFICALLY FOR
CHILDREN AND SO.
I WOULD LIKE.
THIS IS A TIME FOR THE
DISCUSSION I GUESS WE CAN PUSH
IT ON TO YOU KNOW LET'S TALK IN
MY OFFICE OR LET'S WORK ON THIS
LEADER.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HAVING THIS
HEARING SO THAT WE COULD FIGURE
OUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
ON YOUR END AND ON OUR END AND
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THAT 13%
THAT'S GREAT BY.
AS A MOM IS A FORMER TEACHER I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THESE ARE
CHILDREN.
THE 42% AS A CHILD AND SO HOW DO
WE RECONCILE.
DIED WERE AT 42% FOR A CHILD
KNOWING THAT THERE'S TWO PEOPLE
IN THE HOUSEHOLD.
AND HOW DO WE RECONCILE THAT
WITH WITH YOU KNOW OUR GOAL IS --
TO TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN AND TO
BRING CHILDREN OUT OF THE
POVERTY I MEAN I HEAR THAT ALL
THE TIME WHICH IS A GREAT AND
NOBLE.
COMMENT BY THE CHART SHOWS
OTHERWISE.
SO I NEED YOUR HELP CAN WE HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION HERE.
CERTAINLY OKAY.
AND I THINK WHAT SHOULD BE NOTED
AS MS JOHNSON SAID IS WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A U..
S..
ONE THAT'S 26% OF ALL CHILDREN.
WAS THAT CORRECT.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF CHILDREN
THAT FALL UNDER THIS CATEGORY.
WHO REMAINED IN DEEP POVERTY --
I KNOW THE LA -- HAS IN THE
PROPOSAL TALKED ABOUT INCREASING
THE PERCENTAGE AND USING SOME OF
CASH AND FINDING OTHER WAYS AND
PERHAPS.
THAT IS -- PART OF WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO TO DO MR HELL DID YOU
HAVE A COMMENT YOU'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVIEW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR REFERENCING THE
CHART ON PAGE TWELVE I THINK.
THE NUMBER THAT YOU'RE
IDENTIFIED I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT THIS WHAT THIS REALLY IS A
REFLECTION OF IS A HISTORICAL
INEQUITY THAT HAVE BEEN BEEN
BUILT IN THE GRANT LEVELS FOR
DECADES.
THAT WAS A CHOICE THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY MADE BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND APPROVED PRIOR
LEGISLATURE PRIOR GOVERNOR AND
IT'S A CHOICE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THIS GOVERNOR CAN
CHOOSE TO FIX.
AND SO I THAT'S WHY WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT WE DO ADOPT
LANGUAGE WITHIN THIS BUDGET THAT
WOULD ALLOCATE THE AMOUNT THE
GOVERNOR PROVIDES OR IF WE CAN
GET AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT.
THAT WOULD GO TO MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE IS AT THE SAME
LEVEL OF THE POVERTY LEVEL AND
WE DON'T CONTINUE THIS
HISTORICAL INEQUITY THAT WE SEE
FOR THESE SINGLE TRIAL
HOUSEHOLDS.
THANK YOU AND THE POINT THAT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE IS IS EXACTLY
THAT.
THAT WE HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
THAT WE DON'T PAT OURSELVES ON
THE BACK -- AGAIN IT'S REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT WE HAVE 13% BUT
IT REALLY ISN'T YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT GOOD ENOUGH AND IN THAT TIME
WHEN WERE BOASTING ABOUT THE THE
THE AXIS AND REVENUES.
IF YOU ARE THE OVER BUDGET OR
WHATEVER BOTH THE WORD WE CHOOSE
TO USE.
JUST.
I CAN TALK IN PERCENTAGES BUT IT
WILL HIT HOME BETTER THAN.
THEY RECEIVE SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE DOLLARS A
YEAR.
I I MEAN SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE DOLLARS A
YEAR.
THAT'S I I DON'T KNOW WHO CAN
LIVE OFF OF THAT.
AND SO THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE IS THAT YES WE CAN CHOOSE
TO FIX IT BY BECAUSE WE'VE
ALREADY SAID HOW GREAT WE ARE
BECAUSE WE'VE INCREASE THAT
THIRTEEN POINT 1% I DON'T WANT
THIS.
YOU KNOW IF WE DECIDE AT SOME
POINT TO PUT THIS IN SOME KIND
OF A EITHER TRAILER BILL OR FOR
US TO DECIDE THAT THIS IS GOING
TO INCREASE FOR US NOT TO SAY
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE THIRTEEN
POINT 1%.
LET US JUST CONTINUE INTO THIS
NEXT YEAR AND SO I NEED YOUR
HELP. TO FIGURE OUT HOW WHAT
LANGUAGE OR WHAT IN WHAT CONTEXT
WE PUT THIS IN SO THAT.
WE THESE PEOPLE DOT ORG THESE
CHILDREN.
DON'T RECEIVE ONLY SIX THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
DOLLARS A YEAR.
I MEAN THAT'S YOU KNOW FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT -- DRINK STARBUCKS
IT'S YOU KNOW TWO HUNDRED IF YOU
DRINK STARBUCKS EVERY DAY IT'S A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAT YOU SPEND ON STARBUCKS AND
YOU KNOW JUST.
I DON'T WANT -- TO KEEP THE
LABORING THE POINT BY IF WE
DECIDE TO FIX THIS.
SAYING THAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE
THIRTEEN PORTS PERCENT ACROSS
THE BOARD I DON'T WANT THAT TO
BE A REASON NOT TO HELP US
FIGURE HOW WE CAN INCREASE THIS.
TO THE 50% OR THE 40% LEVEL.
THANK YOU.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PERFECTLY WILLING TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE RECOGNIZING
THAT AS A PRIORITY.
THANK YOU MS REVIEW THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWO SOME TATIAN.
UPDATE ON CAL WORKS OUT COMES IN
ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
SAFETY NET RESERVE FUND
INCLUDING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WITH ASSOCIATED ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AND AND STAFF APOLOGIES
FOR THE EARLIER FALL START --
THAT'S ALL RIGHT WE'RE ON TRACK
NOW.
YES MY NAME'S A TOPIC ON THE NEW
CAL WORKS IN CHILD CARE BRANCH
CHIEF IT CDSS I'D FIRST LIKE TO
NOTE IN THANK YOU FOR THE
CONFERENCE OVERVIEW OF CAL OR IN
THE AGENDA ON PAGES TWENTY ONE
THREE TWENTY THREE TO THAT I
JUST WANTED TO ADD A BIT.
OF ADDITIONAL COMMENTARY FIRST
HIGHLIGHTING THAT COW OR IS A
NEW AND DISTINCT MOVE AWAY FROM
HOME AN OLD WORK FIRST MENTALITY
IN AN HISTORIC EMPHASIS ON W. P.
R. WHICH IS THE SINGULAR FEDERAL.
MEASURE WHICH IS A POOR PROXY IT
BEST IN A PERVERSE INCENTIVE AT
WORST -- THE PREVIOUSLY DROVE
DECISION MAKING FOR CAL WORKS
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION.
CAL OR REPRESENTS A CRITICAL
PATH FORWARD FOR THE STATE TO
STAND BY A MESSAGE OF ENGAGEMENT.
pAND INTENTIONALITY IN SERVICE
PROVISION.
HUNDREDS OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THE STATE'S COUNTY
PARTNER AGENCIES ADVOCATES AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN WORK FOR OVER EIGHTEEN MONTHS
IN MORE THAN FIFTY MEETINGS TO
CRAFT A FRAMEWORK FOR THE CAL OR
CULTURE SHIFT.
REPRESENTING A MOVE TOWARDS
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
IN A REAL MODEL MODEL FOR DATA
DRIVEN PROGRAM MANAGEMENT.
THE STATE AND STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD TO DEFINE AND
DEVISE THE THREE COMPONENT PARTS
OF CAL OR AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT.
THEIR NEARLY FINALIZED IN
PREPARATION FOR LAUNCH JULY OF
TWENTY NINETEEN WITH AN ON RAMP
TO FULL IMPLEMENTATION BY THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY PART ONE
OF CAL OR IS A SET OF TWENTY
SEVEN PROCESS SHORT TERM MEDIUM
TERM LONG TERM METRICS THAT
REFLECT THE COW WORKS PROGRAM
LOGIC MODEL.
PART TWO IS A COUNTY SELF
ASSESSMENT WHICH PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COUNTIES TO
REALLY DIG INTO THE METRICS AND
REFLECT ON AND GATHER LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS FOR CONVERSATION
WHILE INCORPORATING ADDITIONAL
KLEIN FEEDBACK THROUGH A NEW
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION SURVEY.
ALLOWING LOCAL NUANCE PROGRAM
DESIGN AND INNOVATION TO DRIVE
THE SPIRIT OF CONTINUOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT AND PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT.
PART THREE IS A SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN TO CAPTURE
COUNTY GOALS FOR INNOVATION
TWEAKS AND STRATEGIES TO BETTER
SERVE THE CALL WORKS RECIPIENTS.
COUNTIES WILL CONNECT WITH OTHER
COUNTIES REPEAL YOUR SUPPORT AND
REVIEW -- OF SYSTEM IMPROVEMENT
PLANS IN THE STABLE PARTNER WITH
THE COUNTY THROUGHOUT ALL THREE
STEPS IN THIS PROCESS TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT.
COLOR SET TO LAUNCH AS I NOTED
JULY TWENTY NINETEEN WITH THE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA
DASHBOARD.
INFORMATION AVAILABLE IN THOSE
DASHBOARDS WILL BE UPDATED WITH
NEW METRICSIN PHASES AS THEY
BECOME AVAILABLE AND THEN ON A
REGULAR ROLLING BASIS MONTHLY IN.
WE'RE WORKING WITH YOU TO BE A
IN THE CONSORTIA AND OUTSIDE
PARTNERS TO TACKLE DATA
LIMITATIONS AND TO GENERALLY
CREATE A WHOLE NEW DATA DRIVEN
PROCESS FROM THE GROUND UP.
THE FIRST COUNTY CSA'S WILL BE
DRAFTED BY SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE FIRST SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENT PLANS WILL BE
DRAFTED -- BY THE WINTER OF
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOLLOWING THAT
OVERVIEW I'M HAPPY TO MOVE ON TO
RESPONSES TO THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO WITH REGARDS TO CAL
WORKS TWO POINT NO AND LIKE TO
KNOW THE CALORIES TWO POINT OH
IS AN INITIATIVE LED BY THE
COUNTIES.
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT
AND THIS APPROACH STATEWIDE IN
THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES
IT'S TOO
EARLY TO DEFINITIVELY CODIFIED
THE APPROACH IN STATUTE BUT IS
VERY INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO
LEARN ABOUT THE IMPACT
.
OF CASE TYPES WITH APPROPRIATE
FUNDING.
FOLLOWING CASE MANAGEMENT THE
DEPARTMENT STAKEHOLDER
STAKEHOLDERS WILL REVIEW THE
SERVICES PORTION OF THE
METHODOLOGY TO DETERMINE WHAT
ADDITIONAL ADJUSTMENTS MIGHT BE
NEEDED.
AND I'D LIKE TO HAND OVER TO MY
PARTNERS OF FINANCE STIR WHAT'S
SURE -- FOR THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE QUESTION THAT'S IN YOUR
AGENDA I THINK MR SO JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT.
THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE TO
THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE --
ARE NOT.
REDIRECTING THE INTENT OF
PUTTING OUT FUNDING TOWARDS MEDI
CAL AND HOWARD SPECIFICALLY.
HI THIS IS SIMPLY AN ATTEMPT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE CALLING THE
SAN OF THAT.
THE CAL WORKS IN MEDICAL
PROGRAMS CAN CHANGE OVER TIME --
THE CASELOADS THE VARYING LEVELS
SERVICES.
AND PUTTING IN PLACE A
METHODOLOGY -- FOR FUNDING IN
AND OUT OF THAT RESERVE FIND.
MIGHT BE.
TYING OUR HANDS TO SOME EXTENT
AT LEAST FOR WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
HAVING FLEXIBILITY DURING A
DOWNTURN TO USE THOSE FUNDS.
AND AGAIN JUST SO I REITERATE
THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE STILL
INTENDED TO GO TO THE TWO
PROGRAMS AS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN
SOME FIFTEEN YEARS EARLIER.
IT IS A FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE POINTED OUT
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST CHANGE IN
THE WAY WE DO ELFARE TO WORK.
SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
COWARDS PROGRAM.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
CLEARLY ARTICULATED WOULD WE
WANTED OUT OF IT HOW WE ARE WHAT
WE REALLY MEASURED WAS A FEDERAL
WORK PARTICIPATION RATE THAT WE
ALL KNEW WAS FLAWED.
I'M AND WE DIDN'T.
TRACK THOSE OUTCOMES AND
TRANSPARENTLY PUBLISH THEM AND
ASK COUNTIES TO USE THOSE THE
DATA ON THOSE OUTCOMES. FOR
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
IN THOSE ARE REALLY THE KEY
ELEMENTS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE DISCUSSED -- AND
SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED WITH THE
PROGRESS WE'RE VERY PLEASED AT
THE PARTNERSHIP.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND WITH ADD
ADVOCATES IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK -- MY
COLLEAGUES I TALKED ABOUT THE
MILESTONES THAT WERE REACHING I
CAN TELL YOU -- THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY HEAVY LEFT AND WE'RE
AT THE POINT WHERE THE TOUGH
PART WHICH IS OPERATIONALIZE
SAYING.
SO COLLECTING DATA -- FROM DATA
SYSTEMS THAT WERE NOT BUILT FOR
OUTCOMES MONITORING.
I'M LINKING TO OTHER DATA
SOURCES LIKE EDT THAT HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT PEOPLE WHEN
THEY'RE NO LONGER ON A ROLES --
AND SO THE AMOUNT OF CREATIVITY
AND THOUGHT GOING INTO EXACTLY
HOW TO DO THIS -- HAS BEEN --
REFRESHING AND AND SOMETHING
THAT WERE THAT WERE QUITE
PLEASED ABOUT FROM A BUDGETING
STANDPOINT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION.
ON THE BUDGET ESTIMATES FOR DATA
COLLECTION AND THE COUNTY
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT WORK AND
WE HOPE TO HAVE SOMETHING IN THE
MAY REVISION THAT MEETS
EVERYONE'S.
EXPECTATIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND MADAME TRY DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S NOW IF IF YOU'D LIKE A
BRIEF COMMENT ON THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
THANK YOU -- MIKE MY COLLEAGUES
ALSO DISCUSSED THE EFFORT UNDER
WAY THAT WAS STATUTORILY
REQUIRED. FOR THE COUNTIES IN
THE STATE TO DEVELOP A NEW
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT SEARCH SERVICES
METHODOLOGY. TO YOUR QUESTION IN
THE AGENDA IT HAS BEEN
ILLUMINATED BY THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE IN CAL WORKS TWO
POINT NOW.
SO THE TYPES OF THINGS THAT GO
INTO CASE WORK THE TYPE OF
INTENSITY OF THE CONTACT THAT WE
WANT EMPLOYMENT SERVICES WORKERS
TO HAVE WITH FAMILIES.
HAS BEEN ILLUMINATED BY THE WORK
WE'VE DONE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ON HOW. TO USE THE BEST STATE OF
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE TO HELP
PEOPLE MOVE ON THEIR JOURNEY.
FROM FROM WELFARE TO WORK WE THE
STATE IN THE COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
REMARKABLY ALIGNED AND SORT OF
THE WAY WE'RE THINKING ABOUT --
A NEW METHODOLOGY SHOULD BE
CONSTRUCTED AND WE WE ARE AT THE
POINT WHERE SORT OF THE DEVIL.
IS IN THE DETAILS -- AND WILL
KNOW WITH THOSE DETAILS ARE MORE
I ASSUME IN THE MAY REVISION
COMES OUT -- BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT WE WILL HAVE THE SORT OF
THE THE GUTS OF FOR THE OR THE
LION'S SHARE OF A METHODOLOGY.
THAT FUNDS COUNTIES FOR THE
OUTCOMES THAT YOU WANT OUT OF
THIS PROGRAM WHICH IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE NOW.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE SOME
QUESTIONS LATER BUT IF WE CAN
HAVE MISTER HERALD.
BACKUP.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE WE DON'T HAVE
MORE CHAIRS.
THE SMALL ROOM.
THE SMALL ROOM -- MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN MY CAROL
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY -- SO I I THINK YOU
JUST HEARD A VERY GOOD OVERVIEW
I THINK FROM THE STATE AND FROM
THE COUNTIES ABOUT.
THE THREE MAINISSUE AREAS THAT --
ALL OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
AT THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES MANY MANY MANY MANY
MEETINGS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
REALLY GOING BACK TO THE
BEGINNING OF CALOR -- AND I HAVE
SOME SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT I WANT TO GET TO A FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH I ARE OUTLINED
IN YOUR AGENDA BUT THE BROADER
PICTURE I WANT.
A TO FIRST START OFF WITH IS
THAT ALL THREE OF THESE ISSUES
ARE INTER RELATED.
AM I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO VIEW THESE ISSUES
THAT WAY -- AND I WOULD ALSO
AGREE WITH THE ASSESSMENT OF
BOTH MS NIKOLAI MISTER MECCA
THAT THESE ARE TRANSFORMATIONAL
EFFORTS THAT WERE DOING.
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL CULTURE
SHIFT THAT THE STATE IS ENGAGING
IN RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE WAY THAT
WE MANAGE.
THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM -- AND
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW -- WE WON'T
KNOW THE OUTCOMES FOR THAT FOR A
FEW YEARS BUT FOR THE FIRST TIME
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA HAVE REAL
DATA. FOR YOU FOR THE PUBLIC FOR
OURSELVES THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO DO THESE KIND OF ASSESSMENTS
ABOUT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE COMING FROM
THE STATE BUDGET EVERY YEAR --
SO -- I I I WOULD JUST BUT LET
ME JUST TRY IT THIS WAY BECAUSE
I WAS TRYING TO THINK ABOUT A WE
WAITED WE THIS ALL TOGETHER AND
I'M GOING TO PROBABLY
FUNDAMENTALLY CRASH AND BURN
HERE.
BUT SO IT IN OUR WAY OF THINKING --
BOTH CAN OF TWO POINT NO CAL
WORKS TO POINT KNOWS IT'S BEING
CALLED AND CAL OR OR SORT OF ON
COMPLEMENTARY PIECES -- WE ARE
REALLY TRYING TO INSTITUTE A TWO
GENERATIONAL APPROACH TO ENDING
POVERTY AMONG EXTREMELY POOR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE USING CALOR
PRINCIPALLY AS WELL AS A WAY TO
MEASURE AND TRACK THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'RE DOING IN THAT
ENDEAVOR -- SO IT'S REALLY
ESSENTIAL THAT WE DO THAT BUT
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION FUND IN
OUR JUDGMENT IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISION THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL MAKE THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS MISTER MAC A
REFERENCE HISTORICALLY -- CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES WITHIN THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION SERVICES FUND
HAVE BEEN A FLAT AMOUNT SO FOR
EVERY CASE THAT THE COUNTY GETS.
NO MATTER WHAT THE NEEDS OF THAT
FAMILY THEY GET THE SAME AMOUNT.
AND WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT NOW IS AN APPROACH THAT
WOULD REALLY.
HAVE US PRIORITIZE AND PUT MONEY
TO WHERE WE WANT COUNTIES TO
FOCUS.
SO FAMILIES IN OUR JUDGMENT WITH
THE GREATEST NEEDS FAMILIES WHO
ARE HOMELESS FAMILIES WHO HAVE
FAILED TO KEEP CHILDREN WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES OR
OTHER CHALLENGES -- FAMILIES WHO
ARE FACING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OF
THESE ARE FAMILIES THAT ARE IN
TRAUMA AND CRISIS WHEN THEY COME
IN THE OFFICE OFTEN AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT COUNTIES ARE
INCENTIVIZE FINANCIALLY TO
REALLY ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS
RIGHT UP FRONT.
I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO THINK WHEN WE SEE
THE MAY BE REVISED PROPOSALS
ABOUT WHAT THE PRIORITIES ARE
ADDITION TO THAT THAT WE WANT.
TO WE WANT TO FOCUS ON AND FOR
US AS WE DISCUSS IN MANY FORMS
WE REALLY BELIEVE IN EDUCATION
WE REALLY WANT TO SEE FAMILIES
ENCOURAGED TO GO TO EDUCATION.
SO WE WOULDN'T AND ENCOURAGING
AGAIN A CASE MANAGEMENT FEE THAT
WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE COUNTIES
TO GO TOWARDS EDUCATION -- STE
SO AND THEN AT THE BOTTOM INTO
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW WE MIGHT
NOT WANT TO ENCOURAGE WITH A
LARGE CASE MANAGEMENT FEE.
THE CONVICTED THERE THE OLD
APPROACH THAT WE'VE HAD OF WORK
FIRST WHICH IS SIMPLY GO THROUGH
THE THE JOB CLUB TRY TO GET A
JOB RIGHT AWAY -- AND HOPEFULLY
WORK YOURSELF UP PARTY WE THINK
THAT THAT MODEL HAS RUN ITS
COURSE SO THAT'S WHAT I'D LIKE
YOU TO SEE THAT THERE'S A
POTENTIAL RANGE THERE OF OPTIONS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION IN MANY WAYS IS GOING
TO DRIVE THE OUTCOMES THAT WE
WILL GET THROUGH CALOR AND THE
SUCCESS THAT WE CAN GET FROM PAN
OF TWO POINT NO.
SO I WOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE THAT
APART I MEAN THE LEGISLATURE TO
PUT A HEAVY FOCUS ON THAT WHEN
WE COME TO MAY REVISE -- ONE OR
TWO ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT I
WOULD JUST SAY -- ON TEN OF TWO
POINT NO -- WELL I THINK THE
DILEMMA THAT WE FACE RIGHT NOW
IS -- IS THAT THE THE STATUTE
CONTINUES TO READ AS A WORK
FIRST MODEL IT'S A VERY RIGID
APPROACH.
I'M I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE
SHOULD MAKE SOME.
CHANGES TO THE STATUTES WITHIN
THIS EXISTING BUDGET I THINK
THAT WOULD TAKE A GREAT DEAL OF
FOUGHT AN EXAMINATION FOR US TO
MAKE THOSE KIND OF CHANGES.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO BE
SENDING A SIGNAL.
THAT WE ARE CHANGING.
AND SO WE COULD DO THAT I THINK
THROUGH SOME INTENT LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT AND I
THINK THEN WE COULD FOLLOW THAT
UP BY HAVING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CREATE A
STAKEHOLDER WORK PROCESS. TO
LOOK AT HOW COULD WE AND SHOULD
WE CHANGE THE STATUTE IN THE
FUTURE AND TO BRING THAT BACK
FOR CONSIDERATION BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET CYCLE.
I I DO THINK -- ON ALL THIS IS
COMPLICATED WE NEED TO ALL GET
IN A ROOM AND REALLY PUT OUR
THINKING CAPS ON AND TRY TO
FIGURE THIS OUT.
SO THAT WOULD BE OUR THAT WOULD
BE OUR PROPOSAL ON HOW TO TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THE ON THE TOWN
OF TWO POINT OO SCOURS TWO POINT
OH EXCUSE ME FOR SAYING THAT
AGAIN.
I'M AND THEN UNDER THE DISORDER
QUEST THAT WE WOULD HAVE AROUND
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION IS THAT --
WHY WE THINK THAT IT'S GREAT
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SEE --
INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES TO HELP THE
FAMILIES OF THE GREATEST NEEDS
AND WE'RE PUTTING MONEY INTO
WHERE WE THINK THE PRIORITIES OF
THE COUNTIES FOCUS SHOULD BE.
ON WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ARE RECIPIENTS ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT ARE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE PROVIDED.
AND SO ONE THING THAT I THINK WE
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT IS IN
THE PROCESS AND THE CONCEPT OF
THE SINGLE ALLOCATION IS.
HOW DO WE FLIP THE SWITCH IF YOU
CAN ON SERVICES SO ONCE THE
COUNTY AUTHORIZES AND SAYS
YOU'RE GOING TO SCHOOL?
AND IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE FIFTEEN UNITS OF
CLASS AND AT THE MOMENT THAT
THAT HAPPENS THE COUNTY
AUTOMATICALLY AUTHORIZES THE THE
AN ALLOCATION FOR BOOKS THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO THAT
STUDENT.
SO THE STUDENT THE CURRENT WAY
THINGS WORK THE STUDENT HAS TO
COME BACK TO THE WORKER PRESENT
WITH THEIR BOOKS ARE AND THEN
THE THE WORKABLE MAKE THAT
STUDENT JUSTIFY THAT THE STUDENT
PARENT JUSTIFY THAT.
WE FREQUENTLY SEE IF -- PARENTS
WERE SITTING IN THEIR SECOND
THIRD FOURTH WEEK OF CLASS AND
WE STILL DON'T HAVE THEIR BOOKS.
WE HAVE TO IN THOSE KIND OF
THINGS I THINK CHILD CARE IS
ANOTHER ARENA WHERE WE ALSO NEED
TO BE FLIPPING THE SWITCH THAT
ONCE WE AUTHORIZE A WELFARE TO
WORK PLAN.
CHILD CARE JUST OUGHT TO GO WITH
IT THE THE WORKER.
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO BACK AND
SPEND MORE TIME GOING THROUGH
PAPERWORK RE AUTHORIZING
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY IN TOP
AN ENTITLEMENT IN THE LAW.
SO THESE ARE THE KIND OF CHANGES
THAT WE WE THINK ARE NECESSARY
THAT WOULD BOTH STREAMLINED THE
PROGRAM TAKE SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITY OUT OF MAKE IT EASIER.
FOR THE RECIPIENTS TO GET
THROUGH THIS AND ALLOW THE
WORKERS TO BE SOCIAL WORKERS AND
NOT BE PAPER PUSHERS -- AND THEN --
ON THE SAFETY NET.
FIRST OF ALL WE SUPPORT
OBVIOUSLY THE AUGMENTATION
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE I'M SPEAKING OF NOW.
WE APPRECIATE THE THE THE
GOVERNOR'S ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
THAT.
WE WORRY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HAVING ALL THE MONEY AND WANT.
TO COUNT -- OR YOU KNOW -- CAL
WORKS IS FREQUENTLY TAKEN VERY
DEEP CUTS IN PRIOR BUDGETS --
AND I WOULD JUST BE.
LESS THAN HONEST I DIDN'T SAY
THAT YOU KNOW THEM.
THE HEALTHCARE ARENA HAS A LOT
OF POWERFUL INTEREST GROUPS AND
AT HAS A LOT OF STRONG ADVOCATES --
THERE AREN'T AS MANY IN THE WALL
FOR WORLD I THINK
PUTTING SOME WALLS AROUND THAT
FUNDING TO PROTECT THAT AND MAKE
SURE THERE'S SOMETHING THERE
SUBSTANTIAL FOR OUR TO REHAB GOD
FOR BID ANOTHER BAD BUDGET IS
REALLY IMPORTANT -- AND THEN WE
REALLY DO SUPPORT THE ADMINISTER
THE PROPOSAL THAT WAS PUT IN
LAST YEAR'S TRAILER BILL THAT
WOULD TRY TO MOVE -- AS WE SEE
CASELOAD DECLINES AS OUTLINED AS
BY MS JOHNSON EARLIER AS WE SEE
THOSE CASELOAD DECLINES THAT WE
WOULD TAKE SOME OF THAT REVENUE
AND PUT IT INTO THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT OVER THE LAST
SAY HALF DOZEN YEARS WE REALLY
HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL RESERVE
BECAUSE OUR CASELOADS DROPPED A
LOT FRANKLY WE PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DOING THE SAME THING
IN OUR SOCIETY -- SO UNFORTUNATE
WE CAN'T SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDATION ON THAT PIECE --
BUT WE DO AND WE DO APPRECIATE
THE AUGMENTATION THANK YOU.
YOU DON'T SUPPORT YOU SUPPORT
THE SEVEN HUNDRED BILL YES NOT
OKAY YES BUT NOT THE POST SO
WE'RE CLEAR NOT THE POLICY
CHANGE IS WONDERFUL --
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
TOWARDS HER TO FINANCE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
ALL.
SPEAKING EXCLUSIVELY TO THE THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE QUESTION --
SO JUST TO GO BACK A BIT IN THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AN
INITIAL DEPOSIT OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WAS MADE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING.
A US A SECOND DEPOSIT OF SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION FOR TOTAL NINE
HUNDRED MILLION.
ON IN DOING SO THE GOVERNOR ALSO
PROPOSES SOME STRUCTURAL CHANGES
TO HOW THE RESERVE WOULD WORK
OUR OFFICE MADE NO SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS TO APPROVE OR
NOT THOSE STRUCTURAL CHANGES --
RIGHT NOW THE NINE HUNDRED
MILLION UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
BE USED FOR EITHER CAL WORKS FOR
MEDI CAL IS MR HERALD MENTIONED --
PREVIOUSLY UNDER THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET STRUCTURE THERE
ARE TWO SUB ACCOUNTS SO THEY
WERE THEY WERE SEPARATED -- WE
POINT OUT WE'RE NOT.
CERTAIN HOW MUCH SEPARATION IN
PRACTICE THAT PROVIDED IT WAS
CLEARLY A SIGNAL BUT THEY WERE
STATUTORY SOME ACCOUNTS SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD HAVE AT ANY
POINT IN THE FUTURE.
JANE STATUTE AND MOVED FUNDS
BETWEEN THOSE TWO SUB ACCOUNTS
IF SOMETHING AS AS MISTER WOODS
MENTIONED -- CHANGED REGARDING
ONE OF THE PROGRAMS AND THE
FLEXIBILITY WAS NEEDED -- SO WE
THINK THAT'S A QUESTION REALLY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE GOING
FORWARD OUT REGARDING THE
WHETHER OR NOT TO USE A FORMULA
DRIVEN DEPOSIT SORT OF AN
AUTOMATIC THE POSITIVE CASELOAD
SAVINGS EACH YEAR.
ON WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
THE FORMULA DRIVEN APPROACH THAT
WAS A PART OF THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGETARY STRUCTURE FOR
THE RESERVE.
MIGHT.
RESULT IN A SORT OF RECOMMENDED
AUTOMATIC DEPOSIT THAT WASN'T IN
THE LEGISLATURE'S BEST INTEREST
IN SOME FUTURE YEAR -- AND SO WE
DO APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY OF
NOT HAVING AN AUTOMATIC DEPOSIT --
BUT WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE.
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE EACH YEAR TO BASICALLY
PUBLISHED THAT CASE LOAD SAVINGS
NUMBER AND MAKE IT PART OF THE
BUDGET CONVERSATIONS SO BETWEEN
EARLY SPRING AND AND THE THE
SIGNING OF THE BUDGET AX THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE GOVERNOR
CONSERVE.
NEGOTIATE AROUND THAT CASELOAD
SAVINGS NUMBER AND DETERMINE HOW
MUCH GIVEN THE LETTERS LEADERS
PRIORITIES SHOULD BE SET ASIDE
IN THE RESERVE FOR FUTURE YEARS
OR USE FOR OTHER PURPOSES -- SO
WE WE THINK OF THAT AS A SORT OF
A MIDDLE GROUND BETWEEN THE TWO
APPROACHES THAT THAT WE WOULD.
AT LEAST SUGGEST IF NOT
RECOMMEND.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I DO WANT TO COMMENT THAT I
THINK THAT THIS.
ENTIRE NEW APPROACH IS JUST
WONDERFUL WERE WHERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BEING SOCIAL
WORKERS.
BECAUSE IF THE ENTIRE INTENT IS
TO GET OUR CHILDREN IN THE
FAMILIES OUT OF DEEP POVERTY NOT
OF POVERTY.
THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE WE TO GET JOBS
WE TO GET TRAINING -- AND YOU'RE
RIGHT IF THE IF THE IF THE THE
PARENTS HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED TO
GO TO SCHOOL.
IT SHOULD BE AUTOMATIC WE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE.
TO FIGURE OUT TO ANOTHER PAPER
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IT SHOULD
BE A PROCESS SO THAT IT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED OTHERWISE.
OKAY WE'VE GOT IN SCHOOL THAT ME
MEANT NOTHING BECAUSE IF THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THEIR BOOKS.
THAT BECOMES A SERIOUS PROBLEM --
I IN ONE OF THE COMMENTS.
ON THE SINGLE ALLOCATION I KNOW
THAT THE THE ADVOCATES.
WHAT TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS SO I
WOULD ASK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE AS?
THAT PARTICULAR -- PART OF IT IS
IS IS YEAR YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
THAT CAN CAN WE INCLUDE THE AT
THIS THE ADVOCATES.
IN THAT DISCUSSION.
FINANCE WOODS A BUT WE'VE
CURRENTLY WERE WORKING WITH THE
COUNTY PARTNERS BUT IF THERE IS.
TO BE PERFECTLY HONEST MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD HAVE TO CHECK THE
STATUTE TO MAKE SURE THAT IS
APPROPRIATE.
BUT IF THAT IS INDEED THE CASE
WE COULD HAVE A DISCUSSION
EVERYONE JUST PULL SO LET'S
ASSUME IT IS APPROPRIATE.
THEN WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
INCLUDE THE STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M NOT TRYING TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT I JUST THINK THAT IF IT'S
SOMETHING.
IN THE END WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
GET TO THE SAME PLACE.
WE WANT TO WE DON'T WE WANT TO
MOVE THINGS FORWARD.
AND IF WE HAVE STAKEHOLDERS.
WHO ARE SO CONCERNED AND WANT TO
BE INCLUDED IN THIS?
THEN WHEN WHEN IT THE PROPOSAL
IS BROUGHT TO THE COMMITTEE THEN
THE DISCUSSION IS ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS GOT TOGETHER WE
DISCUSS THIS.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS WE DON'T
JUST WE DON'T AGREE ON BUT THIS
WAS DISCUSSION THIS IS THE END
RESULT -- AS OPPOSED TO HERE'S
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
STAKEHOLDERS WELL WE DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT IT NOW WE WANT TO
TELL YOU WHAT WE THINK ABOUT.
YES IT'S JON CAM JOHNSON SOCIAL
SERVICES SO I I'LL JUST ADD THAT
YES THERE IS A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONSULT WITH STAKEHOLDERS
KNOWS THEY'RE ACTUALLY IT'S
ACTUALLY SPECIFIC THE
COMPOSITION IS INCLUDED IN
STATUTE WE HAVE.
SO -- THERE'S BEEN TWO LARGER
STAKEHOLDER AT MEETING SPECIFIC
TO THE SINGLE ALLOCATION
EMPLOYMENT SERVICES COMPONENT
THE FIRST WAS IN ARE.
AT KIND OF KICK OFF OF THINKING
THROUGH THE CONCEPTS WE WANTED
TO EXPLORE IN THINKING THROUGH
WHAT KIND OF PHASES OR STAGES WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT ARE THE
COMPONENTS WITHIN THE EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES.
AND WE ALSO JUST HELD A
STAKEHOLDER MEETING A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO SPECIFIC TO THINKING
ABOUT CASE MANAGEMENT AND
DIFFERENT NEEDS OF DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS WITH AND CAL WORKS.
WONDERFUL IT AND I KNOW THAT IF
GOING BACK TO THE SAME THING OF
CALOR.
WE'RE MORE IS WANTED.
TO RIDE LEAVING MR HERALD IT IS
TALKED ABOUT THAT WE WANT
INTERVENTION WE WANT TO BE AREA
REMOVAL WE WANT HOUSING JUST AS
AS YOU MENTIONED -- IF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS AN ISSUE THAT'S DEAL
WITH THAT.
THEY NEED A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
LET'S DEAL WITH THAT COLLEGE
COGNITIVE ISSUES MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES WHATEVER THE ISSUES ARE
THEN YOU WORK AS A SOCIAL WORKER.
TO TRY TO WORK WITH THE FAMILY
BECAUSE WE WANT AGAIN TO TAKE
THESE CHILDREN IN THESE FAMILIES.
OUT OF THE DEEP POVERTY.
COLLEAGUES YOU STOP ME WHENEVER
YOU WANT TO ADD SOMETHING
BECAUSE I I THINK IT WOULDN'T.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE THE
SAFETY NET -- I AT FIRST I I I
AM EVER SO GRATEFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR -- FOR THE ADDITIONAL
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION.
I I THINK THAT THAT IS.
IT SENDS A MESSAGE IT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BUDGET IT IS OUR
VALUES AND I I I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT AND KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES DO AS WELL.
I THINK THAT THE NEED FOR THE
SUB ACCOUNTS.
I WANT TO STATE I THINK WE HAVE
THE NEED FOR THE SUB ACCOUNTS.
I THINK THAT -- I THINK IT WAS
MENTIONED AND I THINK MR HERALD
YOU MENTIONED THAT.
THAT WE DO NEED TO PROTECT THE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WHEN WERE
STARTING TO LOOK FOR CUTS FOR
AREAS TO CUT.
OFTENTIMES SOLDIER THE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CUT DO WE WANT
TO BE SURE.
THAT WE DO PROTECT THEM BECAUSE
THESE ARE TOTALLY RIGHTEOUS
PROGRAMS AND WE'VE GOT TO FIND
WAYS TO TO PROTECT THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT DO HELP.
OUR KIDS -- AND WE'VE GOT TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO TO PROTECT
THEM -- INDEED GOING BACK TO THE
SINGLE ALLOCATION ARE THERE ANY.
ADDITIONAL PENDING MEETINGS --
WITH THE WITH THE ADVOCATES FOR
THE STAKEHOLDERS -- I THINK ONCE
WE SO WE HAVE WE'RE NOT AT THE
FINAL PLACE WE'RE STILL
EXPLORING AT WHAT.
THE CASE MANAGEMENT COMPONENT OF
THE METHODOLOGY MIGHT BE AS WE
TURN TO SERVICES WHICH YOU HEARD
AT MR HERALD HERALD MENTIONED
AND AND AT THINKING THROUGH WHAT
IS THE AT METHODOLOGY BEHIND HOW
WE IDENTIFY THE SERVICE NEEDS
REALLY BASED ON THE INDIVIDUALS --
I THINK WHAT WE WILL ABSOLUTELY
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS FOR THAT CONVERSATION
WONDERFUL.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
YES MISTER FRAZIER.
AND AGAIN I I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
WILLINGNESS TO ADVANCE -- THE
SAFETY NET.
I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL ALSO
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE INSTALLED ON ANY OF
THESE -- PANELS.
THAT YOU SHOW EXPECTATIONS AND
COMES.
AS SO THATWE CAN SHOW ADVANCES.
SO THAT WE CAN JUSTIFY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS GOING FORWARD --
WE DON'T WANT WHEN WE HAVE --
BLACK OR WHITE OR ANY KIND OF
WHITE PAPER PERSPECTIVE GOING
FORWARD -- IT'S HARD TO ARGUE.
YOU KNOW REALLY GOOD OUTCOMES
OKAY.
AND THEN THE MONEY'S BEEN SPEND
IT AT A GOOD VALUE.
THEN THE DEAL OF CAN'T REFUTE
THAT.
I'M SERIOUS I MEAN AND THE
VACANCY THEY CAN BE PROUD OF
WHAT THEY'VE ALSO SUPPORTED
GOING.
FOR SO.
I THINK YOU KNOW MY EXPECTATION
IS IS A I SEE.
YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS GOING OUT.
AND I'M A WILL HAVE AN
EXPECTATION THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE USED WELL [inaudible]
HOW WELL?
SO IF WE CAN START TRACKING.
AND AND BEING ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR WHAT WE'RE GETTING AS AN
OUTCOME.
THAT TO ME.
IS WHAT THE BUDGET SUB.
ONE PANEL IS SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING AND AND AND IT
ACCOMPLISHING.
AND IN THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS.
WE'VE ADVANCED.
GREAT.
SOCIAL EQUITY.
WE ALSO DID IT.
IT'LL WE HAD A DANCE PEOPLE INTO
ANOTHER -- OUT OF POVERTY AS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- RUBIO SAID.
AND THE DOLLAR WAS SPENT.
HAS THIS PANEL EXPECTED IN AS
THE VIEW OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
I I NEED TANGIBLE RESULTS THAT I
CAN SEE -- TO BE ABLE TO SAVE
NEXT YEAR.
LET'S DO IT AGAIN.
LET'S ADVANCE OF LOCAL WHAT WE
ACCOMPLISHED SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR WHEN I GO FORWARD
IT'S GREAT. TO TO GET EXTRA
MONEY.
WHAT WE GET FOR IT?
THIS WILL LOOK.
FOR WONDERFUL THANK YOU MUST
FRAZIER -- I COULD MEDICARE
THAT'S MISTER FRAZIER SAPLING.
WHEN OUR MEMBERS WERE --
CONCEDING THAT CAL OR THE
OUTCOMES AN ACCOUNTABILITY
REVIEW.
IDEA ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES THAT
WE WERE FACING WAS THE INABILITY
TO ARTICULATE WITH DATA.
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING FOR THE
MONEY WE KNEW WE WERE DOING GOOD
THINGS WE'RE PROUD OF THE WORK
WE WERE DOING BUT WE AS A STATE?
NEVER ARTICULATED THE OUTCOMES
WE DIDN'T GATHER THE DATA TO
TRACK THEM -- AND SO A KEY.
REASON BEHIND THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THE NEW OUT COMES AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM IS TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO EXACTLY THE
NEED THAT YOU JUST ARTICULATED
[inaudible]
GOOD ANSWER.
THANK YOU.
I HAVE ALSO EL STAFF TO TO WORK
WITH TO TO WORK WITH YOU.
TO FIND WAYS THAT WERE
INTERESTED I THINK I THINK I
SPEAK FOR MY COLLEAGUES AND I IN
FORMALIZING YVR CODIFYING.
THE INTENT THAT OF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS.
TO TO TO IN DOORS THE TWO OF
WHAT WHAT WE WITH CALOR IS IN
TWO K. -- CAL WORKS TO PORTO THE
THIS ISWHERE WE WANT TO SHIFT
THIS IS WHERE WE WANT TO GO --
AND I THINK THAT I I I DO WANT
STAFF TO WORK WITH YOU TO FIGURE.
THE LANGUAGE -- SO THAT THAT CAN
BE CODIFIED AND THERE WE KNOW
THE DIRECTION WE'RE TRAVELING IN.
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS A VERY
GOOD THING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
ALL RIGHT THEN IF WE MAY --
LET'S MOVE. TO TWO ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND I KNOW THAT
MY COLLEAGUE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEEKS IS HERE SO AFTER THE
GOVERNOR AFTER THAT THE THE
GOVERNOR'S PRESENTATION -- AS IT
IS THERE PROPOSAL I LIKE TO HEAR
FROM MY COLLEAGUE.
YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE TASHA
NIKOLAI AGAIN FROM DSS.
WANT TO NOTE HERE AGAIN AT THE
AGENDA PAGE TWENTY EIGHT TO
THIRTY TWO HAS A GOOD SUMMARY OF
THE HOME VISITING PROGRAM INTO
THAT I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS VERY EXCITED TO BE
LAUNCHING THE CAL WORKS ON
VISITING INITIATIVE IN FORTY
FOUR COUNTIES IN THIS FOR CYCLE.
LEVERAGING HOME VISITING
SERVICES INTO THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM PRESENTS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROMOTE TO
GENERATION POLICIES THAT MEET
THE NEEDS OF BOTH THE PARENTS
AND THE CHILDREN.
COUNTIES ARE LEVERAGING FOR
EVIDENCE BASED MODELS INCLUDING
HEALTHY FAMILIES AMERICA
APPEARANCES TEACHERS NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIPS AND EARLY
HEAD START AS WELL AS FOR HOME
GROWN INITIATIVES THAT.
HAVE MET THE ROBUST REQUIREMENTS
OF THE PROGRAM.
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDES A PROPOSAL TO MAKE HOME
VISITING AN ONGOING PROGRAM
COMPONENT COMPONENT IN THE
COLLEGE PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT WAS SHORT AND SWEET MS WICKS
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WE YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT UNMET
BASIC NEEDS ECONOMIC HARBOR
HARDSHIP HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
UNDERMINE THE SHORT AND LONG
TERM HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
FOR FAMILIES AND CHILDREN IN THE
STATE -- AND TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CHALLENGES WE KNOW THAT
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS ARE
REALLY POWERFUL TOOLS TO HELP
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE IN
REALLY -- IN DESPERATE NEED --
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WE KNOW THAT
THESE PROGRAMS TO TALK ABOUT ARE
A WHY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS
CAN GENERATE YOU KNOW PUBLIC
SAVINGS BY INCREASING HEALTHY
BIRTHS.
PROMOTING SCHOOL READINESS
REDUCING CHILD MALTREATMENT AND
INCREASING FAMILY SELF
SUFFICIENCY THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS
WORK AND THEY'RE REALLY STRONG
INVESTMENTS [inaudible]
THEREFORE.
I AM REQUEST RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE BUILD UPON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL OF
SAID SEVENTY EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION FUNDING FOR CAL WORKS
HOME VISITING INITIATIVE THROUGH
KEY.
AMENDMENTS AND BY ALLOCATING AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
ON GOING TO THE PROGRAM TO SERVE
THESE FAMILIES RIGHT NOW WE ARE
ONLY SERVING 8% OF THE CAL WORKS
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF TWO AND FRANKLY WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE MILLIONS OF%
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY IN
THE STATE.
AND THESE ARE DISPROPORTIONATE
CHILDREN OF COLOR.
AND SO THERE'S A RACIAL EQUITY
LENDS HERE I THINK WE ALSO NEED
TO LOOK AT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES AND I'M A BIG
BELIEVER THAT SUPPORTING STRONG
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PRO PROGRAM'S
REALLY HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD -- FOR THESE KIDS AND SO
WE SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS.
PARENTING A YOUNG CHILD.
IS AN ENORMOUS STRESS AND I KNOW
BECAUSE I HAVE A TWO YEAR OLD.
OF IT PLACES THE PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL DEMANDS ON ON ADULTS
AND SOME FAMILIES MAY NOT HAVE
WHAT THEY NEED.
A OR KNOW WHERE TO GO WHERE TO
GET THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
AND HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
REALLY HELP PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT
FOR THOSE FAMILIES SO I AM
MAKING THIS REQUEST I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE COALITION OF
GREAT ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
CHILDREN NOW AND OTHERS ON THIS.
I THANK YOU FOR A CHEN ISING
THIS ITEM TODAY AND FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
FAMILIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANGELA ROTH AMONG ROUGHER MAIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO PRONOUNCE IT
CORRECTLY.
CLOSE ENOUGH NO NO WOOD.
MY NAME IS ANGELA RATHER MAIL
FROM CHILDREN NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
I'M IN THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS -- I'M HERE TODAY
TO RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
COMMITTEE TO BUILD UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S PRPOSAL IN THE CAL
WORKS.
HOME VISITING INITIATIVE AND
ALLOCATE AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS
INCORPORATE SOME KEY TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND AND ENHANCE
VOLUNTARY EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING FOR OUR FAMILIES.
INCREASING SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
POINTS EARLY CHILDHOOD IS A
CRUCIAL PERIOD OF TIME NOT JUST
FOR CHILDREN'S.
DEVELOPMENT BUT ALSO -- TO
INVESTING IN FAMILIES AS A WHOLE
FOR LIFELONG WELL BEING AND
SUCCESS.
I'M IN THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF
LIFE BABIES BRAINS ARE FORMING
ONE MILLION NEURAL CONNECTIONS
EVERY SECOND.
AND ITS RELATIONSHIPS HEALTHY
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS THAT --
FUEL THAT HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT.
POVERTY AN UNMET BASIC NEEDS IN
FAMILIES CAN WEAKEN THIS
ARCHITECTURE BUT STABLE
RELATIONSHIPS AND PARA POSITIVE
PARENT CHILD INTERACTIONS BUT
FOR THE IMPACTS OF ADVERSITY AND
THAT CAN ACTUALLY FOSTER
CRITICAL LIFELONG PROTECTIVE
FACTORS IN CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
WE APPLAUD THE ASSEMBLY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP LAST YEAR AND PUSHING
GOVERNOR BROWN IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE A BIG
VISION AROUND THE CAL WORKS HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE.
WHILE THE COW WORKS EACH BE I
REPRESENTS AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXPANSION OF EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING IN FORTY FOUR COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
CURRENT FUNDING WILL ONLY GO FAR
ENOUGH TO REACH AN ESTIMATED 8%
OF THE ELIGIBLE POPULATION.
THE CAL WORKS HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE ENCOURAGES COUNTIES
TO LEVERAGE EXISTING LOCAL
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS WHILE ALSO EMPHASIZING
ACCOUNTABILITY TO INSURE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES WHICH IS SMART
POLICY -- KEY TO THE SUCCESS OF
THIS APPROACH WILL BE SMARTLY
INTEGRATING THE H. B. I. INTO
LOCAL EARLY CHILDHOOD CONTACTS
AND LANDSCAPES AS WELL AS HAVING
ROBUST TO DATA TO EVALUATE
IMPACTS TO CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE
THE PROGRAM.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
DIVERSE ARRAY.
OF EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAMS ANCHORED WITHIN LOCAL
AND PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS AND UNTIL THE
HISTORIC CREATION OF THE CALYX
EACH BE AYE LAST YEAR THIS
NETWORK WAS SOLELY FUNDED
THROUGH FEDERAL AND LOCAL FUNDS.
THIS LANDSCAPE WITH MULTIPLE
FUNDING STREAMS AND SIMILAR BUT
VERY DATA COLLECTION MECHANISMS --
CAN -- BRING STRONG POTENTIAL TO
LEVERAGE BUT IT ALSO CAN BRING --
INEFFICIENCIES AND SO WE HAVE TO
BE THOUGHTFUL IN TERMS OF HOW WE
SCALE UP THE KELLER TGI.
HALF OF THE COUNTIES IN THE TO
BE I ALSO HAVE FEDERALLY FUNDED
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HOME VISITING SITES.
AND MANY IF NOT ALL HAVE EARLY
HEAD START FEDERAL TO LOCAL HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND FIRST FIVE
COMMISSION FUNDED HOME VISITING
EFFORTS.
THESE PARTNERS ARE PROVING A
RELIABLE TO HELP SCALE THESE
EFFORTS FOR EXAMPLE STAKEHOLDERS
FROM SAN BERNADINO THE COUNTY
RECEIVING THE SECOND LARGEST
AWARD THREE THE HPI.
SHARED WITH ME JUST LAST WEEK
THE NEED FOR LOCAL ENTITIES TO
PAINT BETTER CONNECT AND
LEVERAGE ONE ANOTHER TOWARD THE
SUCCESS OF THIS EFFORT.
WHEN LOCAL PROGRAMS COLLABORATE
AND ARE CONNECTED THEY WERE
BETTER WORK TOGETHER TO MAXIMIZE
SCARCE RESOURCES AND SERVE
FAMILIES IN THEIR COMMUNITY?
THEY STAND READY TO HELP THE
STATE ENSURE THE SUCCESS OF THE
H. B. I. BUT THEY NEED HELP.
SO THE EARLY YEARS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION ARE CRITICAL TO
CATALYZE THE CREATION OF LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD UP AND
MAXIMIZE NETWORKS OF SUPPORT. TO
LEVERAGE DIVERSE NON TANNER
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT TWO
GENERATIONS IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM -- EFFECTIVE SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS MUST BE BACKED
BY INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL ALLOW
FOR THE STATE DEPARTMENT AS WELL
AS LOCAL IMPLEMENTING AGENCIES.
TO COORDINATE AND PLAN EFFECTIVE
INTERAGENCY SYSTEMS --
ESTABLISHED STRONG STATE LOCAL
FEEDBACK LOOPS AROUND PROGRESS
AND BARRIERS RESPOND ON AN
ONGOING BASIS TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING NEEDS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY DO THE HARD
WORK TO NASH AND IT EXISTING
DATA MECHANISM SO THAT WE HAVE
WHAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS AFFECTED.
WERE ALSO REQUESTING TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO IMPROVE THE
COWARDS H. B. I. AS OUTLINED IN
THE AGENDA -- IN PARTICULAR
CLARIFY THAT ALL FAMILIES
PARTICIPATING AND CAL WORKS WHO
ARE PREGNANT OR PARENTING A
CHILD UNDER AGE TWO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THESE SUPPORTS.
CLARIFY THAT INDIVIDUALS
DETERMINED TO BE PRESUMPTIVELY
ELIGIBLE FOR OUR CAL WORKS
EXCUSE ME ARE ALSO -- ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE HOME VISITING SO THAT
SERVICES CAN BEGIN AS SOON A
PREGNANCY AS POSSIBLE -- FI THAT
SERVING NON CUSTODIAL PARENTS IS
ALLOWABLE SO THAT SPLIT CUSTODY
FAMILIES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN HOME VISITING IF
THAT IS THEIR DESIRE AND
PREFERENCE.
AND ALSO TO CHANGE THE NAME OF
THE CAT TO THE COW WORKS HOME
VISITING PROGRAM TO REFLECTING
MIRROR ON THE NAMING OF OTHER
SIMILAR ON PARTS OF THE CAL
WORKS ARE RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO COME AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
HELLO.
WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH WITH
YOUR STAFF ON YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE OF THE PROPOSAL IN
ADDITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- THAT WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS ON THAT WHAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND FOR THE ADMINISTRATION WHAT
IS YOUR THINKING ABOUT SPECIFIC
POINTS ON THE FUNDING.
ON THE ADVOCATES PROPOSAL ON THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
SURE THE TASHA NIKOLAI FROM DSS.
ARE THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES THE
PROPOSAL FROM THE ADVOCATES HAS
MERIT AND THAT FAMILIES WITH
MORE THAN ONE CHILD CAN BENEFIT
FROM HOME VISITING AND THEN AN
EARLY INTRODUCTION TO HOME
VISITING IN A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH DOES BENEFIT FAMILIES.
TWENTY SIX OF THE FORTY FOUR
PARTICIPATING COUNTIES TO DATE --
PLAN TO SERVE EXPANDED
POPULATIONS NOW OF THESE TWENTY
ONE PLAN TO SERVE PARENTS WITH
MORE THAN ONE CHILD FIVE PLAN TO
EXPAND SERVICES THE CAL LEARN OR
TEEN PARENT CASELOADS.
AND FIVE PLANNED TO EXPAND TO
SERVE PARENTS WITH OLDER
CHILDREN BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWO
AND FIVE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE
THAT COUNTIES OF EXPERIENCE SOME
IMPLEMENTATION DELAYS ARE
RELATED TO LOCAL CONTRACTING
PROCESSES BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
APPROVALS HIRING AND TRAINING OF
HOME VISITORS AND DEVELOPING
THEM A USING.
DATA SHARING AGREEMENTS REQUIRED
TO EFFECTIVELY TRACK TO PROGRAMS --
THE DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED IN
PLANS ON GOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SESSIONS TO SUPPORT
THE COUNTIES REALLY REALLY IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESSES --
AND WILL WANT TO CONSIDER THE
TIME NEEDED IS NOTED TO BUILD
CAPACITY AND IDENTIFY HOW MUCH
GROWTH HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
CAN SUCCESSFULLY ACCOMPLISH IN
ONE YEAR -- AND IN ADDITION WE
SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT WE LEARN
ABOUT THE UPTAKE OF IT AS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM MOVING FORWARD.
NOT FOOD FINALLY KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
A PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY C. PH BY ABOUT TWENTY ONE
MILLION.
THE ADVOCATES -- NOTED AND IT'S
STATED THAT PAID THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE.
THIRTY ONE AND TOP OF PAGE.
THIRTY TWO THE FOR SPECIFIC.
PROPOSALS A LANGUAGE CHANGES.
IS THE ADMINISTRATION AVAILABLE
TO THESE CHANGES.
TARA FINANCED HER WORDS.
NOT AT THIS TIME CONSIDERING
THAT THOSE.
CHANGES WOULD RESULT IN COST
PRESSURES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND OTHERS COST PRESSURES --
WOULD THEY BE ALLEVIATED WITH
THE ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION.
AS ADDRESSED BY MS WICKS -- AT
AT THIS TIME WE HAVEN'T DELVED
DOWN INTO THOSE NUMBERS -- TO
THE EXTENT IT DOES BECOME A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE WE
CAN LOOK INTO THOSE NUMBERS AND
HOW THESE LANGUAGE CHANGES
TRANSLATE INTO FUNDING AND COST
PRESSURES.
THANK YOU I THINK IT IS ONE OF
THE LONG TIME ADVOCATES.
WORKING IN THE SPACE -- SAID TO
ME -- THAT.
THE THIS WOULD BE LIKE A DREAM
COME TRUE. TO HAVE IT
UNIVERSAL'S TO HAVE THIS OFFERED
IT TO TO THE MOTHERS -- WITH
KIDS TWO AND UNDER.
SO IF WE'RE ABLE TO TO MAKE A
CHANGE AND AGAIN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
SHIFT CHANGES SO THEY WERE
REALLY ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
CHILDREN TO TAKE CARE OF THE
FAMILY AND HERE OFFER IT SO IT'S
NOT JUST 8%.
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- BUT IF
SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED IN THE
SPACE SAYS THIS WOULD BE A DREAM
COME TRUE WE GOT TO WORK ON
MAKING THOSE DREAMS COME TRUE
AND FIGURE OUT WAYS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT BUDGET
REQUESTS AND AND PRIORITIES AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS IT NEEDS
TO BE DONE?
SO I I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO
WORK WITH THE WITH THE STAFF AND
DO WITH THE ADVOCATES TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE GET.
THIS THIS LANGUAGE AND AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE.
I THANK YOU FOR THAT.
YES MISTER ROBERTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND JUST
SOME REAL QUICK ON THE ON THE
TEN IF IN THOUGH I A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION COMING IN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING.
WE KNOW THAT -- CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST POPULATION
OF NATIVE AMERICANS -- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MANY TIMES WE LOOK AT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING GOING TOWARDS
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION
HOWEVER.
WITH THE HIGH POPULATION IN THE
STATE ITSELF LOOKING AT WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING WAS BEING
PROPOSED HERE WITH THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION.
ARE WE ASSURING THAT ACTUALLY
THOSE GROUPS ALSO WOULD BE --
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WHEN THESE
VISITS TAKE PLACE.
SO IN ADDITION TO THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT SUPPORTS
ATA TRIBAL TENNIS PROGRAM -- THE
TRIBAL TENNIS PROGRAM AS IN
TWENTY THREE TRIBES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE EACH TRIBE HAS
THEIR OWN PROGRAM DESIGN OF THAT
SERVICE RATE THAT'S OFFERED
WITHIN THEIR TEN OF PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION MEMBERS OF THE TRIBE
CAN CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
TRIBAL TENNIS PROGRAM IN THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC REGION OR THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM THE CAN'T BE DULY
ENROLLED BUT THEY CAN CHOOSE. TO
PARTICIPATE IN EITHER PROGRAM SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT AT THE THE
FORTY FOUR COUNTIES ARE
CURRENTLY OUT VOLUNTARILY OPTING
INTO PROVIDING CAO WORK SOME
VISITING IN THE SPUR CYCLE.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
TRIBAL TENNIS PROGRAM THAT
PARTICULAR REGION OFFERED HOME
VISITING THAT WOULD BE THE
VARIABLE TO CONSIDER WHETHER OR
NOT AT INDIVIDUAL WILL BE.
AT HAVE ACCESS TO A HOME
VISITING PROGRAM. ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS INSANE THAT AND HERE
IN THE DISCUSSION THANK YOU FOR
FOR THOSE.
UNCOMMON TO SEE IN THE TRAVEL
COMMUNITY AS FAR AS WHAT'S ON
THE FEDERAL INDIAN RESERVATION
BUT YEAH WE HAVE A HIGH
POPULATION LIVING IN THE URBAN
AREAS.
AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY FUNDING THAT MOVES FORWARD
STARTS TO TAKE CARE OF THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA GENERAL
WHICH AGAIN.
HOLDS THE HIGHEST POPULATION OF
NATIVE AMERICANS -- INDIA ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION SO
BEING ABLE TO WORK WITH YOUR
SPOUSE OR SOMEONE ELSE WITH YOU
IN MY OFFICE TO IDENTIFY HOW WE
COULD DO A BETTER JOB.
AT DOING THAT BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
HERE ON THIS -- COMMITTEE DUSTED
CYSTIC SO THE RATIOS OF AMERICAN
INDIAN PEOPLE NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WITH THE RACES ARE SO
MUCH HIGHER.
THAN THE COURTS OF OF OTHER
GROUPS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO I THINK TRYING TO BRING SOME
SOME AWARENESS SOME EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENTS TO THAT THEN WE LOOK
A SERVICING THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION.
THAT IT'S JUST NOT HERE IS TO AN
INDIAN RESERVATION AND THEN IT
STOPS THERE.
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT LIVE IN THE
URBAN AREAS IS STILL NEED THE
SERVICES THAT ARE THERE SO I
WOULD -- WELCOME TO THE CHAIR --
ANY DIALOGUE THAT WE COULD HAVE
TO MAKE SURE AND INSURE THAT
WHEN THESE VISITS TAKE PLACE.
THAT THE AMERICAN INDIAN PEOPLE
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
TAKING CARE OF ALSO AT THE SAME
TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER ROSS
YES MISTER FRAZIER.
AND YOU'D MENTIONED IN THE TALK
ABOUT THE FORTY FOUR COUNTIES
THAT ARE OPTED INVOLUNTARILY.
BUT IN THE OTHERS.
GOOD QUESTION SO -- VARIETY OF
REASONS IN SOME CASES IT COULD
BE SO LET LET ME BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT TO SAY THAT.
THE COW WORK SOME VISITING
INITIATIVE WAS DESIGNED IN A WAY
TO LEVERAGE AND BUILD UPON WHAT
HOME VISITING EFFORTS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN BIG BEGAN TO THE
MATERNAL INFANT EARLY CHILDHOOD
HOME VISITING FIND AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO
THROUGH.
OTHER LOCALLY FUNDED INITIATIVES
AND AND SO IN TERMS OF AT
CAPACITY AND WHICH COUNTIES HAVE
EXISTING HOME VISITING PROGRAMS
PRIOR TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
LAUNCH OF THE COUCH SOME
VISITING INITIATIVE.
THAT DOES VERY NOT EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY ACROSS CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HOME VISITING PROGRAM.
IN OUR DESIGN EVER APPLICATION
WE DID TO TO MITIGATE THAT AT
ALLOW FOR REGIONAL APPROACHES SO
MULTIPLE COUNTIES ARE AT OR AT
HOME VISITING ENTITY COULD SERVE
MULTIPLE.
REGIONS WE DID NOT RECEIVE -- AT
ANY OF THOSE TYPES OF
APPLICATIONS IN SOME CASES IT'S
ALSO JUST IN TERMS OF THE MODELS
IN THE SPECIFICITY OF THE MALL
FOR EXAMPLE -- STANLEY
PARTNERSHIP WHICH REQUIRES A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE IN SOME
CASES THAT'S NOT A VIABLE --
PERCENT THERE'S NOT NOT ENOUGH
OF A POPULATION -- TO MATCH THE
CASELOAD THAT THAT THAT NURSE
MIGHT CARRY SO THERE WERE THERE
SOME VARIATION IN TERMS OF
CASELOAD CONSIDERATIONS AS WELL
AS CAPACITY.
A MAHOOD UPON VISITING AND WE DO
PLAN IN OUR NEXT SPENDING CYCLE
TO AGAIN OFFER REGIONAL APPROACH
AND PROVIDES MORE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SEE IF THAT WOULD
HELP.
ENSURE IT STATE WIDE.
BECAUSE I KNOW LAST YEAR THAT I
CARRIED A BILL THAT REQUIRED
HEALTH PLANS AND HOSPITALS. TO
HAVE -- OUT.
IN HOME CARE FOR INDIVIDUALS
YOUNG MOTHERS.
ARE MOTHERS WHO -- BECAUSE THERE
ARE BEEN A HIGH.
A SUICIDE RATE ALSO OF THE THE
INABILITY.
TO TO BUILT IN -- THEY WERE
OVERWHELMED RIGHT AND SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS WHY WE COULDN'T
COMBINE THOSE TWO PROCESSES
WHERE THERE'S A DEFICIENCY IN.
FROM IN YOU KNOW THE WHAT IS IT
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES SO MINUS.
FORTY FOUR YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE
THE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN COUNTIES
ARE TAKING CARE OF IN THAT REALM
WITH HEALTH ALLIANCE CAN
ACTUALLY OR THE THE HOSPITAL'S
CAN.
AUGMENT THAT.
THE COMMISSION CHECK.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
I WANT TO THANK THIS PANEL AND
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MS WORKS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MICHAEL WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HERE TO
PRESENT -- ITEM FOR ON YOUR
AGENDA.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE WAS SITTING --
IN ROOMS JUST LIKE THIS ONE OF
THE TENETS OF THE BI PARTISAN
CAL WORKS -- BILL WAS THAT WORK
SHOULD PAY.
IF WE EXPECT PEOPLE GETTING
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE TO WORK.
THERE SHOULD BE AN INCENTIVE AND
THERE SHOULD BE SUPPORT FOR THAT
WORK THEY SHOULD NOT LOSE THEIR
GRANT DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR FOR WHAT
THEY EARN.
SO THE MECHANISM FOR
OPERATIONALIZE THING THAT TENET.
IS THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD.
WE ALLOW CLIENTS TO KEEP TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AND
50% OF EVERYTHING ELSE THAT THEY
EARN -- BUT AS OPPOSED -- TO A
SYSTEM WHERE THEY WOULD LOSE
MORE OF THEIR CHARACTER -- HAS
EARNINGS GO UP.
THE GRANT GRADUALLY COMES DOWN
AND SO DURING THAT TIME A CLIENT
CAN COMBINE THEIR EARNINGS.
THERE GRANT AND THEIR WORK
SUPPORTS LIKE TRANSPORTATION OR
CHILD CARE.
SO THEY COULD GRADUALLY MOVE
FROM RECEIPT OF AID TO SELF
SUFFICIENCY WE WANTED TO CREATE
A BRIDGE TO SELF SUFFICIENCY NOT
A CLIFF.
AND THAT WAS A KEY TENET OF THE
BIPARTISAN CHOLERIC SPELL.
THE PROBLEM IS YOUR AGENDA LAYS
OUT BASED ON AN EXCELLENT REPORT
BY THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER.
IS THAT THE WORK INCENTIVES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CREATED FOR THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM HAS DEGRADED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD
HASN'T BEEN UPDATED IN TWENTY
YEARS.
INFLATION IN THE MINIMUM WAGE
HAVE SO SIGNIFICANTLY DEGRADED
THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD THAT
WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS MORE LIKE A
CLIFF -- THEN A BRIDGE.
HAD IT BEEN UPDATED FOR
INFLATION AND FOR CHANGES IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE WE WOULD BE
DISREGARDING FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS ABOUT RIGHT ABOUT ROUND
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND 50%.
OF THE BALANCE NOT TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE AND AS A RESULT
WERE JEOPARDIZING THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM. TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE --
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT A
PERSON WITH A FULL TIME MINIMUM
WAGE WORK WOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP
THEIR GRANT.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
WORK SUPPORTS -- FROM THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM.
THEY WOULD NOT EXIT OFF THE
PROGRAM UNTIL THEIR EARNINGS
EXCEEDED FULL TIME MINIMUM WAGE
WORK.
THAT VERY SAME CLIENT TODAY
EARNING MINIMUM WAGE IS
INELIGIBLE FOR CALYX.
AND SO NOT ONLY DO THEY LOSE
THAT THAT THE SUPPORT OF THE
GRANT BUT THEY ALSO LOSE THE
WORK SUPPORTS THAT GO ALONG WITH --
WITH THE COWART'S PROGRAM.
HAD WE INDEX THE EARNED INCOME
DISREGARD FOR INFLATION IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
THAT SAME CLIENT THAT I TALKED
ABOUT WOULD HAVE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A
MONTH MORE.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY. FOR A
FAMILY WORKING REALLY HARD TO
TRY TO MOVE THEMSELVES FROM
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE INTO THE WORK
FORCE.
AND THE CURRENT SITUATION LEAVES
A TERRIBLE CATCH TWENTY TWO FOR
WORKING CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS.
TURN DOWN A SHIFT.
SO I DON'T LOSE THE VITAL WORK
SUPPORTS OR INCREASE MY WORK
BECAUSE I WANT TO BUT THEN LOSE
THE KEY THINGS THAT ALLOWED ME.
TO SORT OF GET THE TO TO GET THE
JOB IN THE FIRST PLACE -- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT
SKYROCKETING RENTS HAVE ACTUALLY
MADE THE PROBLEM MUCH WORSE
BECAUSE RENTS HAVE RISEN ABOUT
THREE TIMES FASTER THAN WAGES
AND INFLATION.
AND SO.
I THINK IT'S ARGUABLE THAT THE
EXIT POINT FOR CAL WORKS SHOULD
BE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN IT
WAS IN INFLATION ADJUSTED TERMS
THE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
BECAUSE AS CLIENTS LEAVE -- CAL
WORKS WITH RENTS THAT ARE SO
HIGH THE ABILITY TO TO REMAIN.
HOUSE AND TO REMAIN EMPLOYED AND
NOT NEED TO COME BACK ON TO
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE IS THAT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT.
IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE RENTS
ARE SO HIGH.
SO SEAT EVERY DAY AS A PROPOSAL
IT'S ACTUALLY REFLECTED IN AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX STONE WERE
HAPPY TO WORK ON THIS ALONG WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. TO RAISE THE DISREGARD
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS IN
INTO CERTAIN INCREMENTS. TO
UPDATE IT TO ACCOUNT FOR
INCREASES IN INFLATION IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THEN EVENTUALLY INDEX IT FOR
INFLATION THEREAFTER SO WE DON'T
HAVE THE SAME DEGRADATION THAT
WE'VE HAD OVER THE PAST. TWENTY
YEARS THAT WOULD RESTORE THE
POLICY TO WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED IT TO BE ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS TWENTY TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN IT CREATED THE
COWARDS PROGRAM -- A SIDE
BENEFIT IS THAT IT WOULD IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE BECAUSE AS
THOSE WORKING PEOPLE LEAVE THE
ROLES WE NO LONGER GET CREDIT
FOR THEM IN THE FEDERAL WORK
PARTICIPATION RATE.
SO YOU REDUCE THE RISK OF
FEDERAL PENALTIES IN ADDITION TO
HELPING PEOPLE AVOID A CLIFF --
AND SO WE THINK THERE'S
PRECEDENT FOR THIS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE A VERY
SIMILAR CHANGE IN THE EARNED AND
INCOME TAX CREDIT.
IN OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE CHILD
CARE -- TO ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES
IN THE MINIMUM WAGE WE THINK
THAT THIS WOULD BE IT INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT WAY. TO HELP RESTORE
CAL WORKS TO ITS ORIGINAL INTENT
WHICH WAS TO REALLY SUPPORT THE
TRANSITION TO PEOPLE MOVING FROM.
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE TO WORK
WITHOUT PULLING THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDER THEM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WAS JOHNSON.
HOUSE SPEAKER THE DEPARTMENT'S
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU.
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE TASHA
THANK YOU -- SO THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT THE ID IS
OVERDUE FOR AN UPDATE ESPECIALLY
WHEN CONSIDERING THE ON GOING
AND PLANNED UPDATES TO THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND SUPPORTS
PROGRESS THAT ALLOWS AND
INCENTIVIZE IS FAMILIES TO
ENGAGE IN THE WORK FORCE WHILE
STABILIZING AND DEVELOPING
ADDITIONAL SKILLS FOR OVERCOMING
ADVERSITY.
AND ENCOURAGES AND THE
CONSIDERATION OF HOW THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS
INTERACT -- AND WOULD SUGGEST
THE SORT OF THE CAN BE COMBINING
THEIR FOR IT CONSIDERING THE
ASSOCIATED COSTS AS WELL AS A
PRIORITY IS.
WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND EXAMINE FISCAL
RESULTS IN A LINE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES IN
POSITIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD EXPECT --
AS MR MECCA NOTED THAT THIS
PROPOSAL COULD SUPPORT AN
INCREASE IN THE WORK
PARTICIPATION RATES -- AND
FINALLY CAL OR DOES INCLUDE
MEASURES THAT WILL TELL US HOW
THE EARNINGS OF PARTICIPANTS
CHANGE OVER TIME AND WILL BE
HELPFUL AND ILLUSTRATED IN THIS
IN THIS REGARD.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU.
SOUNDED LIKE A POSITIVE RESPONSE
[inaudible]
INDEED YES.
HELLO WHO WHO DO WE HEAR FROM
NOT NEXT -- FROM THE FINANCE. TO
VERIFY ITS HER WORDS AS MISS
NICOLE I NOTED -- MERITS OF THIS
POLICY.
PROPOSAL NOT WAS STANDING WE
WOULD NOT SUPPORT THIS TIME
GIVEN THE THE COSTS SURROUNDING
THESE AND IT'S HAVING NOT BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNMENT'S
BUDGET.
THANK YOU HELLO A LA -- JAZZ ALL
OVER THE LA L. -- WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ON THIS
PROPOSAL BUT HAPPY TO WORK WITH
STATUTES THAT SIMPLY CONSIDERS
IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR BACK I ALSO I WANT TO THANK
YOU BECAUSE I KNOW THAT.
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA -- IT
[inaudible]
IS.
MANY IN IN THIS AREA NO HAVE
BEEN MAJOR PARTNERS IN IT NOW
SET IN THE FIGHT AGAINST POVERTY.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- IN
LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE IN
LOOKING AT HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
IT ISN'T JUST THAT.
YOU ARE THE DIRECTORS AND JUST
GIVE ME THE PROGRAMMER WILL TAKE
CARE OF IT BUT NO WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE PROGRAM WE SEE
THE BIG PICTURE.
YEAH WE KNOW WHAT WE WANT TO END
UP LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW WE HOW
WE GET THERE.
AND THERE ARE ADJUSTMENTS THAT
WILL BE MADE TO THE BUDGET JUST
AS MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT -- AND IT'S
FIGURING OUT WITH PRIORITIES ARE
AND IT WITH ALL OF THESE IT'S
FIGURING OUT WHEN WE'RE GOING TO
DO THEM.
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO DO THEM
BUT DO THEM WE MUST AND I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
VERY GOOD LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO
ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE LET'S TALK ABOUT THE TIME
CLOCK.
MR HELD BEFORE YOU BEGIN.
EARLIER YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT TO THE TWIN THERE ARE -- WE
HAVE THERE ARE YOU DIDN'T USE
THE WORD LOBBYISTS THAT THERE
ARE ADVOCATES. FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER AREAS -- THAT -- HELLO
WHAT THE WORD IS HIGH PAID --
BUT THEN WE HAVE THOSE WHO ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED.
AND IF THERE ARE SOME AREAS
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THE
ADVOCATES AND THAT'S ONE ONE WE
WELCOME.
THOSE WHO ARE WORKING WITH THEM
THAT'S WHY WHEN SEIU IS HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THEIR WORK AS IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICE.
WORKERS ARE WHEN WITH THE CHILD
CARE WORKERS.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE
AREN'T THOSE HIGH PAID LOBBYISTS
WHO COME IN AND ADVOCATE FOR THE
VERY PEOPLE THEY'RE SERVING.
I WANT TO THANK YOU BECAUSE YOUR
VOICE IS SO IMPORTANT TO ADD
YOUR YOUR ORGANIZATION'S VOICES
SO IMPORTANT. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ADVOCATES ARE AT THE TABLE
THAT THE VERY PEOPLE WERE TRYING
TO SERVE IN EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO.
OUR START ALREADY AT THE TABLE
REPRESENTED FOR LIKE WITH PEOPLE
SUCH AS YOURSELF I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THEM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT'S
VERY NICE OF YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
TIME CLOCK OKAY -- AGAIN MY
CAROL.
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY -- SO --
I BELIEVE I CAN SAY THIS
FACTUALLY CORRECT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF YOUR CONSULTANT --
NONE OF YOU WERE HERE I BELIEVE
DURING THE TIMES WHERE WE MADE
REALLY ENORMOUS BUDGET.
RELATED.
CHANGES TO THE TOWERS PROGRAM IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND WE WEREN'T HERE BUT WE
WERE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND WE
WERE.
PAINED DURING THOSE TIMES AND
THAT IS WHY OUR OUR CONSULTANT
TO IS SO IMPORTANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE DID SHE IS.
AND I WOULDN'T WANT ANY OF YOU
TO EVER HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
EXPERIENCE I AM SINCERELY -- BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID
DURING THAT TIME AS WE MADE VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE CAL
ARTS PROGRAMS -- IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN
ALL OF THIS REALLY BEING DRIVEN
BY THE THE DIRE NATURE OF OUR
STATE BUDGET THAT POINT WE'RE
YOU KNOW.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN IN
DEFICITS IN THE GOVERNOR WAS
TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING TO TRY
TO FIND A WAY TO BRING THE
STATE'S -- FISCAL HOUSE BACK IN
ORDER -- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS DONE WAS THAT WE WE DID TWO
MAJOR THINGS TO CAL WORKS -- WE
DO MANY THINGS WE DID TWO MAJOR
THINGS WE REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
MONTHS FROM SIXTY MONTHS.
TO FORTY EIGHT THAT PUTS
CALIFORNIA IN THE MINORITY OF
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY EVEN
STATES LIKE MISSISSIPPI HAVE A
SIXTY MONTH TIME CLOCK FOR TAN
OF BENEFITS.
OUR STATE DOES NOT --
SECONDARILY -- THE FOLLOWING
YEAR WE TOOK THOSE FORTY EIGHT
MONTHS AND WE DIVIDE THEM INTO
TWO PIECES.
THE FIRST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS WAS
CHANGE IN WHAT WAS CALLED A
FLEXIBLE CLOCK WHICH ALLOWED
RECIPIENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN ANY
ACTIVITY THAT THE ASSESSMENT
DONE BY THE COUNTY DETERMINE WAS
NEEDED. FOR THEM.
THAT WAS POTENTIALLY POSITIVE.
BUT AFTER TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
WE'VE THEN IMPOSED A THE THE
CANNOT WORK FOR WORK REQUIREMENT
RULES WHICH WERE MORE RIGID THAN
ARE EVEN.
CALIFORNIA STATE ROLES THAT --
HAD BEEN IN PLACE FOR THE LAST
DECADE AND A HALF -- THE THE
EFFECTIVE THAT REALLY WAS FOR
MANY CLIENTS IS THAT THEY REALLY
FELT LIKE THEY THEY THEY HAD TO
GET ALL EVERYTHING DONE IN THE
FIRST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
IT REALLY -- MADE CREATED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CONFUSION
NOT JUST FOR OUR RECIPIENTS --
IN OUR CLIENTS AS WE SOMETIMES
CALL THEM BUT ALSO FOR THE
COUNTY WORKERS TRYING TO EXPLAIN
HOW TWENTY FOUR MONTHS WORK THE
OTHER TWENTY FOUR MONTH CLOCK
WORK.
HOW THE EXTENSION POLICIES WORK --
WAS ENORMOUSLY CONFUSING AND AND
REMEMBER THIS IS A POPULATION
THAT WHEN THEY COME IN THE DOOR
TO THE COUNTY WELFARE OFFICE
THAT FIRST DAY THEY'RE OFTEN IN
CRISIS THERE.
THERE ARE HOMELESS THEY HAVE A
CURRENT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION AND IN THEIR LIFE
THEY'VE -- THEY MAY BE GOING
THROUGH A DIVORCE IS ALL SORTS
OF THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
HIS FAMILY'S LIFE AND THEN WE
THROW ALL THIS INFORMATION OUT
ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT CLOCKS --
RAND ACTUALLY DID AN ANALYSIS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN THE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THIS AND
AND ESSENTIALLY CAME TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
THAT THE THAT MOVING TO THESE
TWO TWENTY FOUR MONTH CLOCKS
REALLY HAD NO APPRECIABLE IMPACT
ON THE PROGRAM AND REALLY DIDN'T
BENEFIT -- CERTAINLY NOT THE
RECIPIENTS AND IT REALLY WASN'T.
DOING ANYTHING TO REALLY MOVE
INVOLVEMENT PARTICIPATION AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT IN THE WELFARE TO
WORK PROGRAM.
SO FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS WAS A
FAILED POLICY AND ON THOSE
GROUNDS TO BEGIN WITH WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE. TO
REVERSE THAT DECISION IN THIS
BUDGET -- IN IN IN IN PARTICULAR
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE WAY THAT
THE CURRENT FORTY EIGHT MONTH
CLOCK IS STRUCTURED WITH THE TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTH CLOCKS.
IS A DIRECT IMPEDIMENT TO THE
ABILITY OF WELL WE DESCRIBED
EARLIER AROUND THE NEW PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING ROLLED OUT AROUND
CAL WORKS TWO POINT NO.
CAL OR THESE ARE REALLY MORE
MODERN PROGRAMS THAT OUR FAMILY
FOCUS GOAL ORIENTED SO HAVING.
A PROGRAM IN WHICH THE COUNTY
CANNOT MEET THE CLIENT WHERE
THEY'RE AT BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
FEDERAL OVERLAY OF RULES THAT
REQUIRES.
THEM TO HAVE TO PARTICIPATE IN
WHAT AND WORK FIRST ALL IN WORK
FIRST IS THE PRINCIPAL AND
FRANKLY ONLY ACTIVITY FOR MANY.
IT'S GOING TO ACT AS A AS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPEDIMENT TO OUR
ABILITY TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN THIS
NEW APPROACH THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER TODAY.
SO WE REALLY SEE THE NEED --
WALL WE'RE NOT ASKING -- FOR
STATUTORY CHANGES BROADLY WITH
THAT IN THE WALL FOR WORK
PROGRAM AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WE THINK A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
WOULD BE THE PROPER THE PROPER
WAY TO PROCEED ON THAT.
IN THIS AREA WE ARE ASKING FOR
THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH CLOCK.
WITH THE FEDERAL RULES TO BE
ELIMINATED AND THAT WE TAKE THE
TWENTY FOUR MONTH FLEXIBLE
APPROACH AND ADOPT THAT FOR THE
AN EXTENDED OUT TO THE FULL
LIMIT OF THE FEDERAL LAW.
OF SIXTY MONTHS ON THE TAN A
PROGRAM THE TWENTY THE FLEXIBLE
CLOCK COMPORTS PERFECTLY WITH
THE NEW DIRECTION THAT WE'RE
GOING AND WE THINK THAT THAT
OUGHT TO BECOME THE STANDARD
THAT WE USE IN THE CALPERS
PROGRAM GOING FORWARD -- ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE REALLY THINK
THE SIXTY MONTH CLOCK NEEDS TO
BE RESTORED.
IS AS YOU HEARD EARLIER WE
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION IS THE
KEY TO OUR CLIENTS SUCCESS OVER
THE LONG TERM.
BUT 50% OF THE PARTICIPANTS TO
COMMON TO THE COUCH BERMAN THE
FIRST DAY DON'T HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
THEY DON'T HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA SO THE IDEA THAT THEY
CAN GET THAT G. D. ACCOMPLISHED
AND THEN GET INTO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAM IF PERHAPS TRY
TO GET A BE A WHICH IS THE YOU
KNOW THE GREATEST THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN TO THEM IN TERMS OF
THEIR LONG.
TERM SUCCESS IT'S SIMPLY NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN IN FORTY EIGHT
MONTHS I MEET CLIENTS ALL THE
TIME WHO COME TO ME AND SAY WOW --
I'M SIX MONTHS OR A YEAR AWAY
FROM COMPLETING MY COURSE WORK
HERE.
BUT I JUST GOT MY LETTER FROM
THE COUNTY AND I'M I'M HIT MY
FORTY EIGHT MONTH CLOCK ANIMAL
LOSE ALL MY SERVICES IN MY
ABILITY TO COMPLETE MY PER WHAT
CAN I DO.
HI I DON'T HAVE A VERY GOOD
ANSWER FOR THAT IT'S IT'S SIMPLY
AN IMPEDIMENT RIGHT NOW TO
PERSONS BEEN ABLE -- TO OBTAIN
THE EDUCATION THAT WE KNOW THAT
WILL BENEFIT THEM THE GREATEST
IN THE LONG TERM.
AND THEN WE ALSO KNOW THAT MANY
FAMILIES HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN THEIR LIVES -- OUR
CLIENTS PATHS THROUGH WELFARE TO
WORK IS NOT ALWAYS A STRAIGHT
LINE -- THEIR POOR A LOT OF
THINGS OCCURRED TO THEM THAT.
MANY OF US DON'T GO THROUGH ON A
DAILY BASIS HAVING THEIR CAR
BREAK DOWN I'M NOT HAVING CHILD
CARE -- HAVING A CHILD WHO'S
STRUGGLING IN SCHOOL ARE
STRUGGLING IN THE COMMUNITY
WHICH REQUIRES THAT THEIR
ATTENTION AS A PARENT ARE ALL
THINGS THAT CAN SLOW DOWN THE
PATH OF A RECIPIENT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE SEE MANY
MANY FAMILIES AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO AS WELL VERSED IN
THE SUBJECT MATTER WE SEE SO
MANY FAMILIES WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EITHER IN THE
PAST OR CURRENTLY -- AND THESE --
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY OUR STATE
RULES WORK RIGHT NOW IS YOU
CAN'T GET A WAIVER -- FROM
WELFARE TO WORK REQUIREMENTS IF
YOU HAVE A SITUATION OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE UNLESS YOU CAN
DEMONSTRATE GOOD CAUSE FOR NOT
PARTICIPATING IN WELFARE TO WORK.
SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IT MEANS
THE PEOPLE END UP RUNNING THEIR
TIME CLOCKS TRYING.
TO MEET THE COUNTIES YOU KNOW
WELFARE TO WORK PLAN THAT THERE
THE COUNTY IS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE IN THE MEANTIME THOSE
MONTHS ARE ARE PASSING OFF THEIR
CLOCKS.
SO FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS WE
ARE ADVOCATING WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE A RETURN
TO THE SIXTY MONTHCLOCK.
ON THE WOMEN NATION OF THE
SECOND TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
FEDERAL TIME CLOCK HOW THE
ENTIRE SIXTY MONTHS BE DONE --
UNDER THE THE TERMS OF THE SB
TEN FORTY ONE FLEXIBLE WELFARE
TO WORK APPROACH AND THE MAKE
OTHER CONFORMING CHANGES THAT WE
DID DURING THE TIME.
THAT WE MADE THESE CHANGES TEST
BE TEN FORTY ONE TO RESTORE THE
PROGRAM TO WHERE IT WAS PRIOR TO
THOSE CHANGES THAT'S OUR REQUEST
IN THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WITH NIKOLAI NOW.
SWITCHED AT CAM JOHNSON SOLDIERS
ARE JOHNSON SHOULD.
WERE TAG TEAMING HERE.
I'LL JUST TURN TO THE QUESTIONS
AND ON PAGE FORTY OF YOUR AGENDA
AND AT THIS SPECIFIC PROPOSAL IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUT WE ARE AT AT HAPPY
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
THE COST ESTIMATES AND AND SO
FORTH -- AS AS MR HERALD
MENTIONED IN ALL ALL ALL BABIES
TRY TO HIT ALL OF THESE AND A
AND A STORY HERE AB YES THE RAND
REPORT AND THEN A YEAR OR TWO
AND THREE REPORTS I DID NOT SHOW
SIGNIFICANT AT OR DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES FOR THOSE WHO.
AT PARTICIPATED IN THAT TWENTY
FOUR A MONTH AS FLEXIBLE CLOCK --
THE RAND REPORT THE THE VERY
THOROUGH COMPREHENSIVE FOCUS
GROUPS WITH COUNTY STAFF WITH
PARTICIPANTS WITH STATE STAFF
AND OTHER PARTNERS IN DOING THAT
AND THE COMPLEXITIES.
OF THE TIME CLOCK WE'RE
CERTAINLY AT PRESENT THERE --
AND HARD TO TRACK I WILL NOTE
THAT -- WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LARGE
AND SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF TOWERS
PARTICIPANTS AT BEING REMOVED
FROM EIGHT AM TO AS A RESULT --
OVER THAT THE FULL COURSE OF
THESE AB POLICY CHANGES IN TIME
I FEWER THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY PARTICIPANTS HAVE BEEN
REPORTED AS BEING REMOVED FROM A
DUE TO FAILURE TO MEET THOSE
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS AT THE
TWENTY FOUR MONTH TIME CLOCK
FLEXIBILITY -- WE ALSO HAVEN'T
SEEN THOUGH THE EXTENT WE THAT
WE ARE OFFERED EXTENSIONS SO FOR
THE COUNTIES HAD EXTENSIONS THAT
THEY COULD USE TO SUPPORT --
PARTICIPANTS AND HAVING MORE
THAN TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AND WE
HAVE AN ALSO SEEN MANY OF THOSE
EXTENSIONS USE AGAIN MANY MANY
OF THE PARTICIPANTS HAVE MAYBE.
ZERO AT ZERO MONTHS AT TICKED.
ON THAT TIME CLOCK -- AND THAT'S
DUE TO THAT THE MANY EXEMPTIONS
AFTER COUNTING IT ADD GOING
FORWARD.
IN TERMS OF CAL OR IN WHAT WILL
KNOW WE WILL CERTAINLY AS
MYSTICAL I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
WILL KNOW ABOUT EARNINGS OVER
TIME AND SO -- THROUGH THE
COURSE AN EVOLUTION OF A
PARTICIPANT MOVING TO THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM EVEN POST FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE EARNINGS WE WILL
KNOW EARNINGS OVER TIME SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE KNOW WHAT
EARNINGS WERE.
AT EXIT AND TWO QUARTERS POST AT
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WE COULD
TELL -- IF IF HAVING MORE TIME
ON AID AND ASSISTANCE WOULD --
YIELDS ADD DIFFERENT EARNING
LEVELS OVER TIME.
IN TERMS OF AGAIN WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE CASE LOAD NOW IN
SPECIFICALLY SANCTIONED -- THIS
CERTAINLY WAS PART OF OUR
CONVERSATION IN A SINGLE
LOCATION STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS WE KNOW THAT THE
CASELOAD IS -- COMPRISED OF MANY
MORE THAT HAVE NEED INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT AND HAVE MORE
BARRIERS TO WORK -- THE THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN READY TO
WORK IN AND READY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE WORK FORCE HAVE DONE SO
IN THOSE THAT ARE STILL
PARTICIPATING DO YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL.
NEEDS -- TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
GET THEM ENGAGED IN WORK SO WE
DO NEED THAT INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES NEEDED -- OUR MOST
CURRENT NUMBERS WE HAVE -- A
LITTLE OVER FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
AB PARTICIPANTS IT AT OF TOTAL
SANCTIONED IN THE COW WORKS AT
CASELOAD -- AND THE AVERAGE TIME
ON AID FOR SANCTION CASE IS NOT
IN THE LONG TERM SANCTION WHICH
IS OVER TWELVE MONTHS.
IS ABOUT NINE AND A HALF MONTHS --
ON AVERAGE SO THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE CASE LOAD AT CAL
OR COMING AND AGAIN I WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE ACTUAL RESULTS OF
THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH TIME CLOCK.
THANK YOU FOR WILL FIND.
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCED HER
WORDS OKAY AT THIS TIME.
SIMILARLY OUR OFFICE HAS NO
SPECIFIC COMMENT ON THE PROPOSAL
ON ONE THING WE WOULD POINT OUT
IS THAT.
THIS PROPOSAL - THE GRANT
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAD TO SORT
OF START THE HEARING -- AS WELL
AS THE EARNED INCOME DISREGARD.
THERE ARE A SUITE OF POLICY
LEVERS THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
CAN EVALUATE WHEN THINKING ABOUT
HOW TO MOVE FOR WITH CAL WORKS
BUT CRITICS. TO THINK ABOUT THEM
IN CONJUNCTION -- THEY ARE
OPTIONS MANY OF THEM HAVE FISCAL
COST TO THEM SAID ALSO BEAR BEAR
THOSE ISSUES IN MIND BUT IT IT
REALLY.
WILL DEPEND ON HOW THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SERVICE SEIZE THE
PATH FOR FOR THE PROGRAM.
I THINK THAT THE EFFORT TO GET
US BACK TO THIS SIXTY MONTHS IS.
IS AN IMPORTANT -- IMPORTANT
EFFORT -- WE KNOW THAT THE THE
ISSUE THE IDEA.
IS CLEAR.
IT'S THE COST THAT IS A CLEAR.
SO AS WE DO EVALUATE AND DO YOUR
COM WHICH IS.
BOTH YOUR PARENTS ARE WELL TAKEN
THAT.
OF THAT IS ONE OF THE THE THE
THE AREAS THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING TO IS.
IS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE COST
IS GOING TO BE. FOR THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE -- TO MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
NOT THAT IT'S GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS LET'S GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
SIX STAGE.
ONE CHILD CARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME JENNIFER GRAVITY YES HI
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MADAM
CHAIR -- THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO COME SPEAK TODAY.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER CRAPPIE AND
I'M HERE WITH PARA VOICES
CALIFORNIA TO DISCUSS THE STRONG
START FOR CAL WORKS FAMILIES
BUDGET ASK -- VOICES CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER.
SEIU UT W. AND THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK.
ARE WORKING TOGETHER TO IMPROVE
THE ABILITY OF FAMILIES MACAU
WORKS PROGRAM TO GET THE EARLY
CONTINUOUS.
CHILD CARE THAT THEY NEED TO
IMPROVE THEIR FAMILIES PROSPECTS.
KNOWING THAT THEIR CHILDREN ARE
SAFE AND CARED FOR SO THAT THEY
CAN COMPLETE PROGRAM ACTIVITIES
AND MEET.
THERE CAO WORKS OBLIGATION.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN SO KEY
AND IMPROVING THE COW WORKS
PROGRAM.
INCLUDING REPEALING THE MAXIMUM
FAMILY GRANT.
STARTING.
TO THE PLAN TO LIFT A CASH
GRANTS AND KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
THE POVERTY.
AND WE REALLY SEE THIS BUDGET
ASK AS THE NEXT STEP TO A LONG.
TERM.
SOLUTION FOR FAMILIES.
THIS BUDGET INITIATIVE WAS
STREAMLINED STAGE ONE
ELIGIBILITY RULES.
SO THAT ALL CAO WORKS FAMILIES
ARE AFFORDED THE STABLE RELIABLE
AND CONSISTENT CHILD CARE THEY
NEED TO IMPROVE THEIR FAMILY'S
SUCCESS.
AND ALIGNS THE STAGE ONE RULES
GOVERNING TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY TO THAT EVERY OTHER
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA.
GIVING A STRONG START TO CLOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS BEFORE THEY
START.
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
CHILDREN OF COLOR.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IMPLEMENTS
THE TOP RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE
COW WORK STAGE ONE PROGRAM.
IDENTIFIED BY THE ASSEMBLY BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ON EARLY
LEARNING.
THE LIFTING CHILDREN OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE A ON THE
INTER AGENCY TASK FORCE ON CAL
WORKS CHILD CARE -- VOICES
RECENTLY CONDUCTED FOR FOCUS
GROUPS ACROSS THE STATE TO
INFORM THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION REPORT AND HEARD
COUNTLESS STORIES OF FAMILIES
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS.
OF THE COW WORKS CHILD CARE
PROGRAM.
IT'S PERRANCE LIKE BELL YOUR
FROM FRESNO COUNTY WHO LOST HER
CHILD CARE DURING THE PLAN
TRANSITION BETWEEN STAGES.
AND WAS FORCED TO RETURN TO CASH.
EIGHT DUE TO UNSTABLE CHILD CARE.
OR PARENTS LIKE SYLVIA FROM
HAYWARD WHO NEVER RECEIVED CHILD
CARE WHILE SHE WAS ON CACHET AND
HAD NO IDEA THAT SHE WAS
ELIGIBLE FOR CHILD CARE WHEN SHE
STARTED WORKING.
KATIE FROM SOLANO WHO HAD TO GET
NINE DIFFERENT AUTHORIZATIONS
FOR CHILDCARE IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS.
WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
SOME EASY SOLUTIONS TO THESE
PROBLEMS.
AND WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS BY.
PROVIDING EARLY DETERMINATION OF
ELIGIBILITY WITH TWELVE MONTHS --
AUTHORIZATION FROM DAY.
ONE ONCE DETERMINED ELIGIBLE FOR
CHILD CARE.
CHILDREN CAN STAY IN STABLE
CONTINUOUS CARE -- EVEN IF HOURS
OF ACTIVITY CHANGE OR UNLESS
THEIR INCOME GOES ABOVE 85% OR
IN TAYLOR TRANSFERRED TO STAGE --
TWO IT WOULD END THE PRACTICE OF
SHORT TERM AUTHORIZATIONS THAT
ARE TIED TO ACTIVITIES. TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY BUT ALSO BEGIN
TO ADDRESS THE VERY LOW UPTAKE
IN STAGE ONE CHILD CARE.
THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE OF LESS
THAN 30% OF FAMILIES IN A
WELFARE TO WORK ACTIVITY.
AND WITH AN AGE ELIGIBLE CHILD.
REFERENCED IN YOUR HEARING
MATERIALS ON PAGE.
FORTY TWO CHILD CARE IS OFF
OFFERED AT AVAILABLE WHEN NEEDED
TO PARTICIPANTS IN ANY PROGRAM
ACTIVITY THAT ALLOWS THE FAMILY
TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND OUT OF CRISIS AND TOWARD
STABILITY.
THERE ARE MANY TIMES WHEN
FAMILIES HAVE BARRIERS AND
CHALLENGES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED PRIOR TO MOVING IT TO
SCHOOL OR WORK.
SUCH AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MENTAL
HEALTH OR HOMELESS AND HOUSING
SUPPORT.
THE THIRD ELEMENT WOULD CREATE
AN ONLINE READ ONLY SUMMARY
SCREEN THAT CHILD CARE AGENCIES
AND COUNTY WELFARE OFFICES CAN
USE TO STREAMLINE.
TRANSFERRING CLIENTS FROM STAGE
ONE TO STAGE TO CHILD CARE
WITHOUT INTERRUPTION.
THE SCREEN WOULD PROVIDE THE
NINE DATA ELEMENTS NEEDED TO
ENROLL THE FAMILY INTO STAGE.
TWO AND IT WOULD ALSO PROVIDE
THE LAST STATE OF CASH SHE'D
RECEIVED.
THIS FIX WAS CONCEIVED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH C. W. D. A.'S
CHILD CARE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THE FOURTH PROPOSAL THAT
CAME FROM ONE OF OUR MEMBERS IS
TO PROVIDE FORMALLY AIDED
FAMILIES WITH ONE NEW NOTICE AT
THE EIGHTEENTH MONTH AFTER CASH
EIGHT STOPS.
THIS NOTICE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CHILD CARE SERVICES
FOR TWENTY FOUR MONTHS BECAUSE
POST CASH AID.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PRESS CONFERENCE WHEN SPEAKING
ABOUT DEEP CHILD POVERTY AND THE
COW WORKS PROGRAM.
GOVERNOR NEW SOME DECLARED I'M
SICK OF THIS SCAPEGOATING OF
THIS PROGRAM.
WE COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH THE
GOVERNOR.
INSTEAD OF BLAMING MOTHERS FOR
NOT SUCCEEDING IN THIS PROGRAM.
IT'S TIME THAT WE MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SYSTEM THAT
SET THESE FAMILIES UP FOR
SUCCESS AND FILL THE CRACKS THEY
KEEP FALLING THROUGH.
WE NEED TO START DISRUPTING
POVERTY AND STOP DISRUPTING
CHILD CARE AND SUPPORT ACCORDING
THIS PROPOSAL WILL DO JUST THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE POWERFUL LAST
SENTENCE.
THANK YOU YES.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE
HIM JOHNSON SOCIAL SERVICES AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY AT BOTH THINK --
SCRAPPY AND IMPAIR INVOICES IS
BEEN A PARTNER WITH US -- IN OUR
CAL OR STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUPS
AND SUPPORTING PARENTS AND
CURRENT AND FORMER PARTICIPANTS
IN THAT PROCESS AS WELL AS IN
THE COW WORKS AT CHUCKY
INTERAGENCY GROUP THAT SHE
MENTIONED.
THAT WE COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT
CHILD CARE IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR TOWERS
PARTICIPANTS -- IN ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS IN YOUR AGENDA HERE ON
PAGE TWENTY FOUR I THINK THE
FIRST ONE IS FOR US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT'S BEEN IDENTIFIED
ON PAGE FORTY THREE AND AND LET
YOU KNOW WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE AND
AVAILABLE AND WHAT ISN'T SO.
I'LL DO THAT AND I I WANT TO
JUST MENTION -- WHILE THE AGENDA
ALSO INCLUDES THE PARTICIPATION
RATE.
ARE THE CAO EXPERTISE OPINION
STAGE ONE BUT I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE WERE REMEMBERING THAT
AND THAT'S THE FIRST DATA SET
COMPONENT HERE THAT.
A COW WORKS FAMILY HAS ACCESS TO
A NUMBER OF CHILDCARE SUBSIDIES
ABOVE AND BE ON STAGE.
ONE AND SO WE DO SEE OUR CAO
EXPERTISE OFFENSE ABBOTT
DISSIPATING IN STATE PRESCHOOL
GENERAL CHILD CARE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PER.
MENTIONS ABOUT MIGRANT ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
MINISTERS AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE STAGE ONE THE UTILIZATION
AND YOU LOOK AT THREE AT
PARTICIPATION IN THOSE OTHER
PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION MINISTERS.
WERE CLOSER TO ABOUT 59% OF THE
POWER EXPERTISE DEPENDS AB
PARTICIPATING IN SOME FORM OF
STATE CHILDCARE SUBSIDY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT STILL AT A KIND OF
MINIMUM THRESHOLD BECAUSE AT CAO
EXPERTISE DEPENDS ARE
CATEGORICALLY EDGE ELIGIBLE FOR
HEAD START EARLY HEAD START --
AND THAT'S ALSO A PLACE WHERE
FANS HAVE GROWN OVER TIME SO WE
HAVE MORE OFFERINGS IN EARLY
HEAD START HEAD START THAN WE
HAVE TYPICALLY WITH NEW FUSION
OF DOLLARS THERE.
SO -- THERE'S ALSO AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND LOCAL SUBSIDY
PROGRAM SO WE DO -- WANT TO
INSURE THAT WERE SPEAKING ABOUT.
THE FACT THAT THE COUCH
PARTICIPANTS HAVE HAVE A CHOICE --
IN SELECTING THOSE AND SO AND
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHERE THERE IS DATA
AVAILABLE THAT UTILIZATION RATE
IS CLOSER 260%.
I IN TERMS OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS HERE A NUMBER OF HOURS
A WEEK OF CARE BEING AUTHORIZED
AND SO FORTH WE DO YOU -- MAKE
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE -- THE
KIND OF TIME IN CARE SO WE HAVE
54% OF THE STAGE.
ONE A PARTICIPANT'S UTILIZING
FULL TIME AND 46% YOU UTILIZING
PART TIME CARE.
IN TERMS OF FURTHER BEING
BREAKING DOWN KIND OF THE
DURATION OF THE AUTHORIZATION
OUR EXPERIENCE OF PARTICIPATING --
WE HAVE -- IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION ACT
COMMISSION CHILD TRENDS TO
CREATE A CHILD CARE SNAPSHOT
STUDY.
AND THAT CHILD CARE SNAPSHOT
STUDY OF THE OUTCOME OF THAT
WILL BE A DATA SET THAT TALKS --
TO EXACTLY SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS DURATION IN EACH OF
THE FUNDING STREAMS OF SUBSIDIES --
SOME FEEDBACK FROM CONSUMERS
THEMSELVES AND SO FORTH SO BACK
DATA SET WILL BE AVAILABLE IN
EARLY SUMMER.
AND WILL BE ABLE TO BE
ACCEPTABLE POSTED ONLINE FOR
ANYONE TO ACCESS IN TERMS OF
GETTING A A RICHER PICTURE.
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE --
SOME OF THESE OTHER AT DATA
POINTS AT THE LAST ONE HERE ON
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE FORTY
THREE THAT IS ALSO AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE NAY MORE THAN HAPPY
TO SEND THOSE LINKS AT TO TO THE
ADVOCATE SO THAT THEY THEY KNOW
IT'S AVAILABLE.
SOME OF THESE OTHER WILL REQUIRE --
WHAT WE CALL AT A SEARCH PRESENT
AND PLEASE DON'T ASK ME TO TELL
YOU IT THAT SEE?
MORE AT THE MOMENT BUT BASICALLY
IT'S IT'S WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC DAY THAT COMPONENT
AVAILABLE WE ASK THE SIZE THE
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEMS.
TO AS TAKE SOME SAMPLE DATA AND
AND IN A FIVE AT THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT -- THE COW WORKS OUT
COMES ACCOUNTABILITY REVIEW WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO LOOK MORE
GRANULAR ACCESS AT SOME OF THE
DEMOGRAPHICS BY EACH OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT AT PARTICIPANT AS
ADAM PARTICIPATING AND SO THAT
WAS ANOTHER.
OPPORTUNITY WILL BE ABLE TO
ANSWER SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
MORE SPECIFICALLY -- THROUGH CAL
OR IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM WE WOULD ALSO THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING IT'S CLEARLY IN
STATUTE THAT BE CAO WORKS
CHILDCARE STAGES WERE INTENDED
TO BE SEAMLESS SYSTEMS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT STAGES TWO AND
THREE DO YOU HAVE -- THE POLICY
THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED DO
DEPARTMENT DUCATION SO WHERE THE
LEAK HOW WORK STAGE ONE WAS
INTENDED TO BE THE SHORTEST TERM
OF THOSE AT THREE STAGES BUT TO
THINK ABOUT -- SOME OF THE
CONSEQUENCES AB DESTRUCTION TO
CHILD CARE AND WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR FAMILIES AS THEY ENTERED THE
CARRIAGE PROGRAM WE ALSO.
AGREE IS IMPORTANT TO DO -- SO I
THINK I HAVE COVERED THE
QUESTIONS THERE ON THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HER WITH
NO COMMENT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE REPORT --
THAT WAS PUT TOGETHER BY PARENTS
FORCES CALIFORNIA.
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT BODY
OF WORK THAT WAS DONE AFTER.
MUCH MUCH RESEARCH AND
INTERVIEWING JUST AS USE YOU
STATED -- THE SPEAKERS BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION ALSO --
ANOTHER REPORT AND I THINK ALL
THESE RICH EXTREMELY PART AND
THEY ALL POINT TO THE SAME THING
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
CHILDREN AND PROVIDE THAT CHILD
CARE -- AS AN ASIDE NOT RELATED
DIRECTLY TO THIS SO I CAN
MENTION IT -- I I I AM
SPONSORING A BILL I'M OFFERING A
BILL AB ONE NINETY FOUR
SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE A
BILLION DOLLARS.
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD. FOR
CHILD CARE FOR MORE CHILD CARE
SLOTS.
BECAUSE WE ALL RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS.
BUT I THINK YOU FOR PRESENTING
THIS I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A
DOLLAR AMOUNT WE DON'T KNOW THE
COST.
AND JUST AS WITH THE THE ONE
JUST BEFORE -- THOSE ARE THE
THINGS ARE WORKING ON AND I KNOW
THAT -- YOU.
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT ALL THAT IS
BEING DONE AND I IDEALLY AYE AYE
I'M SURE THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH DSS AND DO DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
FLUENTLY ACTS THEY BEEN AMAZING
PARTNERS -- THERE'S IS THAT
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
I'M SORRY ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
TERRIBLE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
SEVEN ON THE ASSET TEST
[inaudible]
MS BARTOLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST GIVE ARTS
OVER THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY I'M ALSO THE
STEERING COMMITTEE CHAIRPERSON
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSET BUILDING
COALITIONS SO I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT TODAY THE ADVOCATES.
PROPOSAL -- SUBMITTED BY WESTERN
CENTER AND BASS ABILITY
COALITION ALONG WITH EARNED
PROSPERITY NOW AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND SEE SEE DEBBIE RO. TO
REQUEST THAT THE ASSET TEST FOR
THE COUCH PROGRAM BE ELIMINATED.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES AT THAT
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
DENIED AN APPLICANT -- CAL
ASSISTANCE IF THEY HAVE MORE
THAN TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS IN THE BANK OR
AN AUTO WORTH MORE THAN NINETY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THE AUTO RESOURCE TEST WAS IS
PART OF THE CAL THE ASSET TEST
ITSELF THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN ADJUSTED OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS IN THE BUDGET.
AND IT ALSO HAS A COST OF LIVING
INCREASE -- THE ASSET TEST WHICH
MEANS THAT EVERY YEAR THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE AND THE
AND THE COUNTIES HAVE.
TO ADJUSTED.
SO YOU MIGHT ASK YOURSELF WELL
HOW MANY CAO WORKS RECIPIENTS
CAN ACTUALLY SAVE THIS MUCH
MONEY YOU JUST HEARD.
HOW LITTLE PEOPLE HAVE TO LIVE
ON IN THE TOWERS PROGRAM EVEN
AFTER THE LARGEST INCREASE IN
THEIR GRANTS -- IN OVER A DECADE
TWO DECADES -- JUST HAPPENING
THIS MONTH WHICH HURT AGAIN
THRILLED AT THRILLED ABOUT -- IT
AS YOU HEARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO SAY THERE'S STILL A TOO
LITTLE TO IMAGINE LIVING OFF OF
AND THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS.
THAT RECIPIENTS A CAL WORKS ARE
NOT SAVING MONEY AND THEY'RE
BARELY GETTING BY -- BUT WHAT
THIS ASSET TEST DOES IS IT KEEPS
PEOPLE IT PRESENTS A VERY FOR
PEOPLE APPLYING FOR BENEFITS --
AND IT'S NOT A PERMANENT THERE
BY THE WAY WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
WHEN FAMILIES COME IN AND APPLY
FOR BENEFITS IF THEY HAVE ASSETS
LET'S SAY THEY'VE LOST A JOB --
THEY HAD A KNEE INJURY OR DEATH
IN THE FAMILY A FAMILY
SEPARATION OR SOME OTHER LIFE
CHANGING EVENT AND THEY COME IN
TO APPLY FOR BENEFITS TO HELP
PAY THE RENT AND THE BASIC NEEDS.
WHEN THEY GET THERE -- THEY
LEARN ABOUT THE ASSET TEST AND
AND WHAT THEY REALIZE IS IF THEY
JUST GO HOME.
AND SPEND DOWN THEIR ASSETS IF
THEY'RE STILL POOR THEY CAN COME
BACK IN AND APPLY IN FACT YOU
SEE A KIND OF TURNING OF
APPLICANTS -- PEOPLE COME IN A
MAY HAVE JUST OVER THAT THE
SAVINGS AMOUNT WHICH THAT
THEY'VE THEY'VE WORKED REALLY
HARD TO SAY.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE WORKED FOR
YEARS TO SAVE A THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND THEN TO BE TOLD THAT
THEY HAVE TO SPEND THAT DOWN IN
ORDER TO GET A LITTLE HELP WITH
THE RENT -- IS.
IT'S NOT A GOOD WAY TO START THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY -- FOR THE
CALIBER CHARACTER APPLICANTS --
RESEARCH HAS BEEN DONE IN SOME
OF THE OTHER STATES WHERE THIS
IS A REPEAL HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
LIKE ALABAMA AND LOUISIANA --
HAS SHOWN THAT LESS THAN 1% OF
THE THE APPLICANT'S OF ACTUALLY
HAD ASSETS OVER THIS AMOUNT --
AND SO BUT BUT THE TEST HAS TO
BE APPLIED TO EVERY APPLICANT.
SO IT'S ALSO BURDEN FOR THE
APPLICANTS AND THE WORKERS -- IN
ORDER TO SHOW THAT YOU HAVE --
ASSET BELOW THAT AMOUNT. 99% OF
THE APPLICANTS AGAIN WITH ASSETS
BELOW THIS AMOUNT THEY STILL
HAVE TO GET A PRINT OUT OF THEIR
LAST THREE MONTHS OF A BANK
ACCOUNT.
THE ONES THAT ARE CHALLENGE THE
MOST TO DO THIS ARE ACTUALLY THE
ONES THAT DON'T HAVE A BANK
ACCOUNT.
THEN THEY HAVE TO PROVE THEY
DON'T HAVE A BANK ACCOUNT.
AND THIS IS ACTUALLY REALLY HARD
TO DO IF YOU'VE EVER PROVEN YOU
DON'T HAVE A SOMETHING -- THEY
SAY WHAT DO YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO
I PROVE I DON'T HAVE A BANK
ACCOUNT -- SO WE END UP ASKING A
100% OF APPLICANTS. TO GET THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR BANK
ACCOUNT AND SUBMIT IT.
IF THEY IF THEY DON'T HAVE AS
THE THEIR BANK ACCOUNT
INFORMATION MAILED TO THEM THEY
THEY MAY HAVE AN ONLINE THEY
LACK INTERNET ACCESS TO HAVE TO
GO TO A PRINTER.
IT'S IT CAN BE QUITE BURDEN SOME
AND THEN EACH ONE OF THE
APPLICATION IS AT THE PEOPLE
UPSET ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS THE
CASE WORKERS ALSO HAVE TO REVIEW.
THE THE INFORMATION FOR A 100%
OF THE CASES WHEN LESS THAN 1%
OF THE CASES ARE TONIGHT
[inaudible]
SO.
I'M FOR BOTH EFFICIENCIES SO
THAT WE CAN -- FREE UP THE TIME
OF THE SOCIAL WORKERS SO THEY
CAN HELP PEOPLE FIND HOUSING
THEY CAN HELP PEOPLE FIND WORK
THEY CAN REMOVE BARRIERS -- AND
SUPPORT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS -- THERE'S SO MUCH TO
THE CASE WORKERS AT THE COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES COULD BE
DOING THAT BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILIES IN TRANSITION I'M FROM
POVERTY AN OUT OF POVERTY -- AND
THEN TO TO LOOK FOR PEOPLE'S
BANK ACCOUNTS WHICH 99% OF THE
TIME SAY THEY HAVE NOTHING.
WITH THAT SAID IT YOU KNOW JUST
A KIND OF AN CLOSING -- ASSETS
AND EARNINGS THESE TWO THINGS
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT IF WE
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE HELP
FAMILIES EXIT POVERTY RIGHT MOST
OF OF OF THE COUCH PROGRAM IT'S
EITHER.
PREVENTING HARM TO FAMILIES
WHILE THEY ARE LIVING IN POVERTY.
OR HELPING THEM EXCEPT POVERTY.
AND AND I RAIL I REALIZE THAT
THE ASSET -- THIS THIS PANEL IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE EARNINGS
PANEL BUT THEY REALLY DO BELONG
TOGETHER IN A SINGLE KIND OF
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT THE PROGRAM.
HAS A CORE INTERESTS TO HELP
PEOPLE EXCEPT POVERTY IN TO DO
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT EARNINGS.
AND ASSETS -- AND WITH THAT I'LL
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE AND A A STATE
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LIKE SPEAKER.
THANK YOU NATASHA BECAUSE CDSS --
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THE STATE
DOES RECOGNIZE THAT INCREASING
ABSOLUTE ASSET THRESHOLDS TO
SOME POINT MAY DECREASE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR
COUNTIES AND ALSO ALIGNED WITH
THE GOALS OF THE PROGRAM TO
ENCOURAGE WORKING SAVING
BEHAVIOR -- THAT ALLOW FOR
HOUSING IN LIFE STABILITY AN
UNEXPECTED TIMES OF HARDSHIP --
THAT SAID THE STATE DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THE PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE COLLEAGUES.
ON THIS PARTICULAR ONE I I I
WOULD ASK -- STE ALAMO FROM THE
LA -- IT WOULD WE DO NEED TO GET.
WITH.
THE COST PROPOSAL.
AND I WOULD ASK.
YOU REALLY HELP US WITH THIS
PARTICULAR REQUEST.
I THINK IF WE HAVE THE OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THIS -- AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
SAVING ON ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
AND WE'RE NO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
1% OR LESS THAN 1%.
OF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT -- IF
WE IF WE CAN GET A COST AND IF
IF YOU COULD.
HELP US WITH THIS REQUEST ARE WE
WOULD SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT
WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO I ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES -- I I
THOUGHT HE'D BE HERE -- HIS IS
SHARED THAT.
HE SAYS WHY DO PEOPLE HAVE.
TO THE SHAME TO SO MUCH BEFORE
THEY CAN GAIN ENTRY INTO THE
SERVICES THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
PROVIDE TO THEM.
AND I THINK YOU'VE DONE A GREAT
JOB OF TELLING US JUST THAT.
THANK YOU YES DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IT THIS THIS REMINDS ME
OF A LITTLE BIT OF A BILL I'M
WORKING ON RIGHT NOT RIGHT NOW
RELATING TO FLIPPING ON AND OFF
OF THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM --
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OF
PEOPLE'S OWN AND AND SO THESE
ARE THESE ARE REALLY REALLY
FRUSTRATING -BLEMS THAT
THE OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
VULNERABLE AND CREATE TREMENDOUS
CONFUSION AND IT JUST DOESN'T
NEED TO BE THAT WAY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRING THIS FORWARD.
I DO THINK IT'S THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD AND I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS WOULD ALIGN ITSELF OF WE
MADE THIS CHANGE IT WOULD ALIGN
ITSELF WITH THE CAL FRESH POLICY --
AND WITH MEDI CAL FOR FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN SO IT WOULD BE
ADMINISTRATIVELY MORE EFFICIENT
THAT WAY AS WELL.
THIS REVIEW JUST A QUICK
QUESTION HOW DO YOU PROVE THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE A BANK ACCOUNT.
A LOT OF THINGS YOU HAVE TO
PROVE YOU DON'T HAVE WE JUST
SELL THEM TO SAY THEY DON'T HAVE
A BANK ACCOUNT -- BUT IF THEY
HAD A CLOSER OF THE BANK ACCOUNT
SOME PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE BANK
ACCOUNTS THIS IS THAT THEY HAVE.
A DEFICIT IN THE ACCOUNT -- SO
MAYBE SHOW THAT -- AND AND YEAH
IT IS COMPLICATED -- WE WE JUST
TELL THEM TO SAY THEY DON'T HAVE
ONE AND AND A SWEAR IT ON A
PIECE OF PAPER.
AND THAT BUT THEN BUT THEN THE
COUNTY HAS TO GO LOOKING RIGHT
INTO THE COUNTY CAN'T STOP THERE
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
COMPLICATED THE COUNTY HAS A
THAN GO LOOKING THROUGH THE THE
DATABASE IS FULL OF OF OF
INFORMATION.
WOW.
THANK YOU.
I JOIN IN -- DOCTOR WOULDN'T
THANKING YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
AND THE LAST ISSUE ON CAL WORKS
ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT ON HOMELESSNESS IS THE
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
MR HURLED WILL BEGIN WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND BACK AGAIN.
AND THE THE WORD THAT YOU HAD
USED WAS POWERFUL INTERESTS I
JUST COULD NOT -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOR FINDING THE OF THAT WORD HE
WAS NOT TO HIGH PAID LOBBYISTS
THAT WAS NOT THE WORD YOU USED.
YOU TALKED ABOUT POWERFUL
INTERESTS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THAT
POWERFUL INTEREST BECAUSE YOU
ALL ARE POWERFUL HERE FOR US.
FOR HOPEFULLY THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU -- YOUR YOUR
CONSULTANT IS EVER EFFICIENT --
HOPEFULLY I THIS WILL BE A
SOMEWHAT LESS ELONGATED THAN
SOME OF MY OTHER PRESENTATIONS
TODAY -- BUT I WANTED TO BRING
FORTH TO YOU AN ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE FOR
MANY YEARS NOW -- AND WE ARE
AGAIN.
BRING FORTH A PROPOSAL RELATED
TO THE HOMELESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM I'M FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE AGAIN THAT --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS -- COME
FORTH WITH A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
AROUND ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS THAT EXISTS IN
OUR STATE HAS A VERY AMBITIOUS
PLAN FOR TRYING TO BILL THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION UNITS -- THE
LEGISLATURE OBVIOUSLY IS FULLY
ENGAGE WITH THIS ISSUE WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THERE WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
PACKAGE OF BILLS AND LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PROPOSALS I SHOULD SAY.
THAT WILL BE COMING FORTH THIS
YEAR AND TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS OUR
TO FURTHER ADDRESS THE ISSUES
AROUND HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH FOR OUR
CLIENTS I MEAN I USED TO BE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATE IN A
PRIOR JOB.
AND I I KNOW THAT THE TIMELINE
FOR BRINGING THOSE UNITS ONLINE
IS GOING TO TAKE.
SEVERAL YEARS -- UNFORTUNATELY
RIGHT NOW OUR CAL WORKS
RECIPIENTS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES WITH HOMELESSNESS TODAY --
AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO AND
OBVIOUSLY OF WITH THE INCREASE
IN THE GRANT LEVELS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING WE DO THINK
THAT THAT WILL ASSIST IN TRYING
TO ALLOW SOME FAMILIES TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP THEIR HOUSING MORE.
BUT INCREASINGLY THE GULF
BETWEEN WHAT OUR TOWERS FAMILIES
MAKE.
LIVING AS MR AS LAINEY NOTED
EARLIER THE AVERAGE GRANT OF
LOOK JUST 38% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL RIGHT NOW -- AND
THE COST OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
THE GOAL IS JUST SO EXTREME THAT
WE ARE SEEING AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING TO
COUNTY OFFICES ASKING FOR HELP
WITH HOUSING ASSISTANCE EITHER
THROUGH THE HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM.
FAMILY STABILIZATION OR THE LONG
STANDING PROGRAM CALLED THE
HOUSING -- THE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM -- ONE
BERRIER THOUGH THE IN THE
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
CHANGE FOR MANY YEARS.
IS -- THE CURRENT LAW -- WE
PERMITS THAT WE PROVIDE HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE -- FOR UP TO SIXTEEN
DAYS -- BUT THE WAY THE CURRENT
POLICY WORKS IS THAT.
IF YOU IF A FAMILY COMES IN AND
THEY GET SIXTEEN DAYS OF
TEMPORARY HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
BUT TURNS OUT THAT THEY ONLY
NEED SEVEN DAYS THEY FIND
HOUSING WITHIN SEVEN DAYS.
THEY EFFECTIVELY THE WAY TO KEEP
THE STATE COUNTS IT IS THEY'VE
USED UP THEIR ENTIRE SIXTEEN
DAYS.
AND SO -- OUR PROPOSAL IS REALLY
QUITE SIMPLE WE THINK SEVEN DAYS
SHOULD BE SEVEN DAYS AND THAT
WOULD AND THAT WOULD MEAN THAT A
FAMILY COULD COME BACK IF THEY
HAD ANOTHER EPISODE HOMELESSNESS
DURING THAT SAME YEAR.
COULD COME BACK TO THE PROGRAM
AND GET ADDITIONAL NINE DAYS
THAT THEY COULD USE TOWARDS.
FINDING HOUSING ASSISTANCE --
SEARCHING FOR HOUSING ASSISTANCE
WHILE WE GOT TEMPORARY HOUSING.
REALLY THAT'S THE SUM AND
SUBSTANCE OF OUR PROPOSAL --
THIS IS -- BEEN PROPOSING A BILL
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
ACTUALLY SAT IT IN PRIOR YEARS
ANY AGAIN HAS IT THIS YEAR AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS WILL BE
THE YEAR THAT THIS IS THIS
LANGUAGE STICKS IN THE BUDGET.
AND WE MAKE THIS SIMPLE CHANGED
WHAT WE THINK IS BEEN A LONG
TERM PROBLEM.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER HI I SAID IN OUR
HOUSING ASSISTANCE ALL RIGHTS
BRANCH CHIEF AT CSS.
AND SO WE COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THAT THE SIXTEEN
DAYS OF EMERGENCY SHELTER
PROVIDED BY TEMPORARY HOME WITH
ASSISTANCE IS REALLY CRUCIAL --
FOOD TO ALMOST FAMILIES
RECEIVING CAL WORKS WE ARE ALSO
REALLY AWARE THAT THOSE BENEFITS
IN AND OF ITSELF DOES NOT SOLVE
SOMEONE'S HOMELESS CRISIS -- AND
THAT WE HAVE REALLY ENCOURAGE IT
CSS TO ENSURE THAT WERE BREEDING
THESE FUNDING STREAMS -- THIS HA
BEING SORT OF THE STOP GAP
EMERGENCY SERVICES -- RATING
THAT WITH OUR HOUSING SUPPORT
PROGRAM OUR FAMILY STABILISATION
PROGRAM OR CONTINUALLY AS WE'RE
SEEING MORE STATE FUNDING
THROUGH OTHER.
CONTINUUM OF CARE FUNDING
STREAMS IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
TO REALLY ENSURE THAT WE ARE
STABILIZING FAMILY BEYOND SORT
OF AN EMERGENCY MOTELS AFTER.
AND SO WE'RE NOTING THAT WHILE
YOU KNOW.
THERE IS MUCH TO BE DONE AND TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS THIS
EMERGENCY SHELTER PIECE IT JUST
BE ALSO ALLOWS -- AND BECAUSE
EVEN IN SIXTEEN DAYS IF YOU'RE
USING THE FULL SIXTEEN DAYS IT'S
OFTEN TAKING IN THIS MARKET MUCH
LONGER THAN SIXTEEN DAYS TO FIND
YOUR NEXT.
NEXT UNIT AND SO WE'RE STOP
GAPPING THAT WAS NUMBER OF THERE
ARE OTHER FUNDING STREAMS RIGHT
NOW -- INCLUDING NOT JUST SORT
OF FOR AGES P. IN PARTICULAR NOT
JUST A RENTAL SUBSIDY BUT THAT
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT THAT
REALLY IS REQUIRED TO HELP
SOMEONE FIND THEIR NEXT UNIT.
SO JUST OF NOTING THAT THE
BREEDING OF ALL THESE THINGS
TOGETHER AS WE TALKED ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT TODAY WITH ALL THESE
CAL WORKS -- PIECES IS REALLY A
KEY PIECE TO KEEP AN IN MIND --
AND YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT PER YEAR YOUR QUESTIONS IN IT
AND MY CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
HERE I THINK THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
A BIT MORE THAN JUST THE SIXTEEN
DAYS THING THE OTHER ITEMS WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT IS IS THE
SIXTEEN DAYS PLUS SORT OF TELL.
ME IF I'M WRONG -- BUT A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT ALSO ENCOURAGING IT TO
TO REMOVE THAT -- ONE YEAR
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING FOR
ADDITIONAL DAYS BEYOND SIXTEEN
BUT I COULD BE SO THEY DIDN'T
MENTION OKAY I JUST I DIDN'T
WANT IT DIDN'T SORT OF WANT TO
GET INTO COSTS IF THAT'S NOT IT
SO WE WE HAD LOOKED LAST YEAR A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
ABOUT.
HOW MUCH JUST USING THE FULL
SIXTEEN DAYS WOULD COST -- THINK
IN SORT OF REPEAT THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO LOOK AT
SORT OF THE SECOND PIECE OF THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH IF YOU WANT.
TO CHIME IN ON SO I DON'T SPEAK
FOR YOU -- WE THINK WOULD BE
QUITE EXPENSIVE -- AND SO WE
NEED TO DO A LITTLE BIT A
LOOKING INTO THAT AND AND JUST
SORT OF REALLY REITERATING THAT
THAT THE LONG TERM STABILITY
PIECE OF THIS THAT WERE REALLY
TRYING TO FOCUS ON BUT WE HAVE
NO PROOF WE HAVE NO SORT OF
FORMAL.
SHE'S THE RIGHT GUY I DID FORGET
TO MENTION THAT WE ARE ASKING
FOR THE LIMIT ON ONCE A YEAR
SYSTEMS -- FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
I'M NOT SUFFERING FROM DOMESTIC
AN INCIDENT OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BE LIFTED ALSO MY APOLOGIES FOR
FOUR MILLION AT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
LIKE SPEAKER.
VERY GOOD -- QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM YES MISS RUBIO -- JUST THE
COMMENTS ARE YOU HE SAID THAT --
THE SIXTEEN DAYS WON'T TAKE
ANYBODY OUT OF HOMELESSNESS IT
WON'T EVEN MAKE A DENT ON JUST
YOU KNOW -- SURVIVING REALLY A
MONTH ESPECIALLY FOR VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUT YOU KNOW
IF WE CAN DO.
MORE IN A I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
SAY ABOUT THE MONEY AND IT'S ALL
ABOUT THE MONEY WE UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
ISSUES NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE AT
STAKE.
HERE IT'S NOT YOU KNOW SOMETHING
ARBITRARY SO.
CAN I I WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE FOR
THE HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT
PROGRAM HAS CONTINUED TO
INCREASE IN FUNDING OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND THERE'S AN
EXPECTED INCREASE THIS YEAR.
AND NOT REALLY IS MORE ABOUT
PROVIDING THE CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES AND THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE TO FIND SOMEONE A
UNIT ACKNOWLEDGING THAT EVEN
SIXTEEN DAYS IS REALLY NOT GOING
TO GET THEM FULLY STABILIZE AND
THAT PROGRAM IS CONTINUE TO
EXPAND AND CONTINUES TO SERVE.
AND AND HOW IS MORE MORE
FAMILIES EVERY YEAR RIGHT AND
REALLY NOT FULL AND YEAH BUT NO
BUT IT GOES BACK TO YOU KNOW
WHAT IS IT THAT FEET SOMEBODY
FOR OUR GIVE SOMEONE FISH.
TEACH MODIFICHE THEN YOU KNOW IF
WE CAN PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES I
THINK THAT WOULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
BY SAYING.
THAT THE FUNDING HAS INCREASED
AND IF WE CAN PROVIDE YOU KNOW
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AROUND THAT
THEN THAT WOULD BE I THINK THE
IDEAL SITUATION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR ELLO -- IF WE WERE TO TAKE
JUST THE FIRST PART OF THE
PRESENTATION -- AND NOT.
LIMITING IT TO SIXTEEN DAYS
CONSECUTIVE.
BUT I ALLOWING FOR SIXTEEN DAYS
ANNUALLY.
DO WE HAVE AN ESTIMATE ON WHAT
THE COST WOULD BE.
OUR OFFICE HASN'T DONE A
SPECIFIC ESTIMATE ON THAT BUT WE
WOULD BE HAPPY I BELIEVE THE THE
DEPARTMENT DID LOOK AT THIS
QUESTION LAST YEAR.
WE CAN COORDINATE BOTH OF YOUR
STAFF WITH THEM TO TRY TO
FACILITATE INVESTMENT IN THE AND
THEN.
THE SORT OF PROCESS HERE IS THE
BUDGET WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS THE
END OF THE CAL WORKS SECTION
SECTION [inaudible]
AND IF I MAY I I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY. TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE DEPARTMENTS YOU'VE BEEN
VERY ENGAGED TO YOUR YOUR
PERSISTENCE AND YOUR HELP IN
THIS AREA HAS BEEN IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AND I SINCERELY APPRECIATE WHAT
ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THIS
REGARD.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
TIME TO WELCOME TO TASHA NIKOLAI.
IS A CAL WORKS AND CHILD CARE
BRANCH CHIEF.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD LIKE --
TO JUST REMIND YOU.
WE LOOK AT MY LITTLE NOTE SEE
WHAT I SAID AT THE VERY
BEGINNING -- WE WE WANT TO LIMIT
IT [inaudible]
HI.
LIMITED TO TO ONE MINUTE.
THE COALITION CALIFORNIA WILL
WILL PROVIDE CERTAIN
RESERVATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ITEM. ONE TWO EIGHT THEN I
DON'T WANT TO EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BEEN
ASKING A WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON ITEM ONE SURE IN SUPPORT OF
ADVOCATES PROPOSAL TO LIFT
CHILDREN OUT OF THE POVERTY.
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA LATINAS
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE IN THE
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP.
ON ISSUE THREE DEALING WITH THE
HOME VISITING INITIATIVE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP ON BEHALF OF
THEM THESE OF THE PUNK COMMENTS.
WE ARE AN EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM --
HEALTH COMMUNITY HEALTH PROGRAM
BACK BY FORTY YEARS OF RESEARCH
TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING FOR PREGNANT WOMEN. TO
THE TWENTY EIGHTH WEEK OF
PREGNANCY UNTIL THE CHILD TURNS
TWO YEARS OLD.
WE'VE BEEN HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH
DSS ON THE HOME VISITING
INITIATIVE WE EXPECT TO BE IN
ABOUT TWELVE COUNTIES -- THROAT
THIS YEAR AND LOOK FOR THE
EXPANSIONS ON THAT.
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN DSS AND WORKING
HARD TO IMPLEMENT THE HOME
VISITING INITIATED FOR CAL WORKS
FAMILIES.
AS THE ESTABLISHED HOME VISITING
MODEL -- WE APPRECIATE THE
SUGGEST IT WE OFFER THESE
SUGGESTIONS IN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS GOING FORWARD.
WE BELIEVE IS THE ADVOCATES
PROPOSAL OUTLINES THAT WE NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR DSS FOR
DATA COLLECTION.
AND WILL BE WORKING THROUGH
THESE ISSUES ON IMPLEMENTATION
TO GET TO THE EVALUATION PIECES
THAT WE THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM.
SUCCESSFUL.
IN ORDER TO HELP EXPECTING
MOTHERS OBTAIN THE BEST OUTCOMES
ARE MOMS NEED TO BE ENROLLED IN
AN S. P. BY THE TWENTY EIGHTH
WEEK SO WE APPRECIATE THE
PREGNANCY FIX LANGUAGE IN THERE.
AND LOOK FOR THE WORKING ON THIS
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THEIR SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE AND
WOULD WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
NEWSMEN MINISTRATION. FOR THE
INVESTMENT IN ENDING DEEP
CHILDHOOD POVERTY -- THE COUNTY
ESTIMATES THAT APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN HUNDRED FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN WOULD BE LIFTED OUT OF
POVERTY IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY --
FROM THIS ONE BUDGET PROPOSAL
ADDITIONALLY THE COUNTY SUPPORTS
ISSUE NUMBER -- THREE THE AROUND
THE HOME VISITING INITIATIVES --
SANTA CRUZ ACTUALLY WAS PROVIDED
SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT I WORKED WITH
THEM ON CREATING THE HOME
VISITING INITIATIVE AND THEY
THINK OF A MORE INVESTMENT WILL
MEAN THAT THE COUNTY CAN TOUCH
MORE FAMILIES AND I CAN PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AB SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE SEIU
CALIFORNIA WANT TO UPSET SAY OUR
SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE OUR APPRECIATION WITH
CONCERNS FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWO
ONE OF REFERENCE THE POINTS OF
FRANK MACKESY WTA MADE.
REGARDING HIS -- DEVIL BEACON
THE DETAILS SO JUST WHEN THAT.
BUDGET ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
SHAKES OUT THOSE DOUBLES DETAILS
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WILL INSURE
US AFICIONADO FUNDING FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS AN ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
TO CONTINUE TO DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK THEY DO.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ITEMS. THREE
FOUR FIVE AND SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARTHA GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE ARE SUPPOSE IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE AN ISSUE NUMBER TWO WE
OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S -- SINGLE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY --
REDUCTION PROPOSAL -- AND ON
ISSUE ON THE SAFETY NET RESERVE
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE -- ISSUE NUMBER THREE WE
ARE OF THE SUPPORT OF OF THAT AS
WELL AND ON ISSUE NUMBER -- FOUR
WE HAVE OVER -- FOURTEEN
THOUSAND CAL WORKS HOMES
PARTICIPANTS WE HAVE A UNIQUE
IDENTIFIER AND FOURTEEN THOUSAND
IS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO HELP STABILIZE
FAMILIES AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO -- DEEPLY UNDERSTANDS IN
HER DISTRICT SHE KNOWS THAT THAT
IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE SO.
ON THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WILL
HELP THEM GET OUT OF THE POVERTY
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENT IN THE COUNTY
ALAMEDA AND WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND WE THINK
GOVERNOR NUISANCE OF AN
INSPIRATION. FOR HIS WE WE
INVEST IN CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I WAS SHORT THANKS.
TO TESTING THEIR ANSWER ON THE
REST OF YOU.
IT DOESN'T ET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES --
COUNTIES APPRECIATE THE REASON
INVESTMENTS ABOUT THE
LEGISLATION THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR CAL WORKS AND WORKED HARD TO
PARTNER ON IMPLEMENTING IS
IMPORTANT REFORMS IN THE
PROGRAMS.
ARE SPECIFICALLY ON THE SINGLE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE CONTINUING CONVERSATION
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
I REVISED METHODOLOGY IN COMING
TO A PLACE -- THAT AVOIDS BOTH
THE SIGNIFICANT YEAR TO YEAR
FLUCTUATIONS AND PROVIDE
ADEQUATE FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARY NAY SAYS I'M THE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZER FOR PARENT VOICES WE
HAD ABOUT TWENTY PARENTS HERE
TODAY FROM.
A LOT OF YOUR DISTRICTS BUT THEY
HAD TO GO BACK BECAUSE OF
CHILDCARE ISSUES HOWEVER I'M
GLAD THAT YOU'RE HERE.
THANK YOU SO ISSUE ONE WE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT LIFTING UP
ALL FAMILIES ABOVE THE POVERTY --
ISSUE THREE AROUND HOME VISITING
AS YOU EXPAND HOME VISITING WE
WOULD JUST ALSO SUGGESTS THAT --
WE'VE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
PARENTS THEY HAVE MULTIPLE HOME
VISITORS SO HOW DO YOU LIKE
REALLY STREAMLINED AND HAVE ONE
REALLY QUALITY HOME VISITOR.
AND POSSIBLY NOT CALL IT HOME
VISITING BECAUSE THAT HAS A
NEGATIVE CONNOTATION AND IT
FEELS LIKE SOMEONE'S COMING INTO
YOUR HOME IS GOING TO TAKE YOUR
CHILD OR TAKE YOUR HOUSING OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO SOME SORT
OF PARENT PARTNERSHIP -- ISSUE
FOR WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT -- THE
EARNED INCOME DISREGARD -- AND
GETTING RID OF THE THE ASSET
LIMIT TEST -- AND AS YOU TALK
ABOUT THE CAL WORKS TIME CLOCK
WE ALSO BSOLUTELY.
AGREE WITH RESTORING IT TO SIXTY
MONTHS YOU KNOW WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT IN THIS BUILDING THAT SOME
RECESSION IS COMING -- THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE A RAINY DAY FUND
BUT THERE'S NO RAINY DAY FUND
AND NO PROTECTION FOR FAMILIES
IF THAT RECESSION COMES IN AT
THEIR CLOCK IS ENDED.
BEFORE THE RECESSION THEY HAVE
NO WAY OF COMING BACK INTO THE
SAFETY NET PROGRAM -- AND
ADJUSTABLE BARTOLO DESCRIBED --
THE PEACE AROUND WHAT ARE THE
WORKAROUNDS AROUND A BANK
ACCOUNT.
AND ONE OF OUR MEMBERS HAD SAID --
WE DON'T WANT TO WORK THE SYSTEM
WE WANT A SYSTEM THAT WORKS AND
SO THE MORE WE CAN CENTER
FAMILIES AND THEY'RE REALLY
EXPERIENCES NAVIGATING THIS VERY
COMPLICATED SYSTEM.
AND HELP REMOVE THOSE OBSTACLES
AND BARRIERS SO THAT ALL THEY
WANT TO DO IS SUCCEED ALL THEY
WANT TO DO IS IS HELP THEIR
CHILDREN AND AND HAVE A GOOD
LIFE AND THEY WANT TO DO WITH
INTEGRITY BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THEY ARE AND WE'VE GOT TO GET
RID OF THESE.
THINGS THAT STOP THEM FROM DOING
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN THE CLEARLY I LET
YOU SPEAK BEYOND ONE MINUTE BUT
YOUR AN IMPORTANT LEADER IN THE
SPACE AND I WANTED TO BE SURE
THAT.
THE REST OF THE PEOPLE HEARD
FROM YOU YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF
WORK IN THIS AREA THAT YOU PUT
TOGETHER A GREAT REPORT.
BUT I THINK ANYBODY WHO'S
WORKING IN THIS AREA SHOULD BE
READING SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR BRINGING
SO MANY OTHER ADVOCATES WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MONNING ABOUT THIS I'M A PARENT
LEADER OF PERRIN VOICES AND THE
FORMER FAMILY ADVOCATE FOR HEAD
START.
AND I SUPPORT THE CALL WORKS
PROPOSAL.
AND I SEE THE CHALLENGES WITH
FAMILIES -- IN I'M I'VE BEEN AN
ACTIVE LEADER FOR PARENT VOICES
BUT JUST FEEL HAVING THAT
FEELING OF A WORKING AS A FAMILY
ADVOCATE AND I I STILL SEE THAT.
THAT THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY
CHANGES AND I REALLY WANT TO
SUPPORT THE CALVET PROPOSALS
THAT WAS -- GET ENOUGH ASKED
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YEAH HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARIA Là STORY -- I'M FROM
BENTLEY SAN FRANCISCO.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT BECOMING A
PARENT WOULD MAKE ME REALLY POOR.
SO I HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHEN HE
STARTED VOICES MY KIDS WERE --
EIGHTEEN MONTHS MY INFANT
DAUGHTER WAS EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND
MY SON WAS TWENTY THREE MONTHS.
AND MY FIRST PAYCHECK WENT TO
PAY FOR CHILDCARE.
BUT BEFORE I STARTED WORKING AS
A PARENT WAYS ORGANIZER I WAS A
STAY AT HOME MOM FOR THREE YEARS.
AND I WAS ON CAL WORKS BEFORE IT
WAS CALLED CAL WORKS SO I DIDN'T
IT THEN TOOK IT WAS AT THIS
REGARD AND WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO
ACCESS IT AND I'M GLAD THAT NOW
THAT WE HAVE -- CHILD CARE
THAT'S BETTER ACCESSIBLE FOR
FAMILIES BUT I THINK THAT.
WE HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN
MAKE IT BETTER THE TRIP OF CAL
WORK STATES ONE PARTICIPANTS
LIKE ALL OTHER.
CHILDCARE SUBSIDY PARTICIPANTS
IN THE STATE NOT TO MAKE THEM
DIFFERENT TO REMOVE THE HURDLES
THAT THEY'RE FACING.
BECAUSE I I WENT THROUGH THAT A
LONG TIME AGO.
AND I JUST KNOW THAT -- BECOMING
POOR IS A CHALLENGE BUT MAKING
IT EVEN HARDER TO BE POOR IS
EVEN LIKE.
REALLY HUMILIATING -- JUSTICE
OLIVER WENDELL HOLMES SAID THOSE
WHO HAVE LESS IN LIFE SHOULD OF
MORE IN LAW AND I THINK THAT.
OF PROPOSAL SHOULD REALLY BE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED AND THAT
OUR SEATS ONE CAL WORKS FAMILY
SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE THANK YOU WHAT WAS THE CODE
AGAIN.
THOSE WHO THOSE WHO HAVE LESS IN
LIFE SHOULD HAVE MORE IN LOW AND
THAT'S JUSTICE OLIVER WENDELL
HOLMES.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW.
TO HELP YOU JUST HOLD IT IN YOUR
HAVE COMFORTABLE.
HI MY NAME IS MAHDI I'M UP HERE
VOICES LEADER FROM SANTA'S CALL
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE IS --
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER -- SIX IT'S
KIND OF HARD.
WHEN I WAS IN MY SECOND
TRIMESTER OF PREGNANCY?
I PUT MYSELF ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR CHILD CARE.
WHEN I WAS AROUND SIX MONTHS
WITH MY BABY YOU KNOW BEING
ALIVE MY PAPER SIX MONTHS OLD I
STILL DID NOT RECEIVE A CALL?
THOSE OVER ONE YEAR I WAS
RUNNING OUT OF OPTIONS TO GET
BACK TO MY JOB THAT I NEEDED TO
GET BACK -- TO SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY JOB PRODUCTION AFTER
SIX MONTHS IN THE STATE.
SO THEN I WAS TOLD THAT I SHOULD
APPLY FOR CAL WORKS AND GET ON
CHILD CARE I WALKED INTO THE CAO
WORKS OFFICE.
ONLY TO REALLY SECURE CHILD CARE
THAT WAS MY MAIN GOAL BECAUSE I
NEEDED TO GET BACK TO WORK
WITHIN TWO TO THREE WEEKS.
WHEN I WALKED IN -- I WENT
THROUGH ALL THE JUMPS IN HOOPS
OF HAVING A NURSING.
CHILD BEING TOLD BY CAO WORK
STAFF THAT I NEED TO COVER UP --
AND I LIVE IN YOU KNOW SAN
FRANCISCO THINGS LIKE BACK.
WHAT HAPPENED IS I REALIZE THAT
DAY WHEN I APPLIED IS THAT MY
CASH AID WASN'T GOING TO START
THE SAME DAY OF MY CHILD CARE
BUT IF IT?
THAT WAS THE REASON WHY WEB
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO BACK TO
WORK.
AND I WORKED WITH STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
I SUPPORT THE BEGINNING THE
FIRST PAYCHECK. TO LEARN TO BE
SUSTAINABLE IN THEIR LIFE WE
HAVE THEIR 50% LESS LIKELY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A JOB.
WHEN THEY GRADUATE OVER PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA?
SO I WENT TO MY JOB THE DEALS
PUT THREE PAT REPORT BACK TO
WORK IN A SHORT UP AND I SAID
I'M SORRY I COULDN'T FIGURE IT
OUT.
CHILD CARE.
BUT TODAY WHEN I WALKED HOME
FROM.
THE FINANCIAL DISTRICT. THIRTEEN
THE TOTAL I DO THAT THERE WAS
THE DEATH OF MY CAREER.
I STILL ALL COLORS YEAH.
IF I HAD A STRONG START.
IT SO YOU THIS STORY.
PLEASE DON'T LET THIS HAPPEN TO
WANT OTHER PERIOD AT THE STATE
[inaudible]
IT REALLY.
THERE WERE ALLOW IT TO HAPPEN.
SO THANK YOU I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THAT CHILD CARE BENEFITS
KASICH'S START THE SAME DAY
BECAUSE IT SHOULDN'T TAKE
ANOTHER TWO TO THREE MONTHS FOR
THEM TO GIVE ME A CALL BACK IT'S
TOTALLY ME.
THE DELEGATE CHILD CARE WHEN I
WAS LIKE I DON'T HAVE A JOB
ANYMORE SO DON'T THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO JENNIFER GRAB YOUR VOICES
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK BODY JUST
REALLY.
PUT.
AN EXCLAMATION POINT ON WHY WE
NEED -- ISSUE -- SIX BUT I'M
REALLY HERE TO TALK ABOUT ISSUE --
ONE THE INCREASING CASH GRANTS
WHICH I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
AND IT'S A WONDERFUL THING FOR
FAMILIES AND MY DAUGHTER.
IS A TEEN MOM AND SHE IS IN THE
CAO WORKS PROGRAM CURRENTLY
GOING TO SCHOOL.
AND SHE WAS SO EXCITED TO GET
HER NOTICED THAT SAID YOUR CASH
GRAB IS GOING TO BE INCREASED --
AND THEN IN THE SAME LETTER SHE
GOT.
ANOTHER NOTICE THAT SAID.
ACTUALLY NOW WE'RE GOING TO
DECREASE YOUR HOW FRESH BENEFITS
AND SO THE WASH WAS ABOUT TEN
DOLLARS.
SO WHILE WE INCREASE THE CASH
GRANTS FOR FAMILIES WE REALLY
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE HOW THAT
IMPACTS THE OTHER.
OF PROGRAMS THAT THESE FAMILIES
ARE ACCESSING AND THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING EXTRA DOLLARS IN THEIR
POCKET.
AND THAT IT DOESN'T BECOME TO
JUST SORT OF A WASH ONE PROGRAM
TO THE NEXT THANKS THANK YOU.
THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
RAY AS A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JACQUI ONE WITH GRACE
WE MANAGED AND CAL POVERTY AND
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN I BELIEVE
YOUR RECEIPT OF A BUDGET LETTER.
SIGNED BY SIXTY ONE PLUS
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE --
AND IT'S NOT JUST ONE ISSUE HERE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ON WE OFFER
SUPPORT ALL THE ADVOCATE.
ISSUES -- I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS ON THE CONVERSATION THAT
YOU ALL HAVE BEEN HAVING ABOUT
THE POVERTY BECAUSE WE ARE IN
SOME CASES -- LEAVING CHILDREN
ANTI POVERTY FOR IN THE CURRENT
SEXUALLY HAVE SO I'LL CHECK ALSO
WANT TO REMIND MY COMMENTS.
WITH -- PREVIOUS MEMBERS WHO --
PANELISTS WHO HAVE TALKED ABOUT
A CREATING A COW SO WHAT'S FOR
FAMILIES RIGHT NOT THAT NOT THAT
FAMILIES HAVE FOR FOR CAL WORK
SO -- I SUPPORT ALL THE OUTCASTS
WAS SEEN WHEN ANY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU FOR HAVING US ALL
HERE TODAY FOR THIS GREAT
DISCUSSION TRACY PATTERSON WITH
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
WE ARE ALSO LARGELY SUPPORTIVE
OF ALL THE ADVOCACY PROPOSALS.
IN THE ADVANCEMENT OF A HOLISTIC
SAFETY NET THAT TRULY WORKS TO
HELP AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS --
AND JUST WANT TO EXTRA SUPPORT
ISSUE ONE THREE FIVE AND SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI I AM TRYING TO MAKE US ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
SERVING LOS ANGELES AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES.
I AM HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE -- SIX TO EXTEND TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY TO CAL WORK
STAGE ONE CHILD CARE TO PROVIDE
STABILITY AND ENSURE A STRONG
START FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS I'M WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ALL THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS LAID OUT IN ITEMS ONE
THROUGH -- EIGHT OUR NETWORK OF
FORTY ONE FOOD BANKS AND THE SIX
THOUSAND PLUS AGENCIES I'M SEE
EVERY DAY THAT SOME OF THE
HUNGRY JUST FOLKS THAT COME TO
FOOD PANTRIES TO ACCESS FREE
GROCERIES.
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON CAL WORKS --
I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT ESPECIALLY
OF THE ISSUES -- FIVE AND SEVEN
THAT TALK ABOUT AND THE NEED FOR
INCREASING THE TIME CLOCK AND
ALSO FOR A ROOT BY REMOVING THE
ASSET TESTS.
AND WE KNOW THAT IN ORDER FOR
FAMILIES TO REGAIN REAL AND TRUE
STABILITY AND THEIR ALLIES
PEOPLE NEED SUFFICIENT TIME --
AND THEY ALSO NEED A HEALTHY
FINANCIAL BUFFER SO THAT EVEN
JUST MINE ALL FINANCIAL BARRIERS
A DON'T SET THEM BACK DEEPER
INTO POVERTY SO FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS THE MORE WE SUPPORT ONE
THREE EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ASM THE
COMMITTEE I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING A VERY ROBUST
DEEP.
DISCUSSION THAT REALLY SHOWS
YOUR CONCERN FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES -- WE GENERALLY SUPPORT --
ISSUES ONE THREE FOUR AND SIX
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT SIX
JUST FOR A MOMENT WE ARE -- ONE
OF THE ADVOCATES WHO BROUGHT
THIS TO YOU FROM THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER.
AND WE BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY
IT'S TIME TO ALIGN THE STAGE ONE
RULES WITH THAT OF EVERY OTHER
CHILD CARE PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA --
INCLUDING STATE JUST TWO AND
THREE AS THE BENEFITS OF
CONTINUITY OF CARE BECOME
APPARENT FOR THE CHILDREN WHO
NEED THAT STABILITY THE MOST WE
WANT TO SEE THAT.
STABILITY OFFERED TO CAL WORKS
CHILDREN TO PREPARE THEM FOR
LIFELONG SUCCESS BOTH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS -- WE HAVE OUR
HIGHLY SUPPORTIVE OF ISSUES ONE
AND THREE THROUGH EIGHT
SPECIFICALLY ISSUE ONE WE ARE --
BEHIND LA OWES NUMBER THREE
SUGGESTION WHICH WOULD BE -- SO
I DON'T HAVE THE MEMORY STE --
EITHER DOING [inaudible]
OF WHICH IS JUST TO HAVE THE
GOAL OF 50% OF THE POVERTY LEVEL
GRANTS HE MEETING IT HALFWAY. TO
THAT 50% OF THE POVERTY LEVEL
ALSO WE HAVE -- SPECIFIC ISSUES
THAT WE WANTED TO ADDRESS
FOCUSING ON CAL WORKS TWO POINT
NO FOR TIMED OUT CASES WE'VE
NOTICED A DECLINE IN CASELOAD
HOWEVER THE REMAINING FAMILIES
HAVE A HIGHER LEVEL OF NEED.
SO WE JUST HOPE THAT THERE BE
ROBUST FUNDING TO HELP THOSE
FAMILIES -- ALSO FOCUSING ON THE
TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY
FAMILIES.
MOST OF THAT COST FALLS ON
COUNTY -- COUNTIES AND STATE --
BUT TYPICALLY COUNTIES ARE
SUPPORTING THAT AND SO WERE.
HOPING THERE WILL BE A LITTLE
BIT OF FOCUS ON THE TANF FUNDING --
SO ANYWAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA STANDER
ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK --
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUES ONE AND SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JUST BIRTH LOW WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY ADDING OUR
SUPPORT ON THAT COUCH HOME
VISITING AND THE CHILD CAE WITH
MUCH GRATITUDE TO THE PARENTS
AND THE ORGANIZER TO THE PARENT
TO CAME HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BENITO DOGGETT
OLSON SUPPLY BANK DOT ORG STRONG
SUPPORT OF ALL THE ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS BUT PARTICULARLY ITEM
THREE ON CAL WORKS HOME
VISITATION WE WORK WITH ABOUT
THREE DOZEN CHILDREN FAMILY
COMMISSIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ACROSS THE STATE.
MANY OF WHICH ARE DOING THAT
WORK OR GETTING READY TO DO THAT
WORK AND THE IMPACTS THAT WE'VE
SEEN -- THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL HAVE ALREADY
PROVEN TO BE QUITE FRUITFUL SO
STRONG SUPPORT OF ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO INCREASE THAT THANKS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MECCA CWD A IN IN ADDITION TO
THAT ITEM THAT I PRESENTED.
I'D LIKE TO LINE MY SUPPORT FOR
ITEM. ONE THREE FIVE SEVEN AND
EIGHT WITH RESPECT TO STAGE ONE
CHILD CARE WERE CONCEPTUALLY
SUPPORTIVE REALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO
STREAMLINE AND SIMPLIFY CHILD
CARE. FOR PEOPLE ON CAL WORKS WE%
WERE IN VERY GOOD DISCUSSIONS
WITH OUR FRIENDS AT PARENT
VOICES.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO SORT OF
COMING TOGETHER ON THAT ITEM AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MUCH FOR KOREAN
I'M HERE WITH THE WATSON THE
LAWCENTER -- I'M CURRENTLY
INTERNING IN WORKING WITH --
MANY FAMILIES WHO ARE ON CAL
WORKS AND MANY OF THESE PARENTS --
ARE SINGLE MOTHERS WHO SIMPLY
CAN'T MAKE IT JUST WITH THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY'RE
GIVEN -- THEREFORE WE'RE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WELL AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
ISSUES ONE THROUGH.
EIGHT REGARDING CAL WORKS AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION.
YES SIR I JUST HAD A REVELATION
CAN I ASK DIAZ SAYS ONE FINAL
QUESTION SENSOR YES I APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS IT JUST
OCCURRED TO ME AS WE HAVE.
A SITUATION IN THE INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED --
POPULATION WITH LACK OF
PROVIDERS FOR THE FOR THE FOR
THE CAN THE CONSUMER.
A LOT OF FAMILIES NOW OR HAVING
TO DEFAULT AND LEAVE THEIR JOBS.
TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN
WITH THESE DISABILITIES.
DO YOU TRACK -- THIS POPULATION
COMING INTO TO OF TO HAVE THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET GOING FORWARD.
I MEAN WHAT I'M SAYING IS IF ONE
AGENCY -- IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
HELP AND AND THERE'S ALSO THE TO
THE SYNDROME CALLED THE
GATEKEEPER WHERE THEY'RE DENIED
SERVICES ALSO.
AND PARENTS ARE NOW DO.
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW HAVING TO CARE FOR
THEIR CHILD AND BE AN ADVOCATE
AT THE SAME TIME TRYING TO FIGHT
FOR SERVICES.
CAN'T WORK IN SPECIALLY SINGLE
MOMS.
IS THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY TRACK THAT.
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE I REALLY
THINK THAT THAT'S A FAILURE.
OF OF OF THE COMMITMENT FOR
ENTITLEMENT STATE WHERE YOU
DON'T THANK GOD WE HAVE A SAFETY
NET.
BUT ALSO -- MOMS AND DADS WERE
SAYING.
I CAN'T CONTINUE TO WORK MY
CHILD IS NOT BEING PROVIDED.
FOR IN AN ENTITLEMENT STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE.
IN THAT ENTIRE SPACE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
ALL RIGHT THEN WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NOW [inaudible]
TO CALPERS.
WAS IT NOLAN CAPS.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE I COULD HAVE THE THE
PANELISTS COME FORWARD.
AND LET'S BEGIN WITH KIM THE
COURT WADE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
ELECTIONS AGAIN OR JUST GO AHEAD
AND START WITH CAL FRESH YES
OKAY LET'S BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER.
NINE WAS THAT YOUR QUESTION.
SO I BEGIN.
ALRIGHT.
BRIEFLY I CANNOT GIVE YOU A
QUICK UPDATE ON HOW FRESH --
PROGRAM WE SERVE ABOUT THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION INDIVIDUALS
EACH MONTH WITH THE FOOD BENEFIT
ON THE EBT CARD.
OVER SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FOOD BENEFITS COME INTO
THE CONDAMINE SPENT TO GROCERY
STORES AND FARMERS MARKETS.
CASELOADS ARE DECLINING OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS IN RESPONSE TO
THE ECONOMY THEY TEND TO TRACK
UNEMPLOYMENT BUT PARTICIPATION
RATES ARE ESTIMATED TO CONTINUE.
TO GROW SLOWLY A WE ARE WATCHING
CLOSELY THE TRANS TO SEE FOR ANY
IMPACT OF THE CLIMATE AROUND
IMMIGRATION AND MAKING SURE ALL
FOLKS WERE ELIGIBLE ARE STILL
WELCOME.
WE CONTINUE TO BE COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL OVERSIGHT ON
TIMELINESS AND ACCURACY AND ARE
EXPANDING OUR ACCESS ONLINE ON
THE PHONE.
HIGHLIGHTS FROM LAST YEAR WE
BEGAN OUT WELL HEADLINES MAYBE
NOT HIGHLIGHTS WE BEGAN
REIMPOSING THE FEDERAL TIME
LIMITS -- KNOWN AS A BOTTOM
THREE COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO SANTA
CLARA AND SAN MATTEO.
SECOND WE HAD UNPRECEDENTED
DISASTER RESPONSE PARTICULARLY
IN BUTTE COUNTY AND OTHER
COUNTIES FACING WILDFIRE
PROVIDING FOOD.
AND THIRD WE RESPOND TO THE
FEDERAL SHUTDOWN TO ISSUING
BENEFITS EARLY FEBRUARY BENEFITS
EARLY IN JANUARY THEN CONTINUING
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE'S BUT THE BENEFITS
WEREN'T.
INTERRUPTED LOOKING AHEAD THE
MAJOR ISSUE WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IS EXPANSION OF
CALIFORNIA SO SERVE UP PEOPLE
RECEIVING SSI BUT OTHER
PRIORITIES CONTINUE TO BE MAKING
SURE WE STAY WELCOME TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WERE ELIGIBLE
REGARDLESS OF LANGUAGE STATUS OR
DISABILITY -- EXPANDING OUR WORK
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH EMPLOYMENT
AND TRAINING EVEN WHILE IMPOSING
TIME LIMITS AND MORE COUNTIES IN
CONTINUING -- TO GET IT RIGHT
FIRST TIME IMPROVE OUR ACCURACY
REDUCE ERRORS OVER ISSUANCES AND
HEARINGS THAT'S THE SHORT
VERSION FROM CALIBRATION HAPPY
TO TAKE TAKE UP THE ISSUES.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT -- OVER.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE ABLE BODIED
ADULTS WITHOUT DEPENDENCE SURE A
BONDS SURE.
SO -- FOLLOWING THE QUESTIONS OF
THE AGENDA THERE ARE -- SEVERAL --
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE OUT
RECEIVING CAL FOR US WHO WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO THIS TIME LIMIT AS
UNEMPLOYMENT FALLS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IF THEY ARE NOT ABLE
TO WORK FOR TWENTY HOURS PER
WEEK -- THEY WOULD BE CUT OFF OF
FOOD AFTER THREE MONTHS -- AND
THIRTY SIX MONTH PERIOD.
SO THE STATE HAS BEEN WORKING --
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF THAT --
PARTICULARLY IN OUR FIRST TWO
WAVE COUNTIES WERE ABLE TO DO
ARE ONE TWO THREE APPROACH AND
EXEMPTS PEOPLE AS APPROPRIATE
CONNECTED WITH EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES AND ALSO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL BANK OF BENEFITS --
THAT'S WORKING FOR NOW AS WERE
IN THREE COUNTIES AND HOPEFULLY
SIX COUNTIES AT SOME POINT THAT
APPROACH WILL BE EXHAUSTED
PARTICULARLY AS THE LARGER
COUNTIES IN THE VALLEY IN THE
SOUTH MIGHT COME IN WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM.
LOSING FOOD ACCESS IN A MATTER
OF A YEAR.
TO ALSO THE FEDS -- YOU SCA HAS
A PROPOSED RULE WERE.
WERE WHERE DO YESTERDAY BETTER
NOW RE OPENED STILL HAVE TIME TO
COMMENT WHICH WOULD RADICALLY
CHANGE THE SYSTEM AND WOULD
REQUIRE CALIFORNIAN ALL STATES
TO BEGIN ON TIME LIMITS AND
CEASING.
FOOD ASSISTANCE.
THE MATTER OF MONTHS AND THAT
WOULD IMPACT AGAIN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE'S ACCESS TO
FOOD IF THAT RULE WERE TO BECOME
FINAL.
THAT'S THE CURRENT SITUATION.
AND DISINTEREST SECOND QUESTION --
THE THE ALTERNATIVES THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM -- ADVOCATES THE
NATIONAL AND STATE LEVEL AUG
HAVE TO DO WITH CALIFORNIA
CREATING STATE FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS TO FILL IN THE GAP NOT
DISSIMILAR FOR A POST WELFARE
REFORM WHEN -- FEDERALLY SNAP
MADE REDUCTIONS IN THE LEGALLY
PRESENT IMMIGRANTS IT WOULD
COVER CALIFORNIA CREATED A
CALIFORNIA FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO COVER THAT GAP
INSURER.
THOSE IMMIGRANTS CALIFORNIA
COULD CHOOSE TO DO SOME OTHER
SIMILAR GAP FILLING AROUND THESE
GAPS CREATED BY FEDERAL TIME
LIMITS.
SURE ON EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING.
YES.
THIS IS A BECAUSE OUR EMPLOYMENT
AND TRAINING SERVICES HAVE A
NEARLY DOUBLED IN THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS THESE ARE VOLUNTARY
SERVICES AND WE HAVE WORKED TO
BRING IN MORE COUNTY SPRING AND
MORE WORK FORCE PROVIDERS SERVE
MORE PEOPLE.
AND IMPORTANTLY NOTCHES TO
QUANTITY BUT QUALITY REALLY
PARTNER WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WORK FOR SPORTS.
AND NOW WE ARE MEASURING OUR
OUTCOMES ON WAGES AND EMPLOYMENT
RATES TO MAKE SURE IT'S NOT JUST
A SERVICE PROVIDED BUT ACTUALLY --
A BENEFIT CONFERRED -- IN ORDER
BECAUSE WE ARE DOING THAT THE
OFFENSIVE REQUESTED INCREASED
NOT REQUESTED HAVE ARE REQUIRED --
INCREASED OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SO WE ARE REQUESTING MORE STAFF
BUT THAT WILL BE FOR A 100%
FUNDED WITH FEDERAL FUNDS THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT FUND THE
SERVICES WERE ALSO FUND THE
OVERSIGHT WE JUST NEED THE
THIRTY TWO TO STAFF
APPROPRIATELY AS DIRECTED BY THE
FENCE.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE
[inaudible]
GREAT.
THE MAN CHAIRED JESSICA BARTH
LOW WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY HERE TO REQUEST --
THAT WE CREATE A STATE FUNDED
BENEFITS TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE.
LOSING THEIR BENEFITS AS A
RESULT OF THE A BAD TIME LIMIT
WHICH IS THREE MONTHS.
OUT OF A THIRTY SIX MONTH PERIOD.
AT THAT THEY NOT GO HUNGRY.
AS YOU HEARD AS MISS MCQUAY WADE
SPEAK ABOUT THE CURRENT RULE --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A ONE TWO THREE APPROACH
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS WORKED
HAND IN HAND WITH COUNTY
ADMINISTRATORS AND ADVOCATES TO
HELP DEVELOP.
OF WERE SATISFIED WITH HOW
THAT'S WORKING IN AND BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE NOT -- EXACERBATING
HUNGER AS A RESULT OF THAT
APPROACH AND SO CONGRATULATE THE
DEPARTMENT -- WITH SOME REALLY
PRETTY GNARLY TIME LINES BEING
ABLE TO TO IMPLEMENT.
THE RETURN OF OF THE TIME LIMIT.
THAT BEING SAID WE FACE A
PROPOSAL FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHICH WOULD --
LIMIT SIGNIFICANTLY LIMIT OUR
ABILITY TO USE THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE WHEN THE
LAW PASSED TWENTY YEARS AGO AND
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR
THOSE TWENTY YEARS.
OF FOR THE LARGE PART WITH VERY
SMALL CHANGES.
THOSE PROPOSED AS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES TO THE
RULE ARE IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH
LEGISLATIVE HISTOPATHOLOGY FROM
CONGRESS AND AS YOU HEARD LAST
NIGHT WAS.
THE FIRST DEADLINE TO SUBMIT
COMMENTS AND OVER SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE COMMENTED IN
CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
COMMENTED INCLUDING EXPERTS ON
RACE EQUITY AND A CHILD POVERTY.
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT WE HAD
COMMENTS -- FROM WESTERN CENTER
FROM THE FOOD BANKS THROUGHOUT
THE THE STATE AND ALSO FROM --
LABOR EXPERTS AND WHAT EVERYBODY
SAID -- IN PARTICULAR THE SHARED
COMMENT WAS THAT HUNGER DOESN'T
ACTUALLY MAKE SOMEBODY BETTER
ABLE TO FIND WORK.
AT TO GO TO WORK AND TO STAY
EMPLOYED.
I'M.
WE ALSO POINTED OUT THAT THERE'S
GREAT.
RACIAL DISPARITIES EVEN THOUGH
YOU COULD LOOK AT THE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WITHIN EACH
COUNTY.
YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT THERE'S LARGE POCKETS OF
PEOPLE WHO REMAIN EMPLOYED
UNEMPLOYED AND THOSE PEOPLE AT
OUR AT TEN TO BE.
MEMBERS OF RACE RACIAL ETHNICITY
A RACIAL ETHNIC GROUPS MORE
FREQUENTLY THEY TEND A P. B.
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
VETERANS PEOPLE SURVIVING DRUG
ADDICTION SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE -- THEY TEND TO HAVE LOWER
LITERACY RATES AND MANY MORE
CHALLENGES TO EMPLOYMENT AND
STABLE EMPLOYMENT AND NOT ONLY
THAT. TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN THE
LAW WAS PASSED WE ARE CALLING ME
WAS MUCH DIFFERENT TODAY WE HAVE
MANY MORE INDUSTRY JOBS THAT ARE
NOT PERMANENT JOBS AND PEOPLE
STRUGGLE. TO FIND AT TWENTY
HOURS OF WORK IN A SINGLE JOB
AND SOMETIMES THEY'RE PAIRING A
GATHER MULTIPLE JOBS THEY DON'T
HAVE A TINY OVER THEIR
SCHEDULING WITH LACK OF A FAIR
SCHEDULING POLICIES IN OUR STATE.
SO ALL OF THE SAID THE
RESEARCHERS SHOWED THAT.
WORK AT THAT TIME LIMITS AND
RELATED WORK REQUIREMENTS DON'T
ACTUALLY HELP PEOPLE FIND WORK.
AT THAT WORK SUPPORTS AND
PREVENTING HUNGER DO -- AND WITH
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE
THAT CALIFORNIA -- STEP INTO THE
SPACE OF PROVIDING.
A STATE FUNDED BENEFIT.
THROUGH THANK AT CREATING A
STATE BANK -- SO THAT WOULD
ALLOW US TO USE THE PROCESS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE THE ONE TWO
THREE APPROACH -- BY SIMPLY
CREATING A STATE BANK OF MONTHLY
BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T
GOTTEN ENOUGH HOURS TO MEET THE
WORK ROLE OF THE TIME LIMIT OR
WHO HAVE -- SIR PASSED THE THREE
MONTHS IN A THIRTY SIX MONTH
PERIOD TO PREVENT HUNGER AND
ALSO TO PREVENT AN EROSION OF
ECONOMIC FLOW INTO OUR FOOD
ECONOMY.
REMEMBER THE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
FOOD ECONOMY IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
IN OUR STATE WITH WITH HIGH
PERCENTAGES OF PEOPLE RELYING ON
OF PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO BUY FOOD
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO TO HAVE
WORKING KEEP WORK.
SO WITH ALL OF THAT -- WE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
THERE WILL BE SOME CHALLENGES TO
MAKE IT. TO MAKE IT WORK RIGHT
BUT WE KNOW THAT THIS DEPARTMENT --
HAS PROVEN THEMSELVES TIME AND
TIME AGAIN -- TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE MORE DANGEROUS A
PROPOSALS COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WERE
REALLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR
ABILITY TO DO THIS AS WELL.
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT BAKER.
NOTHING FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCER
LA -- IN LIGHT OF WHAT MIGHT BE
HAPPENING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
TO TO HAVE A SUPPLEMENTAL.
OR TO HAVE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE SO WE CAN TRACK THE
RISK OF POTENTIAL ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES.
OF THE FEDERAL AND STATE
POLICIES REGARDING A BOAT.
THEY MAY NOT BE AN IMMEDIATE
ISSUE NOW BUT IT COULD BE DIRE
ISSUE.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE WORK
THE UNCERTAINTY -- DEPENDING ON
WHAT HAPPENS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT SO I
THINK THAT -- STAFF WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT WE CAN
START WORKING ON THAT.
EVERYTHING FROM THE VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S GO.
TO ISSUE TâM.
ELDERLY SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE HI TRACY PATTERSON
FROM CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT IMPLEMENTING A SIMPLIFIED
USER FRIENDLY CAL FIRST
APPLICATION. FOR SENIOR DISABLED
HOUSEHOLDS -- WE ARE PRESENTING
THIS PROPOSAL ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT A R. P. CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS LOCAL FOOD BANKS ANTI
HUNGER GROUPS AND ARE ALSO
THANKFUL THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN WILL BE ADVANCING THIS
PROPOSAL WITH IN THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M SO WHEN IT COMES TO KILL
FRESH WE REALLY ADVOCATE FOR
COVERAGE BECAUSE IT IS THE BEST
ANTI POVERTY PROGRAM WE HAVE --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA HAS
PERSISTENTLY LAGGED BEHIND THE
NATION WHEN IT COMES TO AND
ROLLING ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME
SENIORS INTO CAL FRESH -- JUST
UNDER 20% OF CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
LOW INCOME SENIORS ARE REACHED
BY CAL FOR US WHICH IS THE
LOWEST SENIOR PARTICIPATION RATE
OF ANY STATE -- AND SO IN ORDER
TO MAXIMIZE THE PRESSING
OPPORTUNITY TO ENROLL THE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE AS A SITE POPULATION
INTO CAL FOR ASH IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE LOOK AT ALL PROMISING
WAYS TO STREAMLINE ENROLLMENT
INTO THE PROGRAM.
ALSO CDSS COVERAGE HAS
PARTICIPATED IN A FEDERAL
DEMONSTRATION PROGRAM CALLED THE
ELDERLY SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION
PROJECT WHICH I'LL JUST CALL THE
SAP A SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND WE COMMEND THE
DEPARTMENTS LEADERSHIP AND
GAINING FEDERAL APPROVAL FOR
THIS PROJECT -- THERE WERE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVEN
HOUSEHOLDS IDENTIFIED AS EASE UP
ELIGIBLE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND ALL
NEWLY APPLYING SENIOR DISABLED
HOUSEHOLDS CAN BENEFIT FROM THE
POLICIES AND PROCESS SET IN
PLACE BY THIS -- BUT BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL PEOPLE WAS COST NEUTRAL
WE HAVE NOT IMPLEMENTED IS
ACTUALLY A SIMPLIFIED USER
FRIENDLY SENIOR APPLICATION --
AND SO THIS IS A STATE OPTION WE
DON'T NEED FURTHER A FEDERAL
APPROVAL TO DO THIS WE JUST NEED
THE FUNDS -- BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT MOST OTHER EAST UP STATES
HAVE IMPLEMENTED A SIMPLE
APPLICATION WHICH IS ABOUT TWO
TO EIGHT PAGES -- AND THIS IS IN
CONTRAST TO OUR EXISTING CAL
FRESH APPLICATION WHICH IS
EIGHTEEN PAGES LONG AND CONTAINS
MANY QUESTIONS THAT ARE NOT
RELEVANT TO THESE EASE UP
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND SO WE ARE RESPECTING A ONE
TIME ALLOCATION TO IMPLEMENT A
USER CENTERED SIMPLIFIED CAL
FRESH APPLICATION -- THE COST
ESTIMATE AN IDEA FOR THE PROJECT
IS BASED ON EXISTING PROJECTS
UNDER WAY -- THAT CDS US AND C.
H. SS ARE IMPLEMENTING FOR USER
CENTERED DESIGN PRINCIPLES IN
APPLICATIONS AND RE
CERTIFICATION FORMS AND WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THIS REQUEST WOULD
BUILD UPON ALL OF THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED.
THE WORK THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
COMPLETED AND THIS WOULD BE --
NARROWING IN ON THE SENIOR
POPULATION -- WITH THE EXPANSION
OF CALIFORNIA'S TO THE SS I
POPULATION THIS IS EXTREMELY
TIMELY -- WE ALSO KNOW THAT A
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION IS NOT A
PANACEA I DON'T WANT TO SAY THIS
IS GOING TO SOLVE OUR SENIOR
ENROLLMENT CRISIS -- BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED SORT OF AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH THAT WE
ARE MATCHING BOTH POLICY AND
PROCESS USED. TO GET THE MAXIMUM
BENEFIT -- WE TRULY BELIEVE THAT
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES DESERVE TO LIVE AN
AGE WITH DIGNITY AND FREE FROM
HUNGER AND THIS IS ONE WAY WE
CAN HELP.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK SPEAKER.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL --
SO CERTAINLY AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL WE SUPPORT A REDESIGN OF
FORMS THAT THEY CAN BE MORE USER
FRIENDLY -- THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT HAS
WORK GROUPS ON FOR VARIOUS
CLIENT NOTICES ARE MADE CARRIED
REPORT.
THE CHALLENGE REALLY IS AROUND
TIMING AND COST -- SO
IMPLEMENTATION OF SS I WILL BE
IN ABOUT SIXTY DAYS -- SO WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO DO THIS BY JUNE
FIRST THIS YEAR BUT CERTAINLY A
LOOK AT FRANKLY NOT JUST THE
SENIOR APT BUT THE OVERALL
APPLICATION.
THE SENIOR AT THE FAMILY FACING
APP THE REPORT NEEDS A A RE LOOK
IN SOME OF THE WAYS OF THE
HEALTH FORMS.
OKAY SO -- CERTAINLY THE FORMS
YOU NEED TO RE LOOK IN THE OTHER
TWO KEY TIMING PIECE OF COURSE
IS THE AUTOMATION IT'S ONE THING
TO REDESIGN FORM BUT THEN IT
NEEDS TO BE AUTOMATED SO GET TO
THE PERSON WHO NEEDS THAT FORMER
THAT APPLICATION.
AND AS YOU KNOW OUR THREE
SYSTEMS ARE IN A PROCESS OF A
MIGRATION TO TWO TO ONE SO THE
THINKING ABOUT THE TIMING.
THE PROCESS TO DESIGN THE FORMS
AS A SYSTEM IN THE PART AND THE
TIMING TO AUTOMATE THEM REQUIRES
A A GOOD.
STAKEHOLDER PLAN WITH ALL
PARTIES HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THIS THIS PIECE FITS INTO IT.
SO OUR CONCERNS ARE REALLY
PRACTICAL NOT TO KNOW --
CONCEPTUAL CONCERNS THANK YOU
LIKE SPEAKER.
FROM THE FINANCE HELLO.
I THINK MY FIRST QUESTION WAS IS
ONE MILLION DOLLARS GOING TO DO
THIS.
AND I KNOW YOU HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH STAFF ON THIS ALSO
YEAH SO I THINK YOU KNOW FROM
OUR UNDERSTANDING AND WORK IN
THIS AREA FOR MANY YEARS A LOT
OF THE COST IS THE AUTOMATION.
AND SO THE DESIGN ITSELF IS THE
AUTOMATION.
AND SO THE DESIGN ITSELF YOU
KNOW FROM OUR CONVERSATION WITH
CONSULTANTS ANOTHER PROJECTS
WOULD BE QUITE MINIMAL THIS
COULD REALLY BUILD UPON LEARNING
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE.
I'M TALKING TO USERS AND HOW TO
AUTOMATION COSTS WERE ESTIMATING
AROUND A MILLION THAT TENDS TO
BE -- A SIMILAR AUTOMATION COSTS
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTROL AS
ADVOCATES SO -- I WOULD LEAVE
THAT UP TO INPUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS IT'S ONE
OF THE QUESTIONS DID HAVE TO DO
WITH THE FACT THAT FOR THE
NEARNESS -- OF THE JUNE FIRST
EXPANSION OF A SOCIETY -- BUT
YOU DON'T SEE THAT AS A
POSSIBILITY.
OF OF WHAT WOULD BE A TIME LINE
THAT WOULD BE MORE.
WELL WE'RE EIGHTEEN MY WORKABLE.
TRACY WELL KNOWS WHERE AT LEAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS INTO REDESIGNING
THE EVERITT MID CARRIED REPORT.
SO A COUPLE TWO TO THREE YEARS
AND THEN THE CROSSWALK WITH THE
MIGRATION -- GIVEN THE WE'RE
MOVING FROM THREE TO TWO TO ONE
SYSTEM WHAT'S THE MOST STRATEGIC
AND COST EFFECTIVE TIME NOT
WANTING TO WASTE TIME TO GET
THIS -- INCREASE SERVICE TO
SENIORS BUT ALSO BEING
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT WHEN IT SHOULD
INTERSECT WITH THE MIGRATION
PLAN.
YEAH AND THEY WILL OUT I THINK
YOU KNOW AS MUCH AS WE'RE TRYING
TO GET READY FOR THE JUNE ONE
ENROLLMENT THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
POPULATION THAT'S WHERE
PARTICIPATION RATE IS STILL
NINETEEN POINT 5% AND SO.
WE WOULD LOVE THIS TO BE AS FAST
AS POSSIBLE BUT THIS IS ALSO A
LONG TERM NEED BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SOON WE HOPE THE IDEA OF AS A
SIGN CAL FRESH BEING COMPLICATED
WILL.
A RACE FROM PEOPLE'S MEMORIES AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND IT WILL
TRULY JUST BE CAL FOR US FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE AND SO
YOU KNOW WE WOULD STILL BE EAGER
TO SEE THIS AS A LONGER TERM
PROJECT EVEN IF THE TIMELINE --
IS NOT POSSIBLE FOR THE SUMMER
AND WE WOULD INTENDED DUAL
PURPOSE IT AS THE
RECERTIFICATION FORM FOR ALL THE
NEW SSI FOLKS THE APPAN THE
REFUNDABLE THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT.
DOCTOR WOULD.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS YOU TALK
ABOUT AUTOMATION SO THAT MEAN
THAT THESE ARE GOING TO BE --
AVAILABLE ONLINE FOR PEOPLE ARE
WE LOOKING AT PAPER.
THE ONE SO I THINK WITH THE WITH
AUTOMATION HEN YOU HAVE A PAPER
FORM IT'S STILL NEEDS TO BE
AUTOMATED TO MATCH WITH THE
DATABASE SYSTEM.
SO EVEN IF YOU HAVE A PAPER FORM
YOU STILL HAVE AUTOMATION CAUGHT
AND I WAS MY QUESTION YET BUT
THERE ARE ONLINE AND MOBILE
PORTALS WE HAVE -- THREE
DIFFERENT KINDS FOR THE THREE
SYSTEMS WE HAVE NOW THEY'RE
CONSOLIDATING TO ONE THERE'S
ALSO APPLICATION OF SISTERS SO
YOU CAN FOR INSTANCE THERE'S A
PROJECT THAT CDSS IS FUNDED OF
THE STATE WIDE.
APPLICATION A SISTER CALLED GET
CAL FRESH DOT WORK THAT OPERATES
IN SORT OF A VERY MODERN WAY OF
A RESPONSIVE APPLICATION WHERE
IT WOULD JUST SKIP.
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU DON'T
NEED TO ASK SO THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN SEEING A PAPER FORM OF THE
EIGHTEEN PAGES SO THE IDEA WOULD
BE WHEN YOU HAVE AN ONLINE
PORTAL -- THAT IT WOULD TRULY
JUST BE RESPONSIVE SO IT BECOMES
A SIMPLIFIED YOUR APPLICATION BY
THE QUESTIONS THAT IT SKIPS.
SO IT'S CURRENTLY IN EIGHTEEN
PAGE APPLICATION IS GOING TO GO
SMALLER.
NO THE CURRENT CAL FRESH ONLY
HAVE A IT'S EIGHTEEN YEAH IT'S
IS EIGHTEEN THE CALPERS MEDI CAL
CAL WORKS IS.
FIFTY SIX YEAH.
AND WE WHEN WE REDESIGN THE AS
WE LIKE TO REDESIGN THE PAPER
AND THE ONLINE THE ARCHITECTURE.
SHOULD BE THE SAME AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE -- TO BE THE
FORM YOU NEED NOT THE GIANT
GOVERNMENT PACKAGE.
IS SO THAT THESE THESE LONG
FORMS OUR STATE FORMS ARE NOT
FEDERAL FORMS.
THEY ARE STATE FORMS DRIVEN BY
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
BUT WE HAVE -- JUST WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REDESIGN THE MANY
USER CENTERED WAY.
JUST I GUESS I'M JUST STUNNED AT
THE LENGTH WE ARE TORN YEAH.
AND JUST.
YEAH.
QUESTION.
A RECERTIFICATION -- CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT I MEAN WHAT IS
THE TIME FRAME.
SB MCB RECERTIFICATION MEANS
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO RE SIGN UP
FOR THIS.
THAT MEAN YOU HAVE TO GO BACK
AND FILL OUT THE EIGHTEEN PAGE
FORM AGAIN.
WELL -- FOR MOST FOLKS YES MOST
FOLKS THEY REACT WISEMAN I MEAN
WHO AM I AND WEAPON HERE BUT NOW.
IF YOU'RE ELDERLY AND HAVE NO
INCOME RIGHT FOR YOUR DISABLED
RIGHT AND HAVE NO INCOME RIGHT
THE LIKELIHOOD IS YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET YOUNGER.
AND YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
GET ON TO SAY RIGHT SO FOR THIS
POPULATION THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE
MOVED TO THE EAST THAT PROGRAM
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO THOSE FOLKS
GET THREE YEARS INSTEAD OF ONE
YEAR AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
RE INTERVIEWED AT THREE YEARS
THEY STILL DO THAT APPLICATION
WE DO WE CLING TO CONFIRM.
YOUR HERE YOUR IN CALIFORNIA
NOTHING IS CHANGED WE'D LIKE TO
MAKE THAT SIMPLER AND THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO AN INTERVIEW.
AND WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
SO THEY HAVE BUT THEY'LL HAVE TO
THERE WILL HAVE TO THAT RESEARCH
CATION ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS
UNDER OUR SENIOR PILOT BUT IT'S
STILL EIGHTEEN PAGES.
COULDN'T BE YOU'RE STILL IN
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE STILL HERE.
WE CAN'T SIMPLIFY THAT LITTLE
BIT MORE.
ME LIKE I SAID YOU'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING YOUNGER.
THEY'RE NOT YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
DISABLED YOU'RE DISABLED IN
YOU'RE NOT GOING YOU KNOW I MEAN
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE PEOPLE.
CAN RECOVER BUT BUT IT JUST --
I'M SORRY IT JUST THIS SEEMS
REALLY ONEROUS.
AND TO WHAT END.
YEAH IT'S IT IS THE FUNCTION
HAVING UNIVERSAL APPLICATION
THAT SERVES FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS A YEAR SO WE'RE
ASKING ABOUT INCOME IN CHILDREN
AND ALL KINDS OF QUESTIONS THAT
ARE NOT RELEVANT FOR THIS
POPULATION WHICH IS STILL.
YOU KNOW 10% OF OUR CASELOAD BUT
THEY'RE DEALING WITH THAT
THEY'RE GETTING THE UNIVERSAL
LET'S ASK YOU EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE APPLICATION WE KNOW
BETTER ABOUT WHAT THE KIND
APPLICATION THEY NEED.
BUT STILL RECERTIFICATION IS
GOING TO REQUIRE THE SAME
EIGHTEEN PAGE APPLICATION.
UNDER THE PROPOSAL HERE THERE
WAS A SIMPLIFIED SENIOR APP THAT
COULD ALSO BE USER
RECERTIFICATION.
THERE IS SUPER SIMPLIFIED
VERSION.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE LIKE.
THERE ARE REQUIRED FEDERAL YOU
KNOW NAME ADDRESS RESIDENCY
SOURCES OF INCOME.
THERE ARE AND THERE'S YOU KNOW
IDEAS TO THIS IS WHAT YOU TOLD
US THREE YEARS AGO CAN YOU TELL
US IF THERE'S A CHANGE OR NO
CHANGE THOSE THINGS WITH DESIGN
AND AUTOMATION THAT CAN.
MAKE THAT CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE SO
MUCH BETTER.
SURE HOPE SO.
I'M SURE YOU CAN TELL FROM THE
QUESTIONS THAT PERHAPS THIS IS
AN AREA THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED
AT IT AND THERE ARE SO MANY
YEARS TO SO MANY PROBLEMS THAT.
THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH BUT IF
IF THE APPLICATION PROCESS IS SO
OWNERS.
IF ANYTHING THAT CAN BE DONE
BECAUSE YOU ALSO HAVE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO'S REVIEWING IT SO
THAT'S TAKING ALSO TIME FROM.
THAT WORKER ALSO TO REVIEW
EVERYTHING SO.
SOMETHING TO CONSIDER -- YEAH
AND I GUESS I BRING THIS UP
BECAUSE WE DO THE SAME THING
WITH THE MEDI CAL SYSTEM TO MEAN
SOMEONE WHO IS.
WHO IS PERMANENTLY DISABLED
STILL HAS TO AT POINTS GO
THROUGH A PROCESS? TO RECERTIFY
THAT THERE PERMANENTLY DISABLED --
I JUST FOR IT JUST FEELS LIKE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WASTED TIME
AND EFFORT -- AND IT'S MAYBE
IT'S THE END OF THE DAY AND I'M
FRUSTRATED BUT BUT MY GOODNESS
YOU KNOW.
IT IS THE END OF THE DAY BUT
IT'S STILL SOMETHING THAT IS
ONLY FOR LESS I KNOW.
I KNOW BUT IT IS IT IS I WANT TO
TALK TO YOU FRUSTRATED BUT IT IS
THE END OF THE DAY SO IT IS A
LONG DAY BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
AND IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
THE AREN'T ANY POPULATION --
THEIR SOMETHINGS ARE NOT GOING
TO CHANGE AND I APPRECIATE THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE STREAMLINED IS
GOING TO BE SIMPLIFIED.
BUT YOU'RE HEARING THAT IF IT
CAN BE SIMPLE FARTED PICKING BE
STREAMLINED IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE WOULD CERTAINLY WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT.
OF MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I'M
GONNA ECHO -- MY COLLEAGUES OF
KIND OF THIS MAY THAT WE PUT
THIS ONEROUS TASK ON SOME FOLKS --
IN IN THE MEDI CAL COMPONENT YOU
KNOW I'VE ACTUALLY SEEN.
WHERE THEY'VE ASKED DO YOU STILL
HAVE CEREBRAL PALSY?
OKAY THIS IS THE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS JUST.
RIDICULOUS.
AND YOU KNOW IT HI DID I HEAR
YOU SEE THE WORKING ON THIS TWO
TO THREE YEARS.
ON THIS ON THIS PROCESS RIGHT
HERE -- OKAY.
WHAT IS YOUR -- TO FALTER YOU TO
CLIMB PEOPLE BASED ON SOME OF
THESE ONEROUS TASK THAT THEY
JUST.
BY CAN'T DO IT ARE AND WHAT KIND
OF ASSISTANCE TO YOU GIVE --
GOING FORWARD I MEAN THERE THERE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO JUST DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FILL OUT
FORMS [inaudible]
AND AND IF THEY DON'T FILL IT
OUT RIGHT.
AND YOUR KICKING IT OUT.
WHAT KIND OF TIME FRAMES ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT TO GET IN GETTING
THESE FOLKS?
ASSISTANCE I MEAN.
WE KNOW IT'S IT'S A LARGE --
POPULATION THAT DOES AS WELL AND
AGAIN I GUESS BECAUSE I'M SEEING.
EIGHTEEN PAGES ON FIFTY SIX ON
ANOTHER -- I'M THINKING THERE'S
SOME PEOPLE THAT MAKES MISTAKES.
AND DECLINED MMHM -- THAT'S NOT
COOL.
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY -- A
PRIORITY HAS BEEN FOR THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION AND TO THE NEW SO
MINISTRATION TO STREAMLINE ALL
OF THESE PROCESSES TO GET EVERY
FEDERAL WAIVER WE CAN. TO MOVE
THINGS ONLINE. TO MOVE
INTERVIEWS TO TELEPHONE FROM
FACE TO FACE. TO VERIFY THINGS
ELECTRONICALLY TAKE A PICTURE OF
YOUR PAY STUB AND ON YOUR PHONE
AND SEND IT TO ME RATHER THAN GO
FIND A COPIER IN THE POST OFFICE
SO WE HAVE IT EVERY STEP TRIED
TO ELIMINATE WASTE.
WE'VE ALSO ADDED TO OUR PUBLIC
DATA DASHBOARD. TO METRICS THAT
ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
LITTLE WONKY HERE BUT ONE IS
PROCEDURAL DENIAL.
THAT'S A PERSON DIDN'T MAKE IT
THROUGH THE PROCESS WE DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW.
IF THEY WERE ELIGIBLE OR NOT BUT
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO FINISH THE AT
REQUIRED INTERVIEW THE REQUIRED
VERIFICATION AND WE WATCH THAT
NUMBER VERY CAREFULLY AND SHARE
WITH OUR COUNTIES THEIR
INNOVATION OF BEST PRACTICES TO
REDUCE.
SAME THING AT RESERVE VACATION
IT'S CALLED TURN.
RIGHT WILL YOU DON'T GET THROUGH
THE PROCESS WHEN YOU COME BACK
INTERRUPTING THE BENEFIT THAT
YOU NEED TO BE HEALTHY AND
STABLE AND CREATING MORE WORK
AND WASTE.
SO WE ARE VERY WITHIN OUR
FEDERAL FRAMEWORK.
IN WITHIN THE CAN WITH DRIVEN BY
COUNTY INNOVATION WHERE CAN WE
THREE STEPS WE GOTTA DO APPLY
INTERVIEW AND VERIFY HOW DO WE
STREAMLINED EACH OF THOSE WE CAN
MEET YOU AT THE DOOR YOU WANT TO
WALK THROUGH.
IT'S SUCH A IT'S AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE SO ONE OF THE THINGS I
WOULD I WOULD ASK THEM.
IS THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE AGENCIES. TO
SAY THAT THESE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS ARE ONEROUS AND AND
AND TASK US TO WORK WITH OUR
FEDERAL ACTIVES. TO MAKE CHANGE --
BECAUSE THIS IS AN ACCEPTABLE
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE TO CONTINUAL.
CONTINUALLY DO THESE ONEROUS
BECAUSE OF FEDERAL REGULATION.
AND WE'VE BEEN WE'VE INVOLVED
TECHNOLOGY IS HERE -- THERE'S
EASIER WAYS TO DETERMINE --
OUTCOMES AND I'M LIKE I SAID I
HOPE I WOULD REALLY THINK THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW.
THE PEOPLE ARE SYMPATHETIC IN
THE LEGISLATURE [inaudible]
LAWLER BUT LEE SIXTY ONE OF MORE --
I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT.
CONTACT YOUR FEDERAL
REPRESENTATIVES AND SEEKING
CHANGE [inaudible]
IS.
IRAN AND I HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
THE SEVEN YEARS I'VE NEVER SEEN
AN OUT REACH TO ME.
ABOUT THESE THESE ARE ONEROUS TO
THE AGENCY WE NEED TO CHANGE OR
ALL OR HARMFUL TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WE REPRESENT.
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONVEYED.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
OF THE LAST -- ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN OF REGARDING THIS AREA
CRESSMAN WE'RE WE'RE JUST DOCTOR
AGO SO AS I'M SITTING HERE AND I
GUESS IT IT.
IT.
IT REALLY IT REALLY BOTHERS ME
THAT.
THIS NUMBER ONLY 20% OF ELIGIBLE
LOW INCOME SENIORS ARE GETTING
THIS.
AND SO WHY PART OF I I WOULD
HAVE TO GET I'M I'M A GAS AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT MADE PART IS
MAYBE THIS THESE ONEROUS
APPLICATIONS I MEAN.
HAVE HAVE THERE BEEN STUDIES TO
REALLY FIND OUT WHAT IT IS
THAT'S DRIVING THAT 80%.
OF OUR SENIORS THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
HERE ARE PROBABLY.
HUNGRY YES.
YES WE IN ADDITION TO BEING POOR.
AND SO AND AND SO THAT'S THE
FIRST PART.
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING TO GET TO
THEM.
SO I WOULD SAY OF THE FIRST
THING WAS THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO GET THE THREE YEAR
CERTIFICATION NO INTERVIEW
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS FOR THEM.
THE SECOND PART IS EXPANSION OF
SSI.
WE'RE NOW AS OF JUNE FIRST ONE
POINT TWO MILLION SENIORS AND
PEOPLE DISABILITIES ON SS I WILL
BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR CAL FRESH
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVERYWHERE
ELSE IN THE COUNTRY THAT'S BEEN
TRUE FOR YEARS OR THE LAST STATE
TO BRING THAT.
POPULATION OF LOW INCOME SENIORS
SO THAT SHOULD HELP WITH OUR
PRECIPITATION RATE.
AND THIRDLY WHERE WE ARE --
WORKING VERY HARD ON OUT REACH
OUR OUTRAGE WEAPON ARE ON
SERVING SENIORS IS NEXT WEEK
WITH THE NOW NATIONAL COUNCIL ON
AGING AND OUT REACH EXPERTS ON
REACHING SENIORS.
ARE THE RIGHT MESSAGES AROUND --
THIS WILL HELP YOU STRETCH YOUR
BUDGET AND STAY HEALTHY YOU
WEREN'T TAKING IT FROM CHILDREN
THERE'S A LOT OF MESSAGING
THAT'S IMPORTANCE WE ALSO HAVE
COUNTY MODELS WANT TO COUNTY IN
FACT HAS A PARTICULAR SENIOR
ELIGIBILITY UNIT WHICH IN SOME
WAYS TO MAKE SURE SENIORS GET
THE TAILORED SERVICES.
THEY NEED SO I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU IT'S OUR IT'S OUR FASTEST
GROWING POPULATION IF THAT'S ANY --
IT'S SMALL BUT MIGHTY IT'S
GROWING UP WHILE OTHER
POPULATIONS ARE DECLINING WITH
THE ECONOMY AND WITH THE CLIMATE
FOR IMMIGRANTS SENIORS IS GOING
UP SO WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
RIGHT BUT WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO TO CLOSE THE GAP AND
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
HE SAID TWENTY SET YOU SAID
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO HOW'RE YOU
SAID THESE YOU STARTED DOING
SOME TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN WE
GOT THE PILOT EIGHTEEN WE GOT
THE EXPANSION OF AND EXPANSION
AS A SITE WHICH STARTS JUNE
FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN SO WHAT'S YOUR
JUST CHIPPING AWAY AT EACH OF
THESE PIECES BUT BUT THE NUMBERS
HAVE AN IMPROVED.
YES I'M HAPPY TO BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE A COMMITTEE YES SINCE
THAT SO WHERE ARE THE WHERE ARE
WE NOW HE SAID 20%.
SO WHERE ARE WE OUR SON IS THE
IMPROVED RATE.
WE IMPROVED RATE AND I THINK
IT'S EVEN IN PERSON WE CAN
COMPARE NOTES I THINK IT'S EVEN
IT'S EVEN BETTER ON THAT WERE
ALSO ABOUT TO DO -- YOU ARE
SIXTEEN BEFORE WE WERE THE WORST
FOR SURE.
WE ALSO WE ARE USING SOME OF THE
MONEY FROM THE SS I EXPANSION TO
PARTNER WITH AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING WHO WILL ALL BE CAL FRESH
OUT REACHES SISTERS BEGINNING
THIS SUMMER.
WE THINK HAVING TRUSTED
MESSENGERS FROM THE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING WILL ALSO HELP
US REACH THIS COMMUNITY SO WE DO
HAVE A MULTI.
SENIOR STRATEGY THAT AGAIN IS IS
MAKING PROGRESS AND HAPPY TO
SHARE THE DATA ON THAT'S ON OUR
DASHBOARD AND HAPPY TO SHARE IT
BUT NO QUESTION WERE LAST AND WE
NEED.
TO MAKE UP A LOT OF GROUND.
WHAT IS A DECLINE RATE?
HOW MANY PEOPLE GET DECLINED THE
FIRST ROUND GOING THROUGH?
OUR I COULDN'T DO IT BY SENIORS
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT
OVERALL ABOUT 606065% OF
APPLICATIONS ARE APPROVED JUST
ON THE NET IN GENERAL.
IN GENERAL.
WELL IN YOU CAN TELL FROM THE
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS THAT
YOU HAVE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THAT ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU AND TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR SENIORS.
DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LONG
PROCESS -- THAT THEY RECEIVE THE
BENEFITS THAT WE ARE ALL
DISMAYED.
THAT WE ARE.
WHAT WAS IT THE WORST -- WE HAVE
THE LOWEST PER TO SENIORS SNAP
PARTICIPATION RATE OF ANY STATE.
OF IT SO SOMETHING IS WRONG.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WRONG BUT
WE KNOW IT'S WRONG AND SO WE
WOULD LOOK TO YOU TO HELP US
FIND WHAT'S WRONG.
AND HELP HELP US TO THE WEAKENED.
ONCE IT'S IDENTIFIED FIGURE OUT
HOW WE FIX IT BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT 80% OF OUR
ELIGIBLE SENIORS NOT RECEIVING
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HELP THEM.
IN THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NOW.
AND NOW WE'RE REALLY ARE GOING
TO ISSUE NUMBER -- ELEVEN THE
LAST OF THE ISSUES IN THIS
SECTION.
WELCOME.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH KIM.
THIS IS.
I CAN OWNERS PROPOSAL GIVE YOU A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAMS -- BUT WE
WE RUN TO FEDERAL PROGRAMS OF
THE REGENCY FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH GOES FOR ABOUT
FIFTY FOOD BANK STATEWIDE TO
GIVING OUT WHAT USED TO BE
GOVERNMENT COMMODITIES
GOVERNMENT CHEESE BUT NOW IS A
MIX OF US AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
YOU ALSO MAY BE HAPPY TO KNOW
THAT OUR COMMODITY SUPPLEMENTAL
FOOD PROGRAM WHICH IS OUR SENIOR
FOOD BOX WERE NOW THE LARGEST IN
THE COUNTRY -- OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SENIORS GETTING A BOX
OF HEALTHY FOOD AND THE FOOD MIX
JUST CHANGE TO BE EVEN MORE
HEALTHY NUTRITIOUS MIX FOR
SENIORS.
AND JUST OF THOSE TWO FEDERAL
PROGRAMS WE RUN A SERIES OF
STATE PROGRAMS AND MOST RECENTLY
CAL FOOD -- PROVIDING CAL
PRODUCE TO THAT SAME NETWORK OF
FOOD BANKS THERE'S ALSO BEEN --
THE ONE TIME INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS DIAPER BANKS AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS.
THE BIG TRENDS FOR US JUST
QUICKLY A DISASTER FOOD BANK
FOOD WAS PROVIDED AND YOU COUNTY
AGAIN IN RESPONSE TO THE TO THE
FIRES WITH PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FEDS.
WE'VE ALSO HAD AN UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF FOOD BECAUSE OF THE
TRADE SURPLUS BECAUSE OF
PURCHASING DECISIONS BY USDA SO
FOOD BANKS ARE ABSORBING AND
DISTRIBUTING ON PRESS AND
AMOUNTS OF TRADE SURPLUS FOOD --
AND WE ARE ALSO TAKING A FRESH
LOOK AT HOW ARE LOGISTICS WHICH
LOGISTICS THIS YEAR LOOKING AT
WHERE WE HAVE WAREHOUSES IN
STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MEMBER FOOD
BANKS AND THE BANK ASSOCIATION
IT'S TIME FOR A FRESH LOOK AND
SO WE'RE DOING THAT.
THAT'S A SHORT SUMMARY OF THE
FOOD DISTRIBUTION PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
[inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
THE DID YOU PRESENT ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
SURE THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED A
TWO MILLION INCREASE TO
CALIPHATE ON TOP OF THE SIX
MILLION THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AND IS ALSO A ONE TIME TWENTY
MILLION -- INFRASTRUCTURE --
WANT TO INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT ON TOP OF FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION ALL THE PRIOR YEAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN REYES AND
THEN THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ANDREW SHAM HERE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS -- REPRESENTING THE
CONNECTION PARTNERSHIP OF SAN
BENITO COUNTY AND AND FOOD BANKS
ACROSS ACROSS THE STATE TO BE
SPEAKING TO BOTH.
OF ADVOCACY PROPOSALS TO
INCREASE THE THE CAL FOOD
INVESTMENT -- AND AND AND IT ALL
TO START BY SAYING MY THANKS FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE ONE
TIME ON THE CAPACITY -- JUST
INCREDIBLY GENEROUS AND AND
REALLY JUST EXCITED TO SEE THE
RESPONSIVENESS IN HIS VERY FIRST --
BUDGET ON THAT AND JUST TO THE
POINT THAT -- ISN'T QUITE WAIT
MADE ABOUT THE THE TRADE
MITIGATION FOOD IT IS TRUE THAT
THERE IS A THERE IS A LARGE
TEMPERING INCREASE IN FEDERAL
COMMODITIES INTERVAL TO FOOD
BANKS BUT THE CAME WITH NO
STORAGE AND DISTRIBUTION FUNDING --
AND SO THAT FOOD IS NOT GONNA
TRUCK ITSELF KEEP ITSELF COLD
LET ALONE SAFE -- FOR RESIDENTS
TO EAT AND SO THAT REALLY
DOVETAILS WITH WHY WE ARE
ADVOCATING BOTH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVELS ON THESE ISSUES
BUT CERTAINLY VERY EXCITED TO
SEE ON THE RECOGNITION THAT
THERE IS ANY FOR FOR CAPACITY --
AND AS I TALK ABOUT HELP YOU
JUST A BRIEF NOTE ON EMERGENCY
SAFETY NET AND WHY IT IS VITAL
FOR THE STATE TO INVESTMENT ONLY
IN ITS PUBLIC PROGRAMS I
APPRECIATE THAT.
THE PRIOR DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CAL FRESH IS
OBVIOUSLY IS OUR FIRST AND BEST
DEFENSE AGAINST HUNGER -- BUT AS
YOUR MATERIALS ILLUSTRATE
WHETHER IT'S THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING WHETHER IT'S THAT THE
DEVASTATING FIRES I MEAN IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THE RED EMPIRE --
FOOD BANK THEY'RE STILL DEALING
WITH THE CINEMA FIRE THE LONG
TAIL WHEN FOLKS HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES THEY'VE BEEN DISRUPTED --
YOU KNOW WE ARE THE ONES WITHOUT --
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT -- FEEDING
US THIS HOUSEHOLDS AND THEN MOST
RECENTLY THE FEDERAL THREATS YOU
HEARD THAT THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE ABLE BODIED
ADULTS THE THREAT AS WELL AS
PUBLIC CHARGE WE HAVE HOUSEHOLDS
COMING INTO FOOD BANKS ASKING TO
COME OFF OF COVERAGE.
BECAUSE IT'S MORE TRUSTED SITES
CAUGHT THE PROGRAM AND NOTHING
IS MORE HEARTBREAKING FOR AN
APPLICATION CISTERCIAN PEOPLE ON
THE PROGRAM THEN DID THEN BE
FACING THAT.
AND THEN LASTLY JUST BRIEFLY
THAT THE FEDERAL SHUTDOWN AND I
THINK WE ALL SAW THAT SO MANY
HOUSEHOLD EVEN IF THEY'RE
EMPLOYED ARE JUST ONE PAYCHECK
AWAY FROM HAVING TO COME TO FOOD
BANKS.
AND THE SPECIAL DISTRIBUTIONS
LET ALONE THE SNAP GAP AND MY
SINCERE THANKS TO THE PART. TO
THE COUNTY SEAT MINISTRATION
BRING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE UNDER
THEIR POWER -- BUT EVEN AN
AVERAGE MONTH A THIRD OF
HOUSEHOLDS ON CALPERS ARE STILL
COMING TO FOOD BANKS BECAUSE THE
BENEFIT DOESN'T LAST MONTH AND
THE SNAP GAP -- REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED HOW HOW IMPORTANT
THAT THE BACKSTOP THIS AND SO
THAT'S WHERE CAL FOOD PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE AGAIN -- AS
MISSING OKAY WAIT SAID WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL TO SEE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S FIRST BUDGET THE
CONTINUATION OF THE EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR TOTAL LEVEL --
AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK --
THE GOVERNOR FOR CONTINUING THAT
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION'S GOING
TO AT LEAST SIX BILLION DOLLARS
BUT THEN IT HAS BEEN EIGHT
MILLION TOTAL THE PAST TWO YEARS
BUT I ASK IS TO RAISE THAT TO
TWENTY FOUR POINT.
FIVE WHICH IS ACTUALLY AS YOUR
AGENDA NICELY POINTS OUT THAT'S
THAT'S THE MAXIMUM WE COULD PUT
TO OUR SYSTEM THERE ARE REAL
CAPACITY IMITATIONS IF YOU GO TO
A FOOD BANK.
YOU KNOW THAT THE WAREHOUSES
RIGHT -- THERE'S NOT SPACED OUT
TO PUT THE FOOD THEY'RE TRYING
TO FILL IT TOO DIDN'T THERE AND
DONATIONS AND BY AND LARGE
THROUGH BANKS ARE SUPPORTED YOU
KNOW 9095% WITH PRIVATE
DONATIONS.
BUT IT'S THAT SMALL PIECE OF THE
STATE CAN FIND AT THE FEDERAL --
COMMODITIES THAT COME THROUGH
THE HELP SUPPORT THAT -- REALLY
ALLOW US TO BUY THAT THE PRODUCE
THE PROTEINS AND A HALF FROM
THIS PARTICULAR POSITION OF
THOSE BUTLER FROM SAMBAR AND YOU
KNOW IT'S TURKEY ALMONDS AND OAT
MEAL THERE ALL ONLINE WITH THEIR
HEALTHY FOOD BANK POLICY.
ON THAT YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO THINGS LIKE TRICKING
ALMONDS YOU KNOW VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE NOT GONNA GET DONATED
AND IT'S IT'S THOSE KIND OF
ITEMS THAT THE BANKS ARE USING
THESE THESE VALUABLE PURCHASE
DOLLARS.
FOR AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF THE BANG FOR THE BUCK --
MOSTLY BANKSARE SEARCHING THOSE
TO ABOUT FORTY FIVE MILES PER
DOLLAR BECAUSE AGAIN THEY'RE
LEVERAGING THE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE AND ALL THE PRIVATE
DONATIONS -- SO IT THE THE WISE
USE OF STATE RESOURCES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING MISS BUTLER FROM SAM
PORTANTINO.
QUESTIONS YES DOCTOR WOULD IN
THE MOST FRAZIER.
QUESTION -- HOW HOW MANY OF THE
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA HOW
MANY -- GOING BACK TO OUR
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION SENIORS
MIGHT BE COMING IN WHO.
WHO ARE IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING
TO GET?
HOW FRESH THEY'RE THEY'RE COMING
INTO YOUR FACILITY FOR EMERGENCY
FOOD?
YEAH IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS A
GOOD FOR US TO ANSWER BECAUSE AS
I TESTIFIED TO WITH SIMILAR
PUBLIC CHARGE WE SPECIFICALLY
DON'T ASK VERY MANY QUESTIONS --
I WILL TRY AND SEE IF YOUR FOOD
BANK FOR EXAMPLE IF IT MAKES IN
YOUR DISTRICT -- ARE ASKING AT
LEAST BASIC DEMOGRAPHICS LIKE
ARE YOU OLDER AMERICAN ARE YOU
SENIOR SOME KIND OF AGE
SOMETIMES THOSE KIND OF
QUESTIONS WILL BE ASKED BUT IN
GENERAL WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID
THOSE QUESTIONS WHICH MAKES I
WISH I HAD BETTER.
A DATA FOR A QUESTION LIKE THAT
SO I GUESS THAT BRINGS ME TO MY
OTHER QUESTION WHICH IS.
SINCE PEOPLE ARE COMING THERE
FOR FOOD AND AND MANY OF THEM
MIGHT BE SENIORS.
SHOULD WE NOT BE HAVING STATE
RESOURCES THERE TO HELP ENROLL
PEOPLE IN CAL FRONT SHIP THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE.
AND HELP THEM THROUGH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
ON SITE COULD WE NOT FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO INTEGRATE SOME OF THOSE
SERVICES TO MAKE IT EASIER.
YES AND WE DO SO IT WENT OUT I
WAS I WAS OUR PRICING NAY
MONNING DID YOU KNOW EXACT
AMOUNTS -- SO AS TO WHAT NONE OF
US ANSWER TO WE DID.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW I JUST I JUST WANT
TO SEE IT DONE YOU KNOW.
MAIL COULDN'T COULDN'T AGREE
MORE -- AND I WILL SEE THAT
THERE ARE SOME DATA THAT FOOD
BANKS HAVE I KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY COMMITTEE
FOOD BANK WHICH HAS MORE
RESOURCES TO DO THESE KIND OF
DEMOGRAPHIC SURVEYS NOTED THAT
FROM TWENTY TEN WHICH IS AROUND
THE TIME OF THE CUTS TO THE
EXERCISES P..
GRANTS TO TWENTY FOURTEEN IS A
QUADRENNIAL SURVEY THEIR SENIOR
POPULATION DOUBLED AND SO WE
KNOW WE HAVE SOME SOME BROAD
STROKES IN KNOWING -- THAT WE
NEED TO IMPROVE THE SENIOR
POSITION CAL FRESH THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT BETWEEN THE LOW
GRANTS THE EXCLUSION WHICH AGAIN
IS GONNA AND IN JUNE FIRST FOR
US IS THAT RECIPIENTS THAT
SENIORS ARE OVER REPRESENTED IN
OUR IN OUR LINES AND THERE'S
MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO TURN
ADDRESS THAT.
BUT SPECIFICALLY -- FOOD BANKS
TO HOLD ONE OF THE LARGEST --
PRIME OCT SUBCONTRACTS ON
COVERAGE OUT REACH AND IT IS A
VITAL PARTNERSHIP IN LINE OR
WITH WITH PRIVATE CONSULTATIONS
I'M TRYING TO ASSESS FOLKS TO
GET OUT OF THE PROGRAM AND AND
AND ADDRESSING SOME OF THE MISS
THAT MISSING QUITE WAIT ADDRESS
BECAUSE LOTS OF SENIOR SAY
THINGS LIKE.
ALL I DON'T ONE ELSE EVEN FOR
SOMEONE ELSE OR IT'S ONLY
FIFTEEN DOLLARS A MONTH TO
REALLY TRYING TO TO PAINT THAT
PICTURE IT'S THAT RICHARD IS A
BIG PART OF THE PUSH FOR JUNE
FIRST WITH SSI.
THANK YOU.
MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU -- SO.
AND CONTRA COSTA THEIR BULGING
AT THE SEAMS WITH -- WITH
PRODUCT IN IN IN THE JUST NOT
ENOUGH ROOM SO I CAN APPRECIATE
TALK ABOUT THE CAPITAL NEED --
BUT IN YOUR IN YOUR FIRE YOU
TALK ABOUT THE THE STATE'S
CLIMATE CHANGE ACTIONS
[inaudible]
CAN YOU.
SHARE WITH US WHAT IT WOULD --
HOW MUCH IT DIMINISHES THE
ABILITY BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE
YOUR OF YOUR DOING ABOUT ONE
EIGHT OF THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA?
FEEDING RIGHT NOW -- HOW MANY
PEOPLE DOES THE TO DO THESE
RESTRICTIONS?
LIMIT YOU ARE TAKE AWAY FROM YOU
BEING ABLE TO SERVICE.
SO THAT'S GONNA VERY AND I MAY
HAVE BEEN FELT ABOUT THE ANY
MONEY IN A MONEY YOU KNOW I'M
OUT.
WELL IT IT IS A LITTLE DIFFICULT
TO GET TO QUALIFY AT THE TOP
JUST BECAUSE WHAT'S THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS ARE HAPPENING
THERE ARE THE THE CLEAN BURNING
YOU KNOW EMISSIONS STANDARDS FOR
TRUCKS.
AND NOT FOR SOMETHING MAKES IS
GONNA REQUIRE AN ENTIRE FLEET
OVERALL -- AND SO I HAVE TO
CHECK WITH THE SHAMAN AND AND
LARRY AT YOUR YOUR FEEDBACK
ABOUT IS THAT WHAT THAT MEANS
BUT THE BIGGER ISSUE IS THE THE
STATE TRYING TO DIVERT 20% OF
EDIBLE FOOD.
FROM LANDFILL TO PEOPLE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IS A NOBLE GOAL BUT
WHO IS STUCK TRYING TO GET THAT
FOOD FROM FROM A TO B. IS THE
EMERGENCY FOOD RECOVERY SYSTEM.
WITH YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FROM A LOT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS AND SO
IT IS A COMPLICATED PICTURE FOR
PROJECTS RIGHT NOW.
WELL WE'VE SEEN IN THE RECYCLE
INDUSTRY THAT WE CREATED A
CONDAMINE IN THIRD WORLD
COUNTRIES AND THEN THEY
MONOPOLIZED IT AND THEN THEY
TOOK DROVE IT INTO THE TOILET SO.
I MEAN.
WHEN THE THINGS DON'T ARE
WORKING ON IT ON?
MONIES -- PROGRAM.
SUCH AS YOURS AND YOU NEED TO
REACH OUT TO US THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAYBE POSSIBLY.
CREATING OFFRAMP IN LEGISLATION
THAT WHEN CAN'T WHEN YOU CAN AND
IT IS.
OF DURABLE.
OF THE THEN EVERY EFFORT SHOULD
BE MADE BUT IF IT'S ONEROUS AND
A RESTRICTIVE AND ACTUALLY
IMPACTS YOUR YOUR BOTTOM LINE OF
HELPING THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE
CHARGED TO DO.
FROM THE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW THAT AND SO THAT WE CAN
ADJUST ITS NOBLE TO HAVE.
GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS BUT WAS
HARMFUL TO A POPULATION IT YOU
ARE.
PUTTING YOURSELF OUT THERE AGAIN
I ABSOLUTE MEYER WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
WHEN I HAD A COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION -- THE FOOD BANK WAS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL FOR THE
POPULATION THAT WE WERE SERVING --
BUT WE SOMETIMES MAKE --
DECISIONS THAT HAVE GONE INTO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FOR
OTHER.
OTHER FOLKS AND SO WE NEED TO BE
VOCAL AND BE ABLE TO ADJUST
THOSE WHEN THEY'RE IMPROPER.
I HAVE SOME IN DEPTH REGULAR
COME INSIDE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH -- ALL IN GOOD THANK
YOU I'LL GIVE YOU HIS CELL PHONE
NUMBER.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT IS THE THE
LAST OF THIS PARTICULAR AREA --
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
PRESENTERS -- IN THIS AREA --
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND AGAIN I REMIND YOU.
BECAUSE I DO WANT EVERYONE.
TO GET HOME.
HAVE DINNER WITH YOUR FAMILY
SPEND TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY
SLEEPING YOUR OWN BAD.
SO I ASK AGAIN THAT WE LIMITED
TO ONE MINUTE -- AND TELL US
WHICH SITE WHICH OF THE ISSUES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OR ALL OF
THEM THANK YOU.
ABOUT YOUR SON OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL
THE THREE ISSUES THAT WE JUST
HEARD NINE THROUGH -- ELEVEN ON
NUMBER NINE REALLY QUICKLY I'M
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL
I AM AND HAVE BEEN WORKING
REALLY CLOSELY WITH ALL THREE OF
THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING THE A BROAD RULE
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND
CAN
ATTEST TO HOW HARMFUL IT IS SO
WEIRD STRONG IN SONG STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT PROPOSAL.
ON ISSUE NUMBER -- TEN AROUND
THE ELDERLY SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION -- BUT WE ALSO
IDENTIFIED THAT AS A KEY
STRATEGY TO BE ABLE TO ENROLL AS
MANY -- SS I RECIPIENTS AS
POSSIBLE ON TO CALPERS AS OF
JUNE FIRST AND SO.
BETTER LATE THAN NEVER AND
DEFINITELY SUPPORT MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT STRATEGY --
AND ON NUMBER -- ELEVEN I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE THAT ARE USED TO
WORK AT THE SAN FRANCISCO MARIN
FOOD BANK I'M WHICH IS A MISTER
TINGS DISTRICT -- AND CAN SPEAK
FIRST HAND TO HOW IMPACTFUL THE
CALHOUN FUNDING WAS.
THEM.
OUR FOOD EGGS WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT IS YOU KNOW REALLY
NUTRITIOUS SOURCE OF PROTEIN AND
ALSO AN ITEM THAT'S BASICALLY
NEVER DONATED AND FAIRLY
EXPENSIVE TO PURCHASE.
I AM.
AND I THINK OF THE TIME WE WERE
PURCHASING SIXTY THOUSAND DOZEN
EGGS A MONTH IN ORDER TO SERVE
PEOPLE EVERY OTHER WEEK WITHOUT
PROTEIN SOURCE SO -- ALTHOUGH
YOU KNOW GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
INVESTMENT THAT'S BEEN MADE SO
FAR WE REALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THAT TIME BUDGET ITEM INCREASED
SO THAT WE CAN SERVE EVEN MORE
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING MORE ABOUT ISSUE
TEN BUT ON ISSUE NINE JUST WANNA
REALLY STROH A STRONG SUPPORT
FOR STRENGTHENING THE STATE BANK
FOR EXEMPTIONS -- I'M A FORMER
FOOD STAMP RECIPIENT MYSELF WHEN
I WAS ON FOOD STAMPS I WAS IN A
BOXIF I HAD BEEN CUT OFF AFTER
THREE MONTHS I REALLY WOULD HAVE
STRUGGLE TO GET THE FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT GONE TO GET A
MASTER'S DEGREE.
ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT BECAME
MY LIFE'S POTENTIAL -- SO REALLY
REALLY REALLY SUPPORT ANYTHING
THAT AT THE STATE LEVEL --
ADDITIONALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CALIPHATE PROGRAM OUR FOOD
BANKS ARE ESSENTIAL IN FILLING
IN THE GAPS THAT OUR SAFETY NET
DOESN'T ME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FRANK
MECCA WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF I'D ISSUE NINE ALSO
CONCEPTUAL IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
TEN RELATED TO THE SIMPLIFIED
APPLICATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
ADVOCATES AND THE DEPARTMENT ON
THE COST AND AUTOMATION
IMPLICATIONS THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON JACK ALONG WITH
GRAYSON SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER
NINE US PERFECTLY BECAUSE THERE
ARE A LOT OF NONSENSE REALLY
PARENTS ARE LIVING IN PARTY AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN BECAUSE WE KNOW A LOT OF
FAMILIES LIVING IN POVERTY THE
POVERTY RELY ON THE BANKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- WE ALMOST MISSED
YOU -- REVEAL MORE ARE FROM
SUPPLY BIG DOT ORG IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER NINE TEN AND THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT CONCLUDES THE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU ALL AGAIN -- TO ALL
THE PANELISTS. FOR THE NEXT.
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE IT HAS
TO DO WITH IMMIGRATION RAPID
RESPONSE OF IMMIGRATION SERVICES
PROGRAM.
AND ASSOCIATED ADVOCACY
PROPOSALS.
ALL RIGHT WHERE CELEBRITIES.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US HERE TONIGHT TO SPEAK TO THE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES --
WE PROVIDED THE COMMITTEE WITH
THAT A REPORTS ON THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERING AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS -- ON THAT
REPORT.
WE JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
ITEMS AND ADDRESS A THE TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION RELATED TO
THE DOCTOR LEGAL SERVICES THAT
WAS POSED RIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE.
SO THE COMMITTEE KNOWS CURRENTLY
THE DEPARTMENT IS ADMINISTERING
TO ONGOING LEGAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
ONE TIME INVESTMENT STUFF FOR
LEGAL SERVICES AND OTHER.
SERVICES TO IMMIGRANTS -- THE
LARGER OF THE TWO PROGRAMS IS
THE ONE CALIFORNIA OR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES FUNDING
WHICH IS IN ITS FOURTH YEAR --
THIS YEAR THE DEPARTMENT AWARDED
GRANTS TO ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO PROVIDE
NATURALIZATION SERVICES REMOVAL
DEFENSE OTHER IMMIGRATION
REMEDIES.
A EDUCATION AND OUTREACH AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- JUST TO
BRIEFLY A BREAK DOWN OF THE
INVESTMENT ABOUT 14% OF THE
INVESTMENT WENT TOWARD
NATURALIZATION SERVICES.
ABOUT 20% -- TOWARD REMOVAL
DEFENSE AND THEN A 26% TOWARD
OTHER IMMIGRATION REMEDIES.
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO MADE AN
INVESTMENT OF ABOUT TWO POINT
NINE MILLION AND CAPACITY
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE DESIGNED TO
EXPAND LEGAL SERVICES IN
UNDERSERVED REGIONS OR FOR
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS EXAMPLES
OF THAT INCLUDE.
EXTENDING SERVICES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
CENTRAL COAST AND FOUR API
COMMUNITIES DEPORTED VETERANS --
THE OTHER ONGOING PROGRAM
CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IS THE LEGAL SERVICES
FOR UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS -- THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
IN PLACE NOW FOR FIVE YEARS AND
WITHOUT PROGRAM THE TO IT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO FUND SERVICES FOR
OVER THREE THOUSAND MINERS TO
DATE.
ABOUT 80% OF THE THE MINERS WHO
HAVE WHO HAVE SOUGHT RELIEF
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM ARE SEEKING
ASYLUM RELIEF -- WHICH SPEAKS TO
THE COUNTRY CONDITIONS THAT THEY
ARE FLEEING -- AND MOSTLY
NORTHERN -- TRIANGLE COUNTRIES.
AND THEN FINALLY I CAN SPEAK TO
THE QUESTION AROUND THE DOCK A
LEGAL SERVICES PROGRAM THAT WAS
POSED BY BY THE COMMITTEE -- SO
AS THE COMMITTEE IS LIKELY AWARE --
DHAKA AS A REMEDY -- REMAINS
QUITE UNCERTAIN -- THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION HAS ASKED THE US
SUPREME COURT TO TAKE IT UPON
REVIEW WHICH THEY DECLINED TO DO
IN THIS TERM BUT POTENTIALLY
COULD DO SO IN THE IN THE
FOLLOWING TERM.
THERE ARE ROUGHLY I WOULD SAY
ABOUT.
EIGHT LAWSUITS INVOLVING DAKEN
FOR DIFFERENT DISTRICT COURT
CASES ANYONE OF THEM COULD.
MOVE FORWARD IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS FROM THEM AS MUCH AS WE
ARE WE ALSO HAVE THE POTENTIAL
OF THE OF THE SUPREME COURT.
TAKING ON ON THE ON THE CASE
THAT SAID WHEN THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THEIR
INTENT TO TERMINATE DHAKA IN
SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE STATE MADE
MADE AN INVESTMENT OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ASSIST DHAKA
ELIGIBLE.
IMMIGRANTS WITH A WITH WRITTEN
WITH DOC A RENEWALS -- THAT
FUNDING HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED AS OF
MARCH OF THIS YEAR -- ROUGHLY
OVER AN EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD
THE FUNDING WAS EXHAUSTED WITH A
ABOUT 90% OF THE FUNDS BEING
USED FOR FOR DOCTOR RENEWALS AND
ALSO FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THE
USCIS FILING FEES WHICH ARE
ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
PER APPLICATION.
WITHOUT FUNDING -- THE PROVIDERS
WHICH THE DEPARTMENT -- AWARDED
GRANTS TO WERE ABLE TO ASSIST
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
WITH RENEWALS -- SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED USCIS
FILING FEES AS WELL AS PROVIDING
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION AROUND.
DOCK -- WHICH IS WHICH IS A VERY
MUCH NEEDED BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THE UNCERTAINTY IN THE CONSTANT
CHANGES AROUND DHAKA.
CITY REACHED ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS -- THROUGH
EDUCATION OUTREACH.
COULD YOU BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
ABSOLUTELY -- THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING TO OF CONTINUOUS
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR IT LEGAL SERVICES
THAT INCLUDES FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE ONE CALIFORNIA
FUND.
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED MINOR
FUND.
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES MAKING --
OF SEVERAL ONE TIME A FUNDING --
FUNDING SOURCES ON GOING SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
IMMIGRANTS -- STUDENTS AND STAFF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AS WELL
AS A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION -- THAT PRIMARILY
FOCUSES ON LEGAL SERVICES FOR
BENEFICIARIES OF TEMPORARY
PROTECTED STATUS WHICH THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO.
ANNOUNCED ITS INTENT TO AND AND
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS OR MINOR
SPACING REMOVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LIKE SPEAKER
PLEASE.
THE NAME TAMAKO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
AND RESPONSE THE QUESTIONS IN
THE AGENDA REGARDING THE RAPID
RESPONSE FURTHER IF I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO SOME CLARIFICATIONS THAT THIS
PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING RESOURCES
FOR A RESERVE SIMILAR TO THE
FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS AND IS NOT BUDGET
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE REQUESTED TWENTY MILLION.
WOULD BE AND A SEPARATE RESERVE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS RESERVE WAS DESIGNED
TO BE FLEXIBLE IN ORDER TO MEET
FUTURE EMERGENT SITUATIONS
REGARDING IMMIGRATION HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHERE FEDERAL
FUNDING WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE.
WELL WE CAN ANTICIPATE WHAT
FUTURE SITUATIONS MAY
MATERIALIZE THEM MINISTRATION
WANTS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
FUNDING AVAILABLE THAT CAN BE
DISTRIBUTED. TO THE MOST
APPROPRIATE STAY ENTITY. TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE IN A
RESPONSIVE MANNER.
AND IN A VERY RESPONSIVE TIME
FRAME WE'RE WORKING ON WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON LANGUAGE
RIGHT NOW THAT WE'RE HOPING TO
RELEASE BY THE END OF THE MONTH
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO KEEP
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THANK YOU
AND IF.
WE CAN GO BACK TO MYSTERIES.
ON THE RAPID RESPONSE.
COULD YOU.
COMMENT.
COMMENTS ON THE RAPID RESPONSE
THE TWENTY MILLION.
ABSOLUTELY THE GOVERNOR'S --
BUDGET IS PROPOSING TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR RAPID
RESPONSE -- FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF MADE OF THE THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE AVAILABLE AND CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS TRANSFERRED IT TO
ABOUT TWO POINT TWO MILLION.
DOLLARS OF THAT FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO ADMINISTER --
WHICH THAT FUNDING HAS BEEN
AWARDED TO AN ORGAN A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IN OF SAN DIEGO --
ARE OPERATING A SHELTER THAT IS
PROVIDING SHELTER SERVICES TO TO
THE MIGRANT FAMILIES ARRIVING IN
IN IN SAN DIEGO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF CERTAINLY -- TONY
MOTEL.
YES -- LA ON HE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
SIX I WANTED TO REVIEW MY
QUESTIONS I BELIEVE YOU'VE
ALREADY COVERED THEM
[inaudible]
SONOMA [inaudible]
CAN YOU. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS --
COULD DSS WORK WITH ANOTHER
AGENCY IF NECESSARY THROUGH
INTER DEPARTMENTAL COORDINATION.
SYDNEY TEMAT APARTMENT FINANCE
WE BELIEVE THE RESERVE AS AS
IT'S CURRENTLY PROPOSES UNLESS
TIME EFFICIENT MECHANISM.
SO AND TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
THESE EMERGENT SITUATIONS WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING WE MAY NOT
KNOW WHICH STATE AGENCY WOULD BE
THE MOST APPROPRIATE TO RESPOND
TO WHAT SITUATION MAY ARISE.
SO WE REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT BY
HAVING THE FUNDING AND A RESERVE
RATHER THAN AS A PART OF A
DEPARTMENTS BUDGET.
THAT ENABLES US TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY AND TO BE
ABLE TO REACT IN A MUCH MORE
TIME EFFICIENT WAY THAN ROUTING
THROUGH AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT WHICH CAN BE A LENGTHY
PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO ISSUE.
THIRTEEN REGARDING THE IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP.
WE ARE EXPECTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOAD IN A GONZALEZ.
AND WHEN SHE DOES ARRIVE WILL
HAVE HER ADDRESS [inaudible]
BOTH ISSUES.
I WILL BEGIN WITH JACKIE
GONZALEZ POLICY DIRECTOR.
THE JUSTICE AND DIVERSITY CENTER
OF THE BAR ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S AT ALL OF ALL THAT
ON YOUR BUSINESS CARD YET AND
THERE'S ACTUALLY MORE
BASED.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RAPID
RESPONSE NETWORK IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
IMMIGRANT.
JUSTICE.
ALL RIGHT THIS GONZALEZ THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THINK YOU
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS CHECKING
AND SALAS YOU ALL KNOW THE
VARIOUS COLLABORATIVE'S I NOW
REPRESENT -- THESE COLLABORATORS
OUR NETWORK OF LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS FOCUS ON PROVIDING
RAPID RESPONSE AND LEGAL
REPRESENTATION FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
CALIFORNIA STANDS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S WAR ON
IMMIGRANTS.
WERE HOME TO THE MOST ACTIVE
BORDER CROSSING IN THE WORLD.
AND HOME TO MORE IMMIGRANTS THAN
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
WORD FOR THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
THIS IS OUR HOME.
IMMIGRANTS READ THE STATE ARE
VULNERABLE TO ARBITRARY ARRESTS
INHUMANE DETENTION AND
DEPORTATION WITHOUT DUE PROCESS.
IMMIGRATION IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLEX AREAS OF THE LAW.
AND I'VE EVER EVOLVING.
BUT THOSE IMMIGRANTS WHO FACE
DEPORTATION ARE NOT GUARANTEED
ACCESS TO COUNSEL THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE CASES CAN
BE YEARS AND THE TENSION FAMILY
SEPARATION AND EXILE FROM THIS
COUNTRY.
THE NEED FOR LEGAL SERVICES
INFRASTRUCTURE IS MORE URGENT IN
THE RURAL REGIONS OF OUR STATE.
THOSE PLACES INCLUDE BRIDGES
LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
CENTRAL CLOSE.
THESE ARE HOME ALSO TO THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF
VULNERABLE IMMIGRANTS AND WHERE
ICE AGGRESSIVE ISAM FORSMAN
ACTIONS ARE MOST AGGRESSIVE.
AND TO DEFEND OUR COMMUNITIES WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT IMMIGRATION
COURT ROOMS IN THIS COUNTRY
WHERE TODAY SO MANY OF
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS STANDALONE
ARE TRULY THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS BATTLE.
THE ONE TIME US THAT WE ARE
MAKING IS FOR FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A PILOT
PROGRAM CALLED THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP.
IT WOULD PROVIDE THE FIRST STATE
SPONSORED FELLOW FELLOW PROGRAM
TO INCREASE REMOVAL DEFENSE
REPRESENTATION FOR OUR RESIDENTS.
IT WOULD INCREASE WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LAW STUDENTS
AND YOUNG ATTORNEYS WHO WANT TO
GET BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITY AND
WORK IN THESE REGIONS OF HIGH
NEEDS BUT HAVE NO VIABLE OPTIONS
FOR DOING SO.
FINALLY IT WOULD EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF REPUTABLE LEGAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS ELIGIBLE
TO PROVIDE THESE CRITICAL
SERVICE AND IN THESE REGIONS
WERE IMMIGRATION FRIED AND THE
THOUGHT HE WAS ARE RAMPANT THIS
SERVICE COULD NOT BE MORE NEEDED.
TODAY YOU WILL HEAR FROM
ORGANIZATIONS WERE EAGER TO LAND
THE SUPPORT TO THIS EFFORT AND I
HAVE TO SAY AS A DEPORTATION
DEFENSE ATTORNEY WHO'S BEEN
PRACTICING IN THIS AREA FOR TEN
YEARS.
IT'S REALLY INSPIRING TO LOOK
AROUND AND SEE THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN THIS ROOM HERE -- WITH ME
TODAY.
SOME OF THEM TRAINED ME WHEN I
WAS A LAW STUDENT AND THERE WAS
HALF OF AN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY.
AT AN ORGANIZATION IN THE BAY
AREA TO DATE THAT ORGANIZATION
WHICH IS A FORMER EMPLOYER
EMPLOYER OF MINE HAS.
FORTY FIVE STAFF DEDICATED TO
IMMIGRATION.
AND THAT'S IN TEN YEARS AND I
BELIEVE THAT IF WE INVEST IN A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS THAT CAN BE IN
A A REALITY IN ALL OF THESE
UNDERSERVED REGIONS OF OUR STATE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE PEOPLE
ARE HERE FROM THESE REGIONS CAN
BEST SPEAK TO THE NEEDS -- BUT I
THINK THE MOST INSPIRING THING
IS THAT WE'RE ALL HERE TOGETHER
IN PARTNERSHIP.
AND THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS
REALLY BEEN WRITTEN BY PEOPLE
WHO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND -- BOTH FROM THE
LEGAL SIDE AND THE COMMUNITY
SITE AND ARE READY TO EXECUTE
SOMETHING OF THIS MAGNITUDE I
THINK CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO MAKE
THIS INVESTMENT.
AND WE NEED TO BE A LEADER IN
THIS AREA WE ALREADY ARE BY THE
GENEROUS INVESTMENT THAT'S BEEN
MADE A FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS BUT
FRANKLY THOSE DOLLARS ARE NOT
FLOWING TO THESE REGIONS.
AND SO THAT IS WHERE THE SPIRIT
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS COMING FROM
AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
EVENING AND NIGHT AND I WILL
KEEP THESE COMMENTS BRIEF I'M.
BECAUSE I WANT THE COMMUNITY TO
SPEAK AND ULTIMATELY THE STORIES
THAT THEY WILL SHARE WITH YOU
TONIGHT ARE WHAT'S BEHIND THIS
PROPOSAL SO EVERY RESIDENT OF
OUR STATE WE BELIEVE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS AND
QUALITY REMOVAL DEFENSE SERVICES.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT FUNDING THIS
FELLOWSHIP IS THE FIRST STEP TO
ENSURING CALIFORNIA REMAINS A
HOME TO US ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE.
OUR SALARIES WITH -- DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THE
REGIONAL DISPARITIES IN TERMS OF
THE CAPACITY OF LEGAL SERVICES
PROVIDERS.
TO PROVIDE -- LEGAL SERVICES
AROUNDTHE MORE COMPLEX AREAS OF
THAT TYPE OF CASES INCLUDING
REMOVAL DEFENSE AND ALSO
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPACT THAT
REMOVAL CAN HAVE ON ON FAMILY
SEPARATING FAMILIES OR DENYING.
IMMIGRANTS TO DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
AND TO THAT END WE HAVE MADE
TARGETED INVESTMENTS IN CERTAIN
REGIONS TO TO TRY TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE -- SOME OF THESE
GAPS INCLUDING PAIRING.
LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS IN --
AREAS LIKE THE BAY AREA THAT MAY
HAVE MORE EXPERTISE WITH
PROVIDERS AND AND RURAL AREAS
LIKE THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE
THEY ARE ATTEMPTING.
TO DEVELOP THEIR CAPACITY.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK -- PLEASE.
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU.
I CAN'T AGREE.
WITH YOU MORE ABOUT THE
DESPERATE NEED TO PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES.
ARE WE ALSO A QUITTING HIS THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE'VE NOT
FUNDED THE COURTS.
AN APPROPRIATE FASHION TO CATCH
UP WITH THE DEMAND I'VE
CONSTITUENTS.
THAT THE WINDOWS CLOSED AT LIKE
ONE OR TWO O'CLOCK IN THE
AFTERNOON.
AND ALSO THE COURTS ARE IMPACTED
AS OF THE DEMAND -- ARE WE SURE
THAT.
AS A PARALLEL THAT WE SHOULD BE
FOR FUNDING THE COURTS IN AN
APPROPRIATE MANNER SO THAT.
INDIVIDUALS CAN GET A TIMELY.
A JUDICIAL REVIEW OR WHATEVER
WHATEVER THE PROCESS IS --
BECAUSE MY JUDGES IN MY DISTRICT.
ARE SAYING THE BILL THE FUNDING
IS IS A SHORTFALL IN THAT AREA
TOO AND WE CAN HAVE MORE OF
LEGALLY LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
FOR NOT GETTING THEM A TIMELY --
SAYS SEND.
THE REPRESENTED BITTER HILL IT'S
HIS FOR NOT.
SO IS IT HAVE YOU CHECKED IN TO
MAKE SURE OF WITH THE COURTS.
THAT.
WE PUT MORE LOAD ON THEM WITH
MORE LEGAL REPRESENTATION THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY.
ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE'RE TRYING.
TO TRYING TO GET NOW AND AGAIN I
WANT THIS TO HAPPEN SURE I MEAN
I THINK IN THIS CONTEXT IT'S
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE'S PURVIEW
TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE COURTS
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL.
IT'S A FEDERAL COURT -- I I
BELIEVE THAT THAT AGENCY HAS
SUFFICIENT FUNDING I MEAN THEY
THEY THEY NEED MORE ASSISTANCE
BUT I THINK -- THE COURTS ARE
OPERATING THEIR DEPORTING PEOPLE --
AND THE ISSUE IS NOT -- THAT.
THAT THEY NEED MORE FUNDING --
BUT FRANKLY AND IF THAT WERE THE
ISSUED IT WOULD BE OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE'S.
JURISDICTION IN PRAGUE IT'D TO
TO FIND A FEDERAL COURT
[inaudible]
DOES THAT.
GOOD ENOUGH TO GET. ONE OF THE
AREAS -- THE STATISTICS THAT ARE
NOTED WOULD YOU PLEASE SHARE
THOSE WITH US.
ABOUT THOSE WHO ARE REPRESENTED
AND THE MORE LIKELIHOOD OF THIS --
BEING SUCCESSFUL.
IN IN STOPPING A DEPORTATION
WHETHER YOU'RE REPRESENTED OR
NOT DOESN'T MAKE A DIFFERENCE --
THE A MAKES A DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE -- IT'S FIVE YOUR
FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO WIN
YOUR CASE IF YOU'RE REPRESENTED
BY AN ATTORNEY -- AND THAT'S FOR
THE NONCE TEEN POPULATION --
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DETAINED I
THINK HISTORICALLY NATIONALLY
ARE.
GET ACCESS TO COUNSELING MAY BE.
IT'S BURIED BETWEEN TEN AND 30% --
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
CLOSER 215% NATIONALLY AND WHAT
CALIFORNIA LEADS IN A LOT OF
WAYS -- THE STATISTICS ARE NOT
MUCH BETTER IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S A LACK
OF INTEREST I THINK -- AS
MYSTERIES NOTED IT'S A VERY
COMPLEX AREA OF LAW AND ONE THAT
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN VERY
CHALLENGING FOR NON PROFITS --
TO ENGAGE AND IN THE IN THE
EARLIER COMICS MYSTERIES I
APPRECIATED THAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT IT WAS IN THE
EARLIER ISSUE.
BUT EXPANDING INTO THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND I THINK WHEN I LOOK
AT A A A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS.
I LOVE IT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
IT'S GOING TO SERVE.
SO MANY PEOPLE -- AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND OF COURSE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I THAT I
WOULD ADVOCATE.
FOR BUT I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU
THAT THE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
WE NEED THIS.
TO WE DON'T HAVE A LAW SCHOOL SO
WE DON'T HAVE A THE PERFECT FEED
FOR FOR SUCH A PILOT PROJECT.
WE HAVE LAW SCHOOLS IN LOS
ANGELES.
BUT IT JUST WOULDN'T BE THE SAME
I SEE ONE OF THE ADVOCATES FROM
SHE LINED CERTAINLY WE WOULD
WORK WITH THEM TO SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO BUT EIGHT THE THE THESE
PILOT PROJECTS.
ARE IMPORTANT BUT I'D LIKE TO
SEE HOW WE EXPAND THEM -- OF
COURSE IT'LL COST MORE MONEY BUT
TO EXPAND INTO OTHER AREAS LIKE
THE INLAND EMPIRE.
ONLY BECAUSE I HAPPENED TO BE
THE ONE SITTING HERE BUT MY
COLLEAGUES WOULD TALK ABOUT AN
ADVOCATE FOR THEIR VERY AREAS AS
WELL.
SO THAT IT IT'S MORE THAN JUST
ONE AREA.
IN THE BAY AREA THAT IT INCLUDES
OTHER AREAS YES AND IF I COULD
SPEAK BRIEFLY TO THAT -- MADAM
CHAIR -- I DON'T AGREE 1100% AND
WHAT'S BEEN PUT FORTH AS A PILOT
FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH I
WILL JUST KNOW IS.
THE JURISDICTION OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO IMMIGRATION COURT IS
AS FAR NORTH AS THE OREGON
BORDER AS FAR SOUTH AS
BAKERSFIELD SO THIS PROPOSAL THE
EXPERTISE WOULD BE COMING OUT OF
THE BAY AREA AND THE SERVICES
WOULD BE IN THAT ENTIRE
GEOGRAPHIC REGION THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TO BUILD CAPACITY --
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE THE OTHER REGIONS WE HAVE
BEEN IN CLOSE CONVERSATIONS --
WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS THE VERY
FEW AND ALSO A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN YOUR IF YOU
THAT THAT WAS YOU SAID THAT YEAH
WE THE ONE YEAH WE HAVE ARE SO
DEDICATED YEAH LIKE EMILIO AND
RUSSELL AND THE OTHERS THERE SO
SO DEDICATED.
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THAT THEY
DO BUT THEY COULD SURE USE SOME
HELP YES AND I THIS.
I TRUST THAT THE MODEL WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD IS ONE THAT
COULD BE EASILY SCALE TO HELP
AND REPLICABLE IN THESE REGIONS --
WE HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH THESE VARIOUS REGIONS --
THERE'S AN ADDENDUM TO THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU'LL NOTE
ACTUALLY HAS A SUMMARY FOR THE
DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THIS KIND
OF URBAN ROLE DIVIDE -- AND AND
THE NEED TO STATE THAT YOU SO
RIGHTLY POINT OUT -- IT'S A
QUESTION OF OF MONEY AND
CAPACITY THIS PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
WRITTEN FOR THE REGION WE KNOW
BEST -- BUT BY ADVOCATE SAID THE
WHAT BEST BUT I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF TENANTS TO IT THAT APPLY
VERY EASILY.
IN OTHER PARTS OF OF THE STATE.
WONDERFUL WELL.
THANK YOU FOR FOR THIS PROPOSAL
I I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN SAYING
THAT THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
NEED WE NEED TO TRAIN.
THE TRAINERS SO THAT WE CAN.
HAVE AS MANY -- AS MANY OF OUR
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DETENTION
REPRESENTED BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
IS THE GREATEST SUCCESS RATE.
IS WHEN YOU ARE REPRESENTED.
AND HAVING THE REPRESENTATIVES
TRAINS PROPERLY TRAINED -- IS.
IT'S NECESSARY SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS.
ARE AT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
ARE AT THIS POINT THEN WE WILL
OPEN UP A PUBLIC COMMENT
SPECIFICALLY ON THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUES. ELEVEN AND TWELVE TWELVE
AND THIRTEEN HELLO IN THIRD.
HELLO MY NICK MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS AND THEN THIS -- HELLO
HELP COVER JUSTICE.
AND I AGREE WITH GOVERNOR ON THE
SHOULD TOIL.
ANY VALUE IS SO IF YOU HAD TELL
YOU MY STORY WILL OF US WERE
CRYING.
BUT I I'M GLAD THE EURO GUN
GOSPER YOU'RE HERE ON THE
PLATFORM.
CAN YOU GUYS ARE DECIDING MY LAI
IN OTHER PEOPLE AND I THINK
WE'RE SO FAR BEHIND IT BECAUSE
WE NEED THIS HELP WHEN I CAME
HERE.
WHEN I WAS SPEAKING YOUR TO KNOW
HOW I'M FIFTY YEARS OLD AND --
YOU MEAN TREATED LIKE CRIMINAL
AND I MEAN LISTEN.
TO MY PRESERVING THIS NOW MY
PRESIDENT I CALL IN FIFTY SIX OR
WHATEVER NUMBER IS HE THAT I'D.
HE DOESN'T KNOW NO REGARDLESS OF
BEING A WOMAN IN HERE NO MA'AM
ALL THE STE THOUGH THIS STUDY
HE'S GOING THROUGH SO REALLY.
I THINK OF A COUNTRY AYE THAT'S
WHAT AROUND FROM MEXICO SO I
THINK I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
EVERYBODY OPENS THE WATERS FOR
ME TO GO RUN TO BACK TO MEXICO.
THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ONE I'M A COMMUNITY LEADER FROM
LOS ANGELES -- AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ISSUE NUMBER.
TWELVE ON IMMIGRATION -- REFUSE
ONE THEN SERVICES PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LIZ GONZALEZ
JEWISH W. COMMUNITY LEADER --
AND I'M SO BORED ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL --
MEANS ARE A LOT OF FOR
IMMIGRATION UP PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY THE NEEDS ALSO I'M NOT
A HELP.
NOT JUST ONLY -- US ARE HELPFUL
WITH HIS PAPERS IT'S A COMMUNITY
INTEGRITY AND COMMON ALTOGETHER
TO SUPPORT MORE OF THIS KIND OF
ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NUMBER AS ONE BABY AND
SERVICES INTO THEIR PERSONAL
EVENT WHAT WE AND I I LOVE NEW
IN.
BUT IT GAVE SAYS THEN IT BUT
IT'S THE END OF THE NIGHT OF THE
LIVING SINGLE ME HONEST BUT OKAY
YOUR SINGLE BIT OF ANY LESS THAN
WHAT WE'RE GONNA SO WE LOOK AT
YOU IN A NICE DAY.
NO CALIFORNIA.
OKAY MISTER MORE THAN WHAT YOU
PUT MUCH ELECTORAL ROLLS
IMMIGRANT THIS.
IN WHICH I YOU HAVE OPPOSED TO
THIS IS THE MOST AND PENDANTS
WHAT I THOUGHT BUT I CAN MOST.
APOLLYON DENNIS'S LIVING
ADVANCING CALL ME IN OF ALL OF
IT.
BUT A COUPLE OF IT MUST
INFORMACIóN WHICH IS THE MOTHER
OF YOUR GLASSES A STEADY GLASSES
BUT A THANK YOU CAN ALSO THROW
SO OPINION WE BUT I THOUGHT IT
DIDN'T MEAN ANYTHING ON THE PUT
IN -- BUT IF WE ADDRESS
IMMIGRANT THIS.
BUT OKAY I MUST FOR WINDOWS BUT
I BUT COULD YOU 90% OFF WE ARE
LEFT OUT OF I KNOW THAT BUT WE
DID YES THE CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
BUT A PLEASE DON'T BUT AGAIN THE
THE IT CAN OKAY ALSO BUT AS IN
ANY ME [inaudible]
NEW MOTORS.
GET OFFICE GOT US YES.
HELLO HEY MY NAME IS VIVIAN
JACOB AND I AM ORIGINAL
IMMIGRATION MANAGER FOR
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE
NORTON CALIFORNIA BASIN TARLAC I
STARTED PROVIDING IMMIGRATION
SERVICES ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO.
AND WE PROVIDE RADIO PERMISSION
SERVICES IN THAT AREA IN FISCAL
YEAR.
EIGHTEEN BI POLAR -- BEATS ONE
OFF THAT THE OJ STUFF BE
COMPLETED ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED
APPLICATION.
SO.
BUT BE COULD BE CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE A GAP PROVIDING IT
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SO THE
PARTISAN LEGAL SERVICES.
WHICH ARE THE MOST CHALLENGING
CAM IMMIGRATION CASES.
AND WE CANNOT THAT'S HIS
EVERYBODY IN THAT AREA SO.
WE ARE USED.
AS I AM AN AGENCY WE ARE A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF I AM ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AND THIRTEEN THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS REGISTER HAMMERS.
AND HI EVERYONE TO SEE IF YOU.
OFFER YOUR TO SUPPORT US WITH
THIS BECAUSE YOU'LL NEED MORE
KNOWLEDGE.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S MORE
NON.
AND THERE'S AREAS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A SWEET TOOTH BRUSH
MORE GROW MORE MOST DURATIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO WHAT IS YOUR NAME.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOCELYN.
MARTINEZ AND I'M FROM FRESNO
[inaudible]
AND I DON'T REALLY NEED TURN
MUNCH UPDATED.
SO.
SORRY SO DO YOU WANT US TO
PROVIDE THE MONEY THAT THEY NEED
SO THEY CAN.
PROVIDE ATTORNEYS.
I WANT YOUR OPINION.
WHEN ASKED THAT LIMóN NUMBER
JULIE SECULARITY BINGO THEY'RE
FRESNO CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST
LIKELY BUT A POOR YET UNETHICAL
MONEY THAT THEY MAKE IT OUT
THERE?
HELLO CAM I AM US UP BUT FROM A
SET UP SEP BUT OTHER THIS A
FORMULA PLEASE IF I'M AT THE
LEFT ME A SOME OTHER PART THAT'S
THE HONEST. FOR PUBLIC TO YOU
AND THE FOCUS HIS.
GLASSES.
WHEN I THOUGHT OF IT HAS BEEN
NUMBER A WITH A THING WHETHER
COULD HAVE NOT CALIFORNIA -- YOU
CAN I AM ALSO UP FOR YOUR OWN
THEY LOG BASE TO SINGLE MEN
DAHLE LETTUCE BUT I USE I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT ARE AMONG THEM.
GRASSROOTS.
HELLO MY NAME.
IS -- I COME FROM LOS ANGELES
AND I'M HERE WITH THE I'M A
LEADER A TEAM LEADER FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
S. T. R. U..
M. I'M HERE TO STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE SHOULD TALK BECAUSE I WORK
IT OFF OR IMMIGRANTS.
COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE EDUCATED
ON THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS
[inaudible]
THEY YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ANA WHERE T<c.cyan> I AM A STAFF</c>
ATTORNEY FOR THE REMOVAL DEFENSE
PROJECT OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS FOUNDATION AND
BAKERSFIELD.
I LIKE TO SAY -- THAT I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE THIRTEEN AND
I AM A DIRECT BENEFICIARY OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN THE BAY
AREA NONPROFIT IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND CENTRAL
VALLEY NONPROFIT.
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS THROUGH THIS
PARTNERSHIP I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
RECEIVE WONDERFUL TRAINING FROM
OUR BAY AREA COLLEAGUES BRING
THAT TRAINING HOME TO DIRECTLY
SERVE BOTH ARE DETAINED IN PHNOM
DETAINED.
POPULATIONS AND KERN COUNTY AS
WELL AS DIRECTLY SERVE AS A
CONDUIT FACILITATING THE
AVAILABILITY OF NONPROFIT
DEPORTATION REMOVAL DEFENSE
SERVICES I LIKE TO SAY THAT
CURRENTLY MYSELF AND MY
SUPERVISOR AMBER TWO OF OUR ARE
THE ONLY TWO NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN ALL OF KERN
COUNTY -- WE WOULD APPRECIATE
YOU CONSIDERING IN GRANTING THIS
PROPOSAL SO THAT WE CAN BUILD
CAPACITY CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM
CONTINUE BRINGING THIS TRAINING
HOME AND CONTINUE FACILITATING
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
RESOURCES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GUY CAN YOU SHOW I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE ONE
CALIFORNIA COALITION WHICH IS
CREATED INTWENTY FOURTEEN TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE CREATION THE
ONE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CATHOLIC
CHARITIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA COB THE CONFERENCES
UNABLE TO BE.
HERE TODAY I'M THE ONE EXPRESS
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE I'M COVERING YOU
SOME SPUR OF THE PROPOSAL TO
ALLOCATE COMBINED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARD
IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE ONE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM HAS PROVEN
ITSELF -- AS ATTESTED ENTRY
MODEL OF IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION
AT THE STATE LEVEL BY MOVING TO
AN ONGOING FUNDING ALLOCATION
CALIFORNIA WOULD PROVIDE THE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES WORK
FORCE WITH THE MUCH NEEDED
STABILITY TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
LEGAL SERVICES AND COUNSEL FOR
RESIDENTS.
I'M AND FOR THAT REASON WE ALSO
SUPPORT I'M ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
I'M IN THE PROPOSED TO CREATE
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANTS IN GEOGRAPHICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGAL SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M CENTER SEE RAM
SANTANA REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AND DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
ONGOING FUNDING FOR SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. FOR THE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM AN ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS
FOR OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PIPELINE TO BRING
MUCH NEEDED RESOURCES. TO OUR
CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING -- I BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION
SERVING IMMIGRANT MIGRANT ROLE
FARMWORKERS WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM TWELVE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
MINISTRATION AND THE DEPARTMENT.
FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND IS A ONE
CALIFORNIA STAKEHOLDER WE
CONTINUE THAT -- MOST.
ROBUST FUNDING THAT'S BEING
PROVIDED IN REGARDS TO ITEM
THIRTEEN WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF INCREASED QUALITY LEGAL
REPRESENTATION FOR REMOVAL
DEFENSE THROUGH HAVING
EXPERIENCED ATTORNEYS THIS IS AN
INCREASE WILL TAKE US A STEP
FURTHER PROVIDING NEEDS THAT ARE
UNMET.
PARTICULAR IN A RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE FARMWORKERS ARE
IMMIGRANTS FACED THREATS OF
ISOLATION FEAR.
AND DEPORTATION AND ALREADY EXT
EXPERIENCED POVERTY SO YOU ADD
ON TOP OF ALL THOSE ISSUES
COMBINED.
THEN WE NEED TO HAVE EXPERIENCE
ATTORNEYS WHO CAN WORK WITH THEM
AND TRAIN GET TRAINED PROVIDE
THE SERVICE ITSELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BECAUSE FOR SUCH AS A CHAIR OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION -- REPRESENT
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ORGANIZATIONS ONE
CALIFORNIA GRANT TEAM WE PROVIDE
AFFIRMATIVE RELIEF AND ALSO
DEPORTATION DEFENSE.
REAL BRIEFLY I WOULD JUST LIKE --
TO THE STATE ONE OF OUR RECENT
CASES WE'RE ABLE TO GET A FATHER
OF A VETERAN -- WHO IS SEEKING A
RE ARE UNIFIED TO THE PROCESS OF
DEPORTATION BECAUSE I SAID AT
THE END OF THEM THOSE CASES
NEVER BE ABLE TO GO FORWARD AND
AND -- HAVE THAT PERSON AND
DEPORTATION FORTUNATELY WE'RE
ABLE TO GET THAT -- THAT
INDIVIDUAL OUT AND THEY JUST
WOULD LIKE -- TO PUT IN AN
ADDITIONAL REQUESTS TO HAVE ANA
ODD ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
DOCTOR KNOWS ARM AS WE SEEN THAT
THROUGH OUR OFFICES -- ARM WE
KNOW A LOT MORE FOLKS ARE NOT
ABLE TO SO FOR DOCTOR FEES AND
IT WE BELIEVE IT'S
RESPONSIBILITY THE STATE TURN
OUR ENSURE THAT THAT WE TAKE ON
THAT FEES ONCE AGAIN BECAUSE WE
DID HAVE THAT.
MONEY INITIALLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY ANGER IN A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE TWELVE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ON GOING FUNDING FOR THE ONE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
HAVE AN ATTORNEY BY YOUR SIDE AT
THESE CRITICAL MOMENTS THAT
COULD BE LIFE CHANGING FOR YOUR
FAMILY COMMUNITY.
ARE THEY ARE MOST IMPORTANT
SPEAK THINK THE STATE FOR THEIR
INVESTMENT SO FAR AND I'M GOING
FUNDING WILL HELP ENSURE THE
LONG STANDING SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELL I WANNA START THIS ME
NUMBER ASSIGNMENT.
MUCH OF THE REST OF THE AMPLE IS
THE IGGY BUT I'VE GONE BUT THE
TO ME STUDY.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME'S ALMA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'M HERE
TO SHARE MY STORY.
SO MY LOOK WHAT THE NINOS EVEN
WHEN I'VE GONE THOUGH THAT THE
WRITING.
I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR FOUR AND I
LIVE IN TULARE COUNTY YES DANIEL
AND THEN IT'LL ONE THIS TIME
ABOUT A SON OF A POINT THAT I
LEARNED WAS HOW MAY WOMEN.
THIS YEAR IN JANUARY WHEN I WAS
PREGNANT WITH MY DAUGHTER.
YES BOTH OF WHAT THE NEW OPENING
MADE ASSUME MY HUSBAND WAS
DETAINED BY YOU IT BY
IMMIGRATION. FOR MENTAL IF YOU
SEE THEM MAYBE IT UP AND MOSTLY
FOR YOU SEE.
IT WAS A DIFFICULT MOMENT IN MY
LIFE THE MOST DIFFICULT.
SO LOCAL NEWS NINOS YEAH BUT US
OTHER THAN -- MISSUS. TWO WOULD
COME OVER TO MY PUTTING GOOD
THAT I DO WITH A GUN.
BUT I CAN MEET BOTH WILL KNOW
FOR THE PORTABLE.
I WAS ALONE WITH MY KIDS AND
NINE MONTHS PREGNANT I HAD TO
LOOK FOR HELP SO THAT MY HUSBAND
WOULD NOT BE DEPORTED CONTACT
THEM WHICH IS A MUSCLE IN HIS US
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DIED YES AND
CONSULADO MEXICANO.
YOU DON'T RECALL TOOK UP WITH
THAT IT GIVE A FOR THEM AND I
HAVE A BURNING GONNA BLOW FOR
SEMICON FROM THOUGHT A PRESENT
THAT'S ONLY GOT BUT I'M IS POST.
I CONTACTED MANY ORGANIZATIONS
MANY COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS THE
MEXICAN CONSULATE AND ANY
RESOURCES OUT THERE BUT I
COULDN'T FIND ANY.
THAT COULD PROVIDE ME WITH THE
CONSOLE OR RIDLEY WILL
REPRESENTATION FOR MY SPOUSE.
MISS BOTH OF TO WHAT THE NEEDLE
PORTABLES MISSUS YOU KNOW
BLESSED THAT GOD MAY OPEN UNLESS
YOU MUST AYE.
MY HUSBAND WAS DETAINED FOR TWO
MONTHS AND HE WASN'T ABLE TO BE
WITH ME WHEN OUR DAUGHTER WAS
BORN.
MISS BOTH OF THEM I HAD DIMPLE
COMPLET DON'T BUT A MONTH AND
THAT MOST. TO BUT ALSO TO THE
POOR THEN.
I AM BUT A POOR YOUNG AND
RESTLESS YOUNG EITHER A COMMON
YET CAN ALSO YOU LOW ACCORDED
GONE OUT AND DONE CALL ME THAT'S
IN WITH THOSE GUYS THOSE.
WITH THE MOMENTUM BUT A BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT OTHER PRETTY
WELL DON'T YOU ENOUGH YES A BUT
I CAN MISS BUSHELS IDEA.
MY HUSBAND WORKED FULL TIME TO
SUPPORT US I HAD TO WORK TO TRY
AND HOW TO FIND THE SUPPORT IN
MY CHURCH MY COMMUNITY SO THAT
THEY COULD COVER MY RENT MY FOOD
AND ULTIMATELY PAY A PRIVATE
ATTORNEY AND PAY A BONTA THAT MY
HUSBAND CAN GET OUT.
YOU KNOW PUT UP WHAT IS THAT YOU
THEN ALSO COME WILL GET US OVER
TO BE EITHER ISN'T MOMENT BUT
THEN IF HE SAID.
WITHOUT THAT HELP I DON'T KNOW
HOW I WOULD HAVE SURVIVED THAT
DIFFICULT MOMENT.
I'M GONNA STUFF I MEAN LOOK AT
US IS AT THE ASSIST ONLY THAN
THIS THE MOMENT THOUGH LOS
EFECTOS A MOTION UNLESS MOST
AFRICAN GET ADMIN THING.
EVEN THOUGH MY FAMILY HAS
REUNITED AT THIS MOMENT THE
EMOTIONAL EFFECT ON A FLICKS
THIS EVERY DAY.
MS BUT DOES HE GET BUT I'M GOING
GONZALEZ FOR THE BUT THAT'S YOUR
OWN.
MISSY CLASS IS THAT MEANT THAT
UP YET IT ON MY YOUR CALL MAYBE
GOVERNMENTAL BUT UNTIL LIKE THAT
BUT IF YOU DON'T.
COMMERCIAL THE LITTLE GET BUSTLE
MY SPOUSE CONTINUES TO FIGHT HIS
DEPORTATION MY DAUGHTERS ARE IN
THERAPY AND THE OLDEST HAS
MEDICATION FOR ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION AS A RESULT OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
IS THAT YOUR CAMPAñA COMBAT THE
LIST EXPERIENCE.
ON GUYS MOVED MORE BUT STILL NOT
IN WITH IF YOU SEEN BUT GIMME
THE SOME OF THAT AND THIS
GETTING GOING OFF I MEAN THAT
THING I GET BY CENTER BLOOM IS
MORE.
I'M HERE TO SHARE MY STORY
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH IT'S VERY
PERSONAL AND VERY DIFFICULT.
IT'S MY WISH THAT NO OTHER
FAMILY HAVE TO SUFFER WHAT I
WENT THROUGH.
GET COMO MINIMAL BUT NOTHING OWN
AMERICANS HAVE THIS SOMEONE AND
I THINK ON THAT COULD LEAD INTO
CONEY THAT.
BUT I DO THAT LIKE I'LL EUROPE
BUT IT IS THE PRESENT THAT'S
YOUR OWN UP WE ALL
ESPECíFICAMENTE ON MY LOTUS BUT
I CS SO THAT WHEN THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY IN THIS MATTER.
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY CAN GO
FOR LEGAL REPRESENTATION AND GET
SOME HELP I STRONGLY URGE THE
SUPPORT OF LINE ITEM.
THIRTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD US YES.
BEFORE WE TAKE THE NEXT COMMENT.
AS I MENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOGIN AGAIN SALAS WAS GOING TO
BE HERE.
AND I'D LIKE TO TAKE HER
TESTIMONY IF I MAY.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AND THANK YOU
AT FOR HAVING ME AT THIS LATE
HOUR I'M SORRY WAS LATE.
I I'M SPEAKING -- TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ON IMMIGRATION RAPID
RESPONSE.
ON BEFORE I HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LET YOU KNOW
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I'M HERE TO
REQUEST AT THE STATE BUDGET
INCLUDE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION BE ON THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S PROPOSED TWENTY
MILLION. FOR IMMIGRATION RAPID
RESPONSE THE DIGITAL FUNDING
WILL SUPPLEMENT NECESSARY
MEDICAL SERVICES IN PERSON ALL
THE PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
PROVIDING DALY MEDICAL SCREEN
FOR ARRIVING MIGRANTS AND ASYLUM
SEEKERS.
WHILE THIS.
SHELTER IS IN SAN DIEGO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS A
STATE STATEWIDE ISSUE IT IS THE
FIRST SPOT FOR THE MIGRANTS TO
GET HEALTH CARE NO MATTER WHERE
THEY'RE GOING AND MOST OF THEM
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM ARE NOT
STAYING IN SAN DIEGO.
SO IT AFFECTS OUR ENTIRE STATE
THE JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES OF
SAN DIEGO PROVIDES A VARIETY OF
SERVICES THROUGH THE SAN DIEGO
RAPID RESPONSE NETWORK INCLUDING
SHELTER OPERATIONS.
A CRITICAL COMPONENT A SHELTER
OPERATIONS INCLUDE HEALTHCARE
SERVICES THAT ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THESE ASYLUM SEEKING FAMILIES
THE MEDIA NEEDS HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OUR CENTRAL CORE
ELEMENT OF THE SHELTER OPERATION.
FAMILIES HAVE TRAVELED THOUSANDS
OF MILES IN OUR NEED A BASIC
HEALTH SERVICES TO REMAIN SAFE
IN THE SHELTER AND WHEN THEY'RE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO SUPPORT
THESE EFFORTS BY PROVIDING
MEDICAL PERSONNEL AND CONTRACTED
AGENTS TO CONDUCT MEDICAL STRICT
GREENS AN INTAKE.
HOWEVER THE COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE
ANY BUDGET AUTHORITY TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES PAST JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE
LOSS OF THOSE SERVICES WILL HAVE
A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON THE
HEALTH OF ARRIVING MIGRANTS AND
AS A RESULT ON THE HEALTH OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THE LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
RECOGNIZES NEED FOR SHELTER TO
CONTINUE OPERATING CRITICAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR MY GRANTS
FOR THIS REASON.
IN WORKING WITH JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICES WE KNOW THAT THEY WILL
NEED AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE COSTS OF
THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
OF THAT SHELTER -- IN ADDITION
TO THE GOVERNOR NUISANCE
PROPOSED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
I ASK THIS RESPECTFULLY AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ON IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
YOU HAVE BEEN WITHOUT A DOUBT
ONE OF THE CHAMPIONS ON THIS
ISSUE.
MAKING SURE THAT -- CHANGES WERE
MADE. ONE WE KNEW THAT THERE WAS
SUCH A GREAT NEED AND ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT YOU TOOK A
GROUP OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
MEMBERS. TO SEE FIRSTHAND
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
THE SHELTERS AND SAN DIEGO LIKE
FOR THAT I THANK YOU SO THANK
YOU.
FOR PRESENTING THIS TODAY YEP.
NOW WE WILL CONTINUE WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT.
HI MY NAME'S ASHLEY HERRINGTON
WITH JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF
SAN DIEGO THE CURRENT MIGRATION
HIGHER OPERATOR YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- TO DESPITE THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY OUR
SHELTER HAS BEEN RECEIVING MORE
INDIVIDUALS THAN EVER -- WE'VE
HAD TO USE OVERFLOW SHELTERS AND
AS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN MENTIONS
THE COUNTY WILL STOP PROVIDING
HEALTH SERVICES WHICH RECORD OR
OPERATION BEGINNING JULY -- ONE
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
STATE COME IN TO PROVIDE THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ENSURE
CONTINUITY BETWEEN JUNE AND JULY
OUR ONLY GOAL IS THAT THE
MIGRANT FAMILIES RELEASED BY
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES.
ARE SAFE AT OUR SHELTER AND GET
EFFICIENTLY ON TO WHERE THEY
NEED TO GO OVERSEAS AND TING UP
ON THE STREETS OF SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
AND ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT OUR
SHELTERS THE ONLY SHELTER FOR
FAMILY MIGRANTS RELEASED BY
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES IN
CALIFORNIA REAR SEE FOLKS FROM
NOT ONLY SAN DIEGO BUT IMPERIAL
COUNTIES.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY APPRECIATIVE OF THIS
BODY AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR THEIR
RESPONSIVENESS AND COLLABORATION
AND WE REQUEST THAT THE FUNDING
GO THROUGH DSS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MAHDI SALAS
SANCHEZ I AM -- NATIVE FROM
DYING TO THE CALIFORNIA FROM
TULARE COUNTY -- I ALSO WORK FOR
THE ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY IN THE FRESNO
OFFICE -- AND ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER --
THIRTEEN AS SOMEONE WHO WORKS IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY A MAJORITY IN
THE TIME OF THE THREE COUNTIES
AT WORK AND TULARE COUNTY FRESNO
COUNTY AND KINGS COUNTY.
I SEE FIRSTHAND THE LACK OF
LEGAL RESOURCES OF ALL KINDS AND
OUR REGION -- AND THIS PROPOSAL
NUMBER ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN IS A MUCH NEEDED FIRST
STEP TO ENSURE THAT OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY -- HAS
ACCESS TO QUALITY LEGAL SERVICES
IN OUR AREAS -- GIVEN YOU KNOW
HOW INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT THESE
CRITICAL MOMENTS ARE IN THEIR IN
THEIR LIVES THEY NEED IN A
DIRECT.
A PATH TO TO QUALITY GOOD
QUALITY LEGAL SERVICES -- SO
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I DEAL
WITH ON A WEEKLY BASIS WITH MY
WORK -- AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SO THAT IS WHY I LIKE WE'RE JUST
INCREDIBLY STRONG OF IT
INCREDIBLY.
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MADELEINE COOPER ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE TWELVE
SPECIFICALLY THAT IMMIGRATION
RAPID RESPONSE PROGRAM IN THE
FUNDING GOING OUT TO THIS
WONDERFUL POPULATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS CHRIS PUTTING BYNUM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
CHANGE LAWYERS.
I'M HERE TO GIVE US SUPPORT FOR
LINE ITEM THIRTEEN IN THE RIGHT
UP WERE REFERRED TO AS THE
COORDINATING AGENCY -- THAT
AGENCIES CALIFORNIA CHANGE
LAWYERS ARE WORK IS TO SUPPORT
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL CHANGE MAKERS
AND WE CALL THEM CHANGE LAWYERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT A STATE IS THE
VERSUS CALIFORNIA WHICH IS NOW
60% OF PEOPLE OF COLOR SHOULD
HAVE A LEGAL SYSTEM AS DIVERSE
AS THE POPULATION.
BUT AS YOU KNOW THE THE LAWYER
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA IS ONLY
22% PEOPLE OF COLOR SO THERE'S A
DRASTIC UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
ATTORNEYS OF COLOR IN THE
PROFESSION.
WHO ARE BEST EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES THAT ARE DESCRIBED
IN THE FELLOWSHIP?
WE SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP
BECAUSE WHEN WE BELIEVE THAT
WHEN LAWYERS COME FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO BEST SERVE THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND THE COMMUNITIES NEEDS
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS TRUE
BECAUSE FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM EXACTLY LIKE
THE ONE THAT'S PRETTY DESCRIBED.
IN THE PROPOSAL AND WE HAVE A
STRONG TRACK RECORD OF MATCHING
UP COMMUNITY LAWYERS WHO WANT TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITY WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT.
THEY WENT TO LAW SCHOOL IN THE
FIRST PLACE TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT.
WE'VE PLACE LEGAL FELLOWS --
INCLUDING IMMIGRATION LEGAL
FELLOWS AT THE U. S. MEXICO
BORDER AS WELL AS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
AND WE ARE WELL POSITIONED TO
CONTINUE TO SOURCE THE BEST AND
MOST TALENTED DIVERSE YOUNG
LAWYERS TO BE ABLE TO SERVICE
PROGRAM AND WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS MATT ON
THE SANDALS AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
PRESENTATION ATTORNEY AT KIND OR
KIDS IN NEED OF DEFENSE AT THE
FRESNO SATELLITE OFFICE.
I'M ALSO STEERING COMMITTEE
MEMBER FOR THE FRESNO COUNTY
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR LINE ITEM.
THIRTEEN IN MY ROLE THAT KIND A
SEE THE HIGH DEMAND FOR LEGAL
SERVICES KIND IS AN EXPERT AT
REPRESENTING UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN.
HOWEVER WE OFTEN GET REFERRALS
FROM THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
WHO WE ARE UNABLE TO SERVE.
I ALSO SEE THE INSTABILITY THAT
THE ADULT CARETAKERS WHO ARE IN
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS THAT
NEGATIVELY AFFECTS THE CLIENTS
THAT WE SERVE.
THE FRESNO COUNTY LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND HAS SECURED PRIVATE FUNDING
TO PROVIDE REMOVAL DEFENSE BUT
WE HAVE NO NONPROFIT ATTORNEY
WITH A LICENSED IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY TO PLACE CASES WITH.
THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO FIX THIS
TRAIN ATTORNEYS AND PROVIDE
SERVICES IN RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHAIRS ARE
PLENTIFUL MARTINEZ ON THE
EXPECTED DIRECTOR OF CENTRAL
VALLEY IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
COLLABORATIVE CIVIC.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
FRESNO COUNTY WITH A FENCE FUND
COMMITTEE THAT.
ARE JUST WHICH IS MUCH RIGHT NOW.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT BOTH ITEMS
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN BUT A
PARTICULAR RESPECT TO ITEM.
THIRTEEN I CALL UPON YOU TO
REALLY SUPPORT THIS AT THIS
PROCESS OF ENHANCING TO
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY -- IN THE REGION
THERE ARE SOME MY HUNDRED
THOUSAND IMMIGRANTS AND WILL
BEGIN WHEN WE GOT TO WORK IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN IN THAT REGION THERE
WERE ONLY EIGHT OR NINE I CREDIT
THE REPRESENTATIVES -- BUT
CAPACITY HAS IMPROVED SINCE THEN
THEY'RE NOT ABOUT THIRTY OR
FORTY A GREAT THE REPS.
BUT HIS MOTHER DOES NOT SURE
RIGHT NOW ONE OF THE MAJOR ARE
PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE IN THE
CENTER BY THE STILL TODAY.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE IMPROVE THE
CAPACITY TO HELP PEOPLE WITH
DOCTOR WITH NATURAL SESSION.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
ASSIST PEOPLE WITH LEGAL DEFENSE.
ARE WE JUST HEARD A VERY
IMPORTANT CASE OF A PERSONAL
STORY THAT WAS MENTIONED HERE.
BUT WE HEAR THOSE STORIES ALL
THE TIME WE ORGANIZE HUNDREDS OF
WORKSHOPS -- SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN LAST YEAR ALONE HUNTER
AND SEVEN WORKSHOPS IN THE
REGION.
IN COLLABORATION WITH ANY
PARTNERS AND IN THOSE WITH
WORKSHOPS WE HAVE PEOPLE COMING
IN SICK IN THAT TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE WE CANNOT A SYSTEM.
THAT IS THE BOTTOM LINE AND WITH
THIS OUR PIPELINE PROJECT HAS
BEEN CREATED WE'RE DEVELOPING IS
A VERY STRONG PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN.
THE LOW CAPACITY ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
STOCK A PATH OF EXISTING IN THE
BAY AREA SO THAT TYPE OF
PARTNERSHIP THAT IS BEING.
DEVELOPING THIS PROJECT IS
NECESSARY WE NEED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ENERGY TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GIVE ME MY NAME'S ALLISON
DAVENPORT AND I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER I'M BASED IN MERCED
COUNTY WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED -- I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF PROVIDING TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO A NUMBER
OF OUTSTANDING LEGAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
AND SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT --
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE I'VE SEEN
WITH MY OWN EYES THE IMPACT THE
ONE CALIFORNIA FUNDING HAS HAD
ON OUR REGION -- BUT WE ALSO
FACE A CRITICAL GAP IN REMOVAL
DEFENSE -- SERVICES.
I CAN COUNT ON ONE HAND THAT'S
FIVE FINGERS THE NUMBER OF
ATTORNEYS WHO PROVIDE FREE
REMOVAL DEFENSE SERVICES TO
IMMIGRANTS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
REGION FROM STOCKTON TO
BAKERSFIELD.
THAT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE --
THE THE FELLOWS PROPOSAL REALLY
PROVIDES THE STRUCTURE AND THE
TARGETED INVESTMENT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO MAKE THAT QUALITATIVE
SHIP.
FROM PROVIDING -- ADMINISTRATIVE
KIND OF AFFIRMATIVE CASE
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDING FULL
SCOPE SERVICES TO OUR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IN THE REGION.
THE ATTACKS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES LEAVE THE
COMMUNITIES VULNERABLE -- IN A
COUPLE OF WAYS ESPECIALLY IN OUR
UNDERSERVED REGIONS THEY'RE
VULNERABLE NOT ONLY TO
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO
TO IMMIGRATION FRAUD WHICH IS
VERY PREVALENT IN OUR IN OUR
REGION.
BECAUSE OF THE THE VACUUM OF
LEGAL SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE -- THE FELLOWS PROJECT
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN REALLY
ADDRESSES UP BOTH THE IMMEDIATE
NEEDS OF IMMIGRANT FAMILIES FOR
LEGAL REPRESENTATION BUT ALSO
INVEST IN THE LONG TERM CAPACITY
OF OUR REGION AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING OTHER DOWN ARE FROM
THE CENTRAL BECAUSE THEY LIVE
WORK AND ADVOCATE FOR THE
CENTRAL COAST -- JUSTIN MONTEREY
COUNTY THERE'S AROUND EIGHTY
NINE THOUSAND FAMILIES WHO HAVE
MAKE STATUS -- BY GET WE HAVE
LIKE AROUND THREE ATTORNEYS WHO
DO REMOVAL DEFENSE -- AND WE
ALSO GROW AROUND EIGHTY SIX
DIFFERENT CROPS -- SO IF WE'RE
ABLE TO TAKE FROM OUR FAMILIES
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GIVE TO OUR
FAMILIES A CONSULTATION -- SO
TODAY WHEN YOU'RE ENJOYING YOUR
DINNER AT NIGHT AND EVERY DAY
THAT YOU ENJOY YOUR DINNER OR
WHEN YOU COME IN STATE.
IN MARIN COUNTY FOR VACATIONS I
THINK THAT ALL THOSE IMMIGRANTS
ARE THE ONES ARE GIVING AND
MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO EAT.
AND MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO
HAVE A COMMUNICATION SO WE
SHOULD MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THEM
TO HAVE LEGAL AID AND BE
REPRESENTED.
AND STAY WITH THEIR FAMILIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS LEE SAID
OF THE BIGGEST AND I'M HERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RULE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE I WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CRIME.
VICTIMS OF CRIME OFFICE SO I
THEY PROVIDE ONLY FIVE OF US ORG
STATED IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WE
PROVIDE RULED AND RULED LEGAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND THAT'S WHY SUPPORT ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTEEN BECAUSE AS A
LITTLE CURRENT LAW.
LAW GRADUATE I DO SEE THE IMPACT
OF AS BEING A ROLE COMMUNITIES
AND AND IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO HAVE
JUST FIVE IN CALIFORNIA BUSCA
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO WE
DO NEED MORE SERVICES TO SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH AVAIL AND I
WORK FOR THE NAY FROM WORKERS
FOUNDATION BUT TODAY I'M HERE AS
A COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO'S SEEN --
FOLKS FILL OUT YOU KNOW TWENTY
THIRTY PAGE APPLICATIONS FOR
PUBLIC BENEFITS WHO DON'T HAVE
RESOURCES IN TERMS OF
IMMIGRATION AND WHO SEE FAMILIES
EVERY WEEK COULD COME INTO OUR
OFFICE.
AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE --
LEGAL DEFENSE FOR FAMILIES SO I
YOUR USE THAT -- YOU KNOW YOU
SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AND
THE REST OF THE ITEMS IN TERMS
OF IMMIGRATION BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST EVEN NOT ENOUGH WORK FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES MOST OF US HERE
AND SERVICE PROVIDERS DON'T SEE
IT BUT WE WERE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE DIFFERENT HATS.
AND ARE VOLUNTEERING MANY OF THE
TIMES TO MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE.
TO SUCCEED OR EVEN NOT BE
DEPORTED -- AND WE DO NOT HAVE --
WE DO NOT HAVE THE SUPPORT FOR
FEDERALLY BUT WE NEED TO HAVE IT
FROM OUR STATE.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HOW MEDIA IS
DUMPING ON THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RAPID RESPONSE AND IMMIGRANT
DEFENSE NETWORK.
I'M HOUSE OF THE BAR ASSOCIATION
SAN FRANCISCO -- OVER THE LAST
YEAR WE'VE BEEN RESPONDING TO
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
THROUGHOUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
NO ONE REMIND THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT FAMILY
SEPARATION IS NOT ONLY OCCURRING
AT THE BORDER BUT IT HAPPENS
EVERY DAY IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
I SING FORSMAN IS FAMILY
SEPARATION AND FOR THOSE OF US
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WE STAND
IT WE STAYED IN UNITY WITH ONE
ANOTHER IF YOU'VE NOTICED THIS
AND THIS PROPOSED THAT WE PUT
FORWARD.
VERY INTENTIONAL THE FOLKS.
IN LINE TODAY TO GIVE TESTIMONY
OR STANDING TOGETHER IN
SOLIDARITY IN COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE BAY AREA CENTRAL
VALLEY TO OPPOSE THESE POLICIES.
AND THIS INTENTIONALITY IS GOING
TO CONTINUE AND I THINK THE
PROPOSAL'S VERY VIABLE BECAUSE
OF THIS INTENTIONALITY.
POISED FOR SUCCESS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS MARIA
MARTINEZ I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN I WORK AT
THE JUSTICE AND NEVER CITY
CENTER WHERE I HELP COLLECT
INFORMATION OF ONE REPRESENTED
INDIVIDUALS.
SERVE THAT THE IMMIGRATION CORPS
AND DETENTION FACILITIES TO
UNDERSTAND -- WHERE ARE THE MOST
AFFECTED IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES --
AND THESE COMMUNITIES ARE MAINLY
IN RURAL AREAS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THE CENTRAL COAST.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WOULD ALSO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- AND THE
FIGURES THAT WE PRESENTED IN THE
PROPOSAL ALSO REPRESENT THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT -- IT INCLUDES THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE -- LONG TERM
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IT INCLUDES ASYLUM SEEKERS WHO
HAVE FLED THEIR COUNTRIES TO SEE
PROTECTION PROTECTION IN THIS
COUNTRY AND ARE DETAINING
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT MAINLY INCLUDES -- THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
FIGHT THEIR DEPORTATION CASES
WITH VERY LITTLE LIMITED LEGAL
ASSISTANCE OR NO LEGAL
REPRESENTATION AT ALL SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS.
OUT FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM IS GOING
TO ENSURE TO PROCESS -- FOR THE
PEOPLE THEY NEED TO THE MOST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS CAROL
CON I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL DEFENSE PROGRAM
AT THE JUSTICE AND DIVERSITY
CENTER AT THE BAR ASSOCIATION
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION
STRONG CONSIDERATION OF ISSUE
THIRTEEN ON THE AGENDA.
OF THE GDC ADMINISTERS THE
ATTORNEY OF THE DAY PROGRAM IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO IMMIGRATION
COURT AND HAS DONE SO FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO ENOUGH ABOUT
THE LEVEL THE RAFT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON REPRESENTED IN THAT COURT.
FOR WHOM THE ATTORNEY OF THE DAY
PROGRAM MAY BE THE ONLY A
TURNING THE EVER SPEAK.
TO I THINK THIS PROPOSAL STANDS
AS THE KEY INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR IMMIGRATION AND LEGAL SYSTEM.
GENERALLY SPEAKING AND WITHOUT
IT -- WE ONLY WILL FARE WORSE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES -- WHEN?
UP WHEN WHEN IMMIGRANTS HAVE
REPRESENTATION THE OUTCOMES IN
OUR ENHANCED AND THE SECURITY
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF COMMUNITIES
AS WELL.
I I THANK YOU FOR THE MOMENT TO
TO SAY THIS AND AND HOPE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IN A STATUS MY NUMBER IS THE AND
A LOT OF GAS YOUR TO HAVE A
WHOLE BUT A CLEAR LINK US.
BUT I WENT TO THE LOO.
YES THERE BINGO THERE IS A
FRESNO CALIFORNIA HE GET ALL OF
IT SU STATUS BUT IN A BILL THAT
IN THE MIDDLE BUT I MUST ECONOMY
THAT BUT I MUST HAVE. WON
IMMIGRANT THIS IT BACK AND I GOT
HIM THIS ABOUT [inaudible]
ABOUT US.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ARE NAY BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT ITEM THIRTEEN WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE CENTER VALLEY
NEEDS MORE RESOURCES AND WE
AGREE THAT THERE COULD BE MORE
RESOURCES.
ACROSS THE STATE -- WERE ALSO
HERE ON ITEM TWELVE WE THINK
IT'S A GREAT THING THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TO MAKE THE
FUNDING FOR ONE CALIFORNIA ON
GOING.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT I JUST
WANNA POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE
MANY MEMBERS ARE TRAVEL ACROSS
THE STATE PEOPLE FROM LA FOR
FRESNO FROM ALL OVER.
MET SOME OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY
VOLUNTEER A VOLUNTARY THE PAIN
TO UNION BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
UNION THE FIGHT FOR THEM TO
FIGHT FOR THEIR RIGHTS.
AND THEIR HERE ASKING FOR FOR
FOR MORE MONEY -- IN ADDITION TO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED FOR
ONE CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY SEE
THE NEED IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THEY'RE ASKING FOR THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS A LET
ME AND THE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
ACTING ATTORNEY AT CENTER LET
OUT OF THE LAST TIME WE ARE THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF REMOVAL
DEFENSE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDE SERVICES TO BOTH
DETAINED AND NON DETAINED
INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THE IMPACT THAT
IT HAS HAD ON OUR WORK TO HAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BE IN SUCH A SUPPORTER OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR IMMIGRANTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS.
AND CLEARLY I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF TWELVE AND THIRTEEN THAT
BEING ABLE TO WALK INTO A
DETENTION CENTER OR INTO A ROOM
AND SAY WE'RE HERE WE HAVE
LAWYERS FOR YOU AND IT'S THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAS
HELPED MAKE THIS POSSIBLE.
IT'S A GOVERNMENT ENTITY IN THIS
CURRENT CLIMATE WHEN.
OUR COMMUNITIES FEEL SO UNDER
ATTACK BUT TO SAY YOUR STATE IS
HERE WITH YOU -- HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE MOST FOR FILLING UP PARTS OF
A I AM VERY FORTUNATE HOWEVER
FOR FAILING CAREER AND THE WORK
THAT I DO.
HOWEVER THERE IS A CRITICAL GAP.
IN THE SERVICES IN THE RURAL
AREA AND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IN PARTICULAR.
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO MEET THAT
NEED WITHOUT CREATING A PIPELINE
PROGRAM THAT IS GOING TO PLAY
ATTORNEYS BACK IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT IS A REALITY THAT IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAVE ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS
REGARDLESS OF YOUR IMMIGRATION
STATUS SO I URGE YOU TO HELP
MAKE THAT A REALITY WITH US AND
SUPPORT -- BOTH TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS HANNAH
CLOUDY ACCOUNTS.
SORRY.
I'M A MEMBER OF FAST SEIU LOCAL --
TWENTY FIFTEEN A NURSING HOME OR
CARE FROM YOU A COUNTY.
AND HOW MANY ME GROUND MYSELF.
AS WE ALL NOW -- IMMIGRANTS ARE
UNDER ATTACK BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
AB REGARDLESS OUR OUR CD STANDS
SHAPE OR IMMIGRATION STATUS WE
MAKE CALIFORNIA PERSON WE ALL DO.
WE ARE CALIFORNIA WORKERS WILL
LEAVE HERE WE PAY TAXES DO BUT
WE ARE TOO AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND OR ACCESS TO
INFORMATION TO LET OUR VOICES.
BE HEARD.
SO WITH THAT.
THE PEOPLE WE NEED -- ACCURATE
INFORMATION FROM TRUSTED
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FOR HELP IN SERVICES LIKE
KNOW YOUR RIGHTS THAT CASS
CITIZENSHIP STATUS LEGAL AUSSIE
STANDS OUT -- TRAINING -- SO THE
SERVICES I VITAL FOR THE
STRENGTH IN PROSPERITY OUR OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE OFTEN DON'T SAY ANYTHING
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
GO TO AWARE TO A FREIGHT.
WE GIVE WE HAVE TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL WE'RE AFRAID TO GO AND
GIVE OUR OUR INFORMATION BECAUSE
THEN WE THINK.
WE DON'T OUT WE DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING MAYBE THEY'RE GONNA
TURN AS IN.
WHY WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING BUT
THEN ALSO WE'RE AFRAID OF GOING
TO THE -- TO THE POLICE OR
ANYTHING. FOR FOR THAT SO WELL --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THE IS -- FUNDING.
THEY HAVE A GOOD EVENING BYE BYE.
HELLO WHEN I STARTED THIS
MINIMALIST ON I'M HE DAWSON DOES
HANDLE TO GET GUEST ALSO NEEDLES.
BEING TAKEN ON PROPOSED IT THE
WAY THAT WAS ONE OF THEM IS WHAT
I'M SEEING US.
WHEN I STUDY YEAH THIS GOT
RATHER THAN LARA THIRTY CM BUT
WHEN SAN?
BUT ALL IS THE KEY.
NO BUT I'LL SETTLE NOT GATTACA
COMMON WHICH IS IN GET ON THIS
SCENE A PARTICULAR NEED.
KETTLE I DO THAT.
GET ALL MY HEART ARE NOT BE THAT
A MUCHAS PERSONAS YOU'LL USE A
THIN AND APART FROM THE THAT ALL
YOU SPACE THE AND AND IS THAT
CAPACITY THAT THEY PRETTY DATA
BE TO ME NOT.
HAPPEN TO SEE ME GET ON THIS GET
IN ANY STORE YES THAT IS THIS
BUT I MANY LACKEY A COME BE I
DON'T HAVE EITHER YEAH COME
BUSINESS PROPENSITY THAT.
INDIVIDUAL IS BE THOSE THAT IS
BECAUSE THEY SAT Là BOSSES THEY
MORE TO SEE ME GET ON THIS THEY
MORE TOOK A MONEY THAT BINGLEY
LADDIE OF THE W. HIDES.
IN A LOT OF THE LESS THEY LOST
TIME PLEASE YOU MORE TIME TO SEE
THAT BUT ALL USE THIS PLAN
PURPOSE AND THOUGHT IN THE
TUNNEL SO TRUST.
PEOPLE THAT KNOWS THAT MOST WILL
NOT KILEY BAD THEY BE THAT BIG
NOT BUT APPLE THOSE.
IT ALSO MUST SAID SO MONALS
YESSICA MOST THERE'S BEEN AN
FROM MEDIA YESSICA MOST THERE'S
BEEN ANY COST NO SALT ASSEMBLY
AND MRS HEAT THAT MOST BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT A PERCENT THEN WHICH
LOWER.
BUT RATHER THAN A LOT OF THOSE
IN THE NINETY S. S. YES.
WHEN INSTEAD OF THIS MAY NUMBER
HERE BUT ARAMBULA HAVING WITH A?
NEVER DOES NOT.
AND PLACE JOKED OFTEN CUMPLE SO
YOU MADE ON DAY.
THE BILL UP FOR YOUNGER Là.
BUT I'LL PLAY A LITTLE BIT IN A
LOT.
MET BUT WHEN THE RULES OF THE
LONG AS THEY SAID EVERYTHING IS
THERE SO BY THE THAT IS THE WITH
THEM WITH IT IS TAKE A AND MR
BUT ON ALL DAY YOU'RE GONNA.
WILL BE WHAT I WILL LOOK IT UP
US ALL UP WHEN NOBODY HAD THE
LAND OKAY AND ONE UP BUT IT WAS
ON THE ME TO SOMEBODY ON OF THE
THE EVENING ON THE SAFETY HOST
OF THIS WEAPON DOES PLACE.
REPUBLICANS BRING ANYBODY WITH
US YES YES YES.
WE WENT A STATUS MY NUMBER IS
LIKE IT'S BEEN NO SUCH.
THING WITH THEM IN THE A LIST.
WHICH IS A IN A STYLE WHICH IS
AN ASSIST FROM MEDIA SAID THE
LOWER LEVELS IN AND DAY MARK.
I'M NOT A PROTEST YOUNG COMES TO
JANICE WHICH OTHER.
CAMPUSES THE SYSTEM THE STEP IN
THE PUBLIC IT CONCEDED IT.
IS NOT YOU THAT CARELESS THE
MOST BILLION NOT.
BUT I CAN DISSEMINATE UP WITH
ALMOST ENDED WHEN I'M A QUARTER
A STATE VISA BUT HONEST US I
MEAN YES IT BUT I MISTER JESSE
THAT DOES THAT ARE COMMON EITHER.
YES YES YES YES.
HI EVERYONE I'M BY RIP INTO I'M
AN ATTORNEY AT CENTER LIKE I
THAT I LASSEN ALSO AN IMMIGRANT
I GREW UP HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUES TWELVE AND THIRTEEN BUT
SPECIFICALLY WITH.
THIRTEEN PRIOR TO MY ROLE AT
CENTRE LET GOD I WAS A LEGAL LAW
FELLOW.
AT THE IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE
CENTER AND MY PROJECT FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING IMMIGRATION SERVICES
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SPECIFICALLY WITH DHAKA.
AND IT IN THAT ROLE I SAW
FIRSTHAND -- THE NEED THAT EXIST
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
IMMIGRATION SERVICES ESPECIALLY
FOR REMOVAL DEFENSE.
AND THIS PROPOSAL IS CRUCIAL TO
BE ABLE TO FIGHT AGAINST THE
DEPORTATION MACHINE THAT WE ARE
UP AGAINST.
AND I URGE THAT OUR STATE
CONTINUE TO COMMIT TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO LEGAL REPRESENTATION
FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY SO THAT
OUR FAMILIES DON'T CONTINUE TO
BE TORN APART.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD EVENING.
GM SAKE I'M AN ATTORNEY AT
CENTROLEGAL LET US IN OAKLAND
I'M HERE TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR
ITEMS NUMBER TWELVE AND THIRTEEN
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT THE STATE HAS GIVEN --
IN REGARDS TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN I WOULD ASK -- TO
INVEST IN THIS INFRASTRUCTURE TO
GUARANTEE.
THAT.
QUALITY LEGAL SERVICES IN
REMOVAL DEFENSE ARE AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS NO MATTER
WHERE THEY LIVE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS COMING
LET'S HAVE IS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOTUS RIGHT THE
FOUNDATION WE'RE BASED IN
BAKERSFIELD WE HAVE A MEMBERSHIP
PROGRAM WITH A SINGLE SONY THOSE
UNITED NEIGHBORS.
AND WE SERVE -- MOSTLY --
IMMIGRANTS FARMWORKERS AND KERN
TULARE IN FRESNO COUNTY AND
WE'RE HERE TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR ITEMS TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN THINK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO EVERYONE GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS DEANNA KIDDOS I'M AN
INTERN WITH THE WHAT'S MY
LAWCENTER I'M HERE TO VOICE MY
ARM.
HER FOR HOURS A. ARM FOR ITEMS
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN SPECIFICALLY
WHAT THIRTEEN I AM VERY
INTERESTED NOT JUST PERSONALLY
BUT ALSO LIKE IN A PROFESSIONAL
WAY.
AND HAVING A PIPELINE THAT I
SURE IS OUR COMMUNITY IS SERVED
WITH THE DURING THE BAD TIMES
ADAPTATION COMING UP ON FAMILIES.
WE ARE VERY ON ON THAT REPRESENT
THEIR COMMUNITIES DOWN IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY -- I HAVE FAMILY
THERE SPECIFICALLY AND I KNOW
HOW HARD IT IS TO FIND SOMEBODY
THAT IS WILLING TO PROVIDE YOU
SERVICES WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT YOU HAVE.
I'M ACTUALLY AN INSPIRING
ATTORNEYS SO HAVING A PIPELINE --
TO BECOME -- THE TOURNEY AND
SERVE MY COMMUNITY WILL ALSO BE
GREAT THANK YOU.
WE WILL WELCOME YOU TO THE LEGAL
PROFESSION.
WHAT ABOUT THIS NUMBERS WITHIN
ABOUT I GUESS? ZERO ZERO LUMINAL
CALCULABLE AHEAD.
THE SEVENTH SEAL THE MUSCULAR
COMMENT THAT IS THE CASE.
YOUR POOR YOUR ROCK POLITICS ON
THIS IN THE USE.
HE RECORDED UNDER THE SKIN THIS
WILL THIS WILL HAPPEN LEVELS
MOST OF MOST LIBERALS UP WE
ALMOST THIS ONE'S A LITTLE
SOURCE DOWN AND WHAT THE OUR
SYSTEMS AND WHAT ABOUT THE TH
AND TH.
IN A SIX JESSICA BARTOLO WESTERN
CENTER ALONG PARTY IN SUPPORT OF
ITEMS TWELVE AND THIRTEEN THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITH THAT.
COMPLETES THE PUBLIC COMMENT TWO
VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT
[inaudible]
AND THE SCHOOL SALAS IS OFFICE.
AND STAFF ON FINDING HOW -- WE
CAN DO THE PLACING OF THE FUNDS
THROUGH DSS -- ARE NOT ITEM
NUMBER. TWELVE I WILL HAVE STAFF
REACH OUT TO YOU SO WE CAN BEGIN
THAT CONVERSATION.
BE TO ENGAGE IN CONVERSATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH Q. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S GO TO ITEM.
OUR ISSUE.
FOURTEEN YOU KNOW WHAT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M GONNA HAVE.
AND FOR LET'S GIVE A MOMENT
[inaudible]
FOUR FOUR IT KILLED.
JUST FOR YOU [inaudible]
TEST TEST [inaudible] FIFTEEN
RESERVE YOUR ALL RIGHT BEFORE WE
BEGIN ISSUE.
FOURTEEN I'M I'M GOING TO ALLOW --
AND ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY
SALAS TO GIVE HIS TESTIMONY ON
ISSUE FIFTEEN ISSUE FIFTY WILL
COME AFTER FOURTEEN HOWEVER I AM
ASKING. FOR HIS TESTIMONY IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I DON'T WANT
HIM TO LEAVE WITHOUT PROVIDING
THAT TO US.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THAT I APPRECIATE THE
DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THAT DIFFERENCE I DO APPRECIATE.
THAT OPPORTUNITY I BELIEVE WE'RE
BOTH SUPPOSED TO BE AT A NOTHER
FUNCTION FAIRLY.
SHORTLY -- TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ON FILE ITEM NUMBER --
FIFTEEN IT'S A REQUEST FOR A ONE
TIME TWELVE MILLION
APPROPRIATION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE DOOR SUPPORT THE
FOUNDATION.
AND THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER.
THIS IS A FUNDING TO BE
DISPERSED OVER THREE YEARS THAT
ALLOW ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE.
CAN WE CLOSE THE DOOR
MOMENTARILY
.
ALL RIGHT I'M SORRY MR SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
UP YEAH I'M HERE TO REQUEST
SUPPORT FOR THE ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AN APPROPRIATION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE DOOR SUPPORT
THE FOUNDATION OF THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING FREEDOM CENTER SAID
TO BE DISPERSED OVER THREE YEARS
SO HOPEFULLY THAT'LL HELP THE
ALLOCATION AS WELL -- HERE
RATHER THAN READING FROM MY
TALKING POINTS -- BUT I'M SURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BUT LET ME JUST TELL YOU WITH
THIS PROGRAM DOES AND WHAT IT
MEANS TO THE VALLEY INTO OUR
RESIDENTS AND I SEE THE FIRST
HAND.
BUT ONLY THE DOORS WITH THE
FOUNDATION WORKING IN THE VALLEY
BUT EVEN THE FREEDOM CENTER AND
THEY'RE UP IN ALAMEDA COUNTY IN.
AN OAKLAND AND THEY'RE LOOKING
TO EXPAND THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
ACTUALLY.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A LOT OF
TIMES WERE UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WE TALK ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE
THAT DIFFERENCE? FOR
CALIFORNIANS THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT'S MAKING IT A DIFFERENCE
FOR THE YOUTH AND I'VE MET I CAN
TELL YOU HOW MANY STUDENTS THAT
HAVE COME THROUGH THIS PROGRAM
THAT FIRST STARTED.
WITH.
BEING LOST READ NO WHAT I WAS
GOING TO DO IN LIFE -- WITHOUT
THE CONFIDENCE THE PUBLIC
SPEAKING SKILLS -- THE THE
ABILITY. TO TO GET OUT OF A
PATHWAY THAT SOME WOULD SAY
WOULD LEAD THEM DOWN.
POSSIBLY THE ROAD PRISON -- THE
ROAD TO NOT CONTINUING HIGH
SCHOOL.
BECOMING TRUANTS.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS
WERE YOU ASK WHAT'S OUR RETURN
ON INVESTMENT. FOR THE STUDENTS
WHAT IS A SMALL ALLOCATION WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN.
AND I CAN TELL YOU IS
TRANSFORMING LIVES.
NO SPOKEN STUDENTS WHERE THEY
SAID.
YOU KNOW I WAS SHOT.
AND NOW ACTUALLY CAN SPEAK IN
PUBLIC.
I WAS.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THOSE STUDENTS
AT FELT.
PROBABLY ASHAMED OF MY ACCENT.
BUT NOW I'M INVOLVED.
THE STUDENT THAT NOW THE USED TO
BE A SHY STUDENT BUT I WAS
TEACHING CLASSES.
RIGHT AND THIS IS WHAT THIS
PROGRAM DOES AND THIS IS HOW IT
MATTERS THIS IS HOW IT'S MAKING
AN IMPACT YOU KNOW THERE'S LOTS
OF GREAT PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
HEARING HERE IN YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND ALL WORTHWHILE PROGRAMS --
BUT THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT BUT
I SEE FOR FUTURE -- REALLY IS
THESE PROGRAMS LIKE THE DOLLARS
FOR THE FOUNDATION.
AND THE FREEDOM CENTER.
I MEAN THESE ARE THE PROGRAMS
WERE AT THE END OF OUR TEN YEAR
WE WANT TO SAY WHAT KIND OF
IMPACT WILL KIND OF LASTING
IMPACT DO WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN YOU SEE?
THESE STUDENTS TAKING OUR JOBS
BECOMING ELECTED OFFICIALS
THAT'S A LEGACY THAT WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE BEHIND AND SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU --
GIVE SERIOUS CONSIDERATION TO
THIS TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR ASK
BECAUSE THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
IS.
AS A RETURN THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE
TENFOLD HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU I WILL KEEP THAT IN
MIND AS WELL WE DO TAKE UP ITEM.
FIFTEEN ALL RIGHT LET'S GET BACK
TO ISSUE [inaudible]
FOURTEEN ALL RIGHT.
LET'S BEGIN WITH.
LOW THE ON FOR WEEKS YES.
I WAS GONNA SAY GOOD AFTERNOON
BUT IT'S MORE LIKE A NIGHT.
MY NAME IS LAW THAT ROYCE AND
I'M THE FOSTER CARE BRIDGE
MANAGER FOR THE YMCA OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY.
CHILD CARE RESOURCE SERVICE
CHAIR LATEST AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE. TO REPRESENT THE
DOZENS OF COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CORY NEED OF AN
INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR THE
MERGING SEE CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER CHILDREN.
GET THE COMMITMENT YOU MADE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO CREATE
THIS PROGRAM.
IS TRANSFORMING THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU FOR REFORMING THE
SYSTEM FOR OUR YOUNGEST
CALIFORNIANS WHOSE VOICES ARE
OFTEN NOT HEARD.
BUT ARE OFTEN REPRESENTED BY
NEGATIVE STATISTICS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS ASKING TO GROW
THE EXISTING PROGRAM BY
PROVIDING THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
TO EXPAND THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES. TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
VOUCHERS TO CHILDREN IN CARE.
FIVE MILLION TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL NAVIGATORS WHO ARE
WORKING TO FIND CHILD CARE FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN.
AND FOUR MILLION TO DELIVER
ADDITIONAL TRAUMA INFORMED
TRAINING FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS.
AS A CARE FOR FOSTER CHILDREN IN
THEIR LOCAL EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROGRAMS.
THE INTENTIONAL HIGH QUALITY
COLLABORATION BETWEEN RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES AND CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES.
IS WORKING TO THE BENEFIT OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
SINCE THE START OF OUR FISCAL
YEAR WE HAVE SIR TWO HUNDRED AND
NINE FOSTER CHILDREN WITH CHILD
CARE NAVIGATION. TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE VOUCHER PAYMENTS
HAVE BEEN ISSUED THROUGH
FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE'VE TRAIN A TOTAL SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS IN TRAUMA
INFORMED TRAININGS.
AND PROVIDED ONE ON ONE TRAUMA
INFORMED COACHING TO A TOTAL OF
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS.
WITH ADDITIONAL PROPOSE FUNDING
TO SUPPORT GREATER NAVIGATION
AND TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING FOR
PROVIDERS MORE CHILDREN AND MORE
PROVIDERS WILL BE SERVED COUNTY
WIDE.
THIS MEANS MORE STABLE AND
CONSISTENT CARE.
PROVIDERS ARE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
CARE FOR THESE CHILDREN.
FOSTER PARENTS INCLUDING
RELATIVE CARE GIVER STRUGGLING
TO ACCESS CHILD CARE IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING A CHILD'S PLACEMENT IN
THEIR HOME.
FOSTER PARENTS ESPECIALLY CAN
CARE GIVERS OFTEN GET LESS THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS TO RANGE FOR
QUALITY CHILD CARE.
THIS MEANS THAT CARE GIVERS WHO
WORK OR ARE IN SCHOOL CANNOT
TAKE IN A CHILD WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANTLY DISRUPTING THEIR
LIVES OR PUTTING THEIR FAMILY IN
FINANCIAL JEOPARDY.
THE BRIDGE BELIEVES THIS BARRIER.
TRAINING FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE THROUGH THE **** BRIDGE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN CRITICAL
BECAUSE OF THE MANY ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
THESE CHILDREN LIVE WITH. ONE
PROVIDER WE WORKED WITH
COMMENTED AFTER RECEIVING
TRAINING AND COACHING WE GOT
STRAIGHT INTO ACTION
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF YOUR IDEAS
THEY HAVE REALLY HELPED.
SHE SEEMS BACK TO HER NORMAL
SELF AND ALL HER PREVIOUS
FRIENDSHIPS AT SCHOOL WOULD HAVE
BEEN RESTORED.
SHE WENT ON TO ADD OUR OTHER
FOSTER KID -- HAD A REALLY ROUGH
TWO WEEK PERIOD FOLLOWING HER
COURT DATE BUT I WAS PREPARED
FOR IT THIS TIME AND WE WERE
ABLE TO GET HER SETTLED DOWN
QUICKLY.
IN PREPARING AND PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT TO OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WE ARE EMPOWERING THEM
TO NURTURE THESE LITTLE ONES.
WHO MAY HAVE EXPERIENCED SUCH
HARDSHIPS IN WAYS THAT CAN HAVE
LASTING EFFECTS?
ON A CHILD'S LONG TERM WELL
BEING.
IN MOVING FORWARD WE STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
THIS BUDGET AUGMENTATION REQUEST
THANK YOU.
LIKE SPEAKER.
CAN JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AT JUST SEE THINGS IN
TERMS OF THE AGENDA.
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T HAVE THE
EXPANSION INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL -- BUT OBVIOUSLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE JUST AB MENTION IN SUCCESS
STORIES THAT ARE HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IT'S IT'S
REALLY AT FEELING GREAT AND MET
NEED APPRECIATE THE WORK THERE --
IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE PROPOSAL --
THAT WE JUST HEARD THE ONE THING
THAT WE WOULD SAY IS THAT WE ARE
WE ARE STILL IN EARLY INFANCY
EVER THE BRIDGE PROGRAM.
AT A STAGE WHERE WE HAVE NOT YET
SEEN WHETHER OR NOT THE BRIDGE
TO THE OTHER CHILDCARE SUBSIDY
SYSTEM IS ACTUALLY WORKING SO WE
WANT TO BEFORE I THINK --
CODIFYING EVERY DAY AT REJECTION
TO THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THE
DOCTOR CAN BE UTILIZED WOULD
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE SOME
DATA THE INFLUENCE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A SUBSIDY THERE --
TO SUPPORT THAT TRANSITION.
ALSO ON YOUR AGENDA AT POINTS
OUT THAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
ADD THIS WOULD BRING THE BRIDGE
AT CONSISTENT WITH THE OTHER
CHILD CARE STEPS THE VOUCHER
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
TO ENSURE THAT ANY EXAM
PROVIDERS PROVIDING CHILDCARE
THROUGH THE BRIDGE INITIATIVE
ARE RECEIVING THE BACKGROUND
CHECK THROUGH THE TRUST LINE
PROCESS.
AND THAT THE FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH GETTING FINGERPRINTED AND
GOING TO THAT PROCESS COULD BE
REIMBURSED AND THAT'S IS
ACTUALLY AT NO COST WE BELIEVE
THE EXISTING RESOURCES.
COULD AT COULD YOU LET BE
UTILIZED HERE FOR THIS AT
SPECIFIC PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
LIKE SPEAKER.
JUST THE GREATEST BERMAN OF
FINANCE -- AT THE SAME -- WITH
REGARDS THE ADVOCATES --
PROPOSAL WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION -- AND THEN JUST A
GUARD THAT WE ARE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT OF THE TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
JENNY BELLOW AT THE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE'D BE HAPPY TO REVIEW
ANY OF THE DATA THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
COULD BE COME AVAILABLE AND IN
THE FUTURE RELATED TO THE
CURRENT PROGRAM.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE'S THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- IN DECEMBER TO DO YOU
KNOW I I DID RECEIVE -- WORD AND
JAMES MOSES CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY.
AND WITH GREAT GREAT WORDS ABOUT
IT -- JORDY THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE HELP TO REACHES ZERO TWO
THREE YEARS OF AGE.
THEY HAVE THE MOST DIFFICULTY
BEING PLACED IN CARE.
THIS PROGRAM GUARANTEES CHILDREN
A SPOT FOR SIX MONTHS EXPAND
EXTENDED TO TWELVE MONTHS.
PROVIDES TRAINING TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AS YOU MENTIONED FOR
TRAUMA COACHING -- TRAUMA AND
COACHING DURING.
ON DECEMBER DINO COUNTY HAS
APPLIED AND BEGAN THE PROGRAM A
JANUARY FIRST.
IN THAT TIME THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK WITH IN PLACE.
FIFTEEN CHILDREN -- SINCE --
SINCE MARCH OF THIS YEAR -- THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR ANOTHER.
THREE HUNDRED OF THE OF OVER
THREE HAD OVER ONE THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN NEED -- IN HIS FINAL
WORD WAS PLEASE CONTINUE THE
FUNDING ON A YEARLY BASIS AND IF
POSSIBLE INCREASE FUNDING TO
HELP MORE KIDS.
ARE COUNTY IN OUR STATE NEEDS
THIS.
AND I SINCERELY APPRECIATE HIS
COMMENTS BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE GREATEST ADVOCATES FOR
CHILDREN.
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY -- AND
TRAILER BILL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE I I THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE PROVIDED -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THIS
FRAZIER.
VERY GOOD -- I'D.
LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS.
NO I'M SORRY.
IT IS THEY'RE GOING TO BE ANYONE
OTHER THAN THE ONE PERSON A
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
ALL RIGHT THERE WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT LIKE WE DID AND WE SAID
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT -- IS IT
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IS GOING TO
BE AFTER ISSUE [inaudible]
FIFTEEN SEVENTEEN ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO ALL OF THE
PANELISTS ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
ISSUE.
FIFTEEN AND WILL RECALL THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- RUDY SALAS
HAS PROVIDED HIS TESTIMONY
ALREADY.
THE SPOKESPERSON FROM THE LOTUS
WHAT THE FOUNDATION.
KAMALA WE WELCOME YOU -- IT WAS
SO GOOD TO TO SEE YOUR MOTHER
THE LOTUS WHAT THE YESTERDAY --
AND TO HEAR HER HER -- VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RUDY SALAS ALSO COMING IN TO
PROVIDE ADVOCACY.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
COMING LET'S HAVE IS I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE THE
LOTUS WITH THE FOUNDATION.
AND I'M JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
DR KAREN BULKY DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS WITH THE
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM CENTER.
TOGETHER ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SERVE OPPORTUNITY
USE FROM VULNERABLE HI POVERTY
URBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE THANK THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORTING THE
FORMAL STATEWIDE LUNCH OF THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
LAST YEAR AND KERN FRESNO
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTIES THF AND MLK HAVE A
COMBINED THIRTY YEARS OF USE
PROGRAMMING WHICH WE ARE
ENHANCING TO EVIDENCE BASED
CURRICULUM.
AND HANDSON CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROJECTS SO YOUNG PEOPLE CAN
TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE IN
ADVOCATING FOR COMMUNITY
IMPROVEMENTS AND POLICY CHANGES
AT THE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVEL.
AND LESS THAN ONE YEAR WE HAVE
EXCEEDED OUR GOALS REACHING MORE
THAN FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS FROM SAN DIEGO TO
SACRAMENTO AT CONFERENCES
CLASSES AND EVENTS.
WE HAVE DONE THIS THROUGH THE
WORK OF TWO HUNDRED AND THREE
STUDENT LEADERS WHO WERE
SELECTED FROM MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED NOMINATIONS BY TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
USE LEADERS ATTENDED FORTY THREE
SATURDAY CLASSES TWENTY NINE
EVENING CLASSES AND SIXTY SEVEN
FULL DAY CLASSES TO PREPARE FOR
THE TRAINING SET THEY IN TURN
PROVIDED TO THE TENS AND
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
A COUPLE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
THE PROGRAM INCLUDE A SIX WEEK
SUMMER CIVIC ENGAGEMENT TORE IN
WHICH OVER ONE HUNDRED USE
LEADERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
TRAVELED THE SEVENTEEN CITIES
TOWNS AND TRIBES.
IT WAS THE FIRST VISIT FOR MANY
OF THE STUDENTS TO TRAVEL OUT OF
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
MAY YOUR ALL AND CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE FORMS WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS AND OTHERS.
LAST NOVEMBER USE LEADERS
ORGANIZE THE EVENTS AND ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE CANDIDATES OVER
A HUNDRED YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS PARTICIPATED IN THE WEEK
LAW.
A WEEK LONG LIFE AND LEGACY
TRAINING DURING THE WINTER BREAK
WHICH PROVIDE IN AN IN DEPTH
STUDY OF DR KING'S WORK AND
WRITINGS.
THF ENGAGED IN TREE PLANTING AND
COMMUNITY CLEAN UP EVENTS AND
KERN WITH THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS SUCH AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUDY SALAS AND
CONGRESSMAN TJ ****.
THEY USE PROVIDED EVENT SUPPORT
MARCHED AND SPOKE AT MULTIPLE
WOMEN'S MARCHES ON EVENTS ON
JANUARY NINETEENTH WITH MORE
THAN FORTY THOUSAND AND
ATTENDANCE.
USE LEADERS KEYNOTED YMCAS
CONFERENCE ON USING GOVERNMENT
TO FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS.
USE LEADERS PRESENTED A WORKSHOP
ON HEALING AND EXPRESSION AT THE
DHS SPONSORED LGBT Q. U. SUMMIT
AND BAKER SPILLED.
OVER FORTY USE ARE TRAINED TO
ENGAGE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUDGETING PROCESS THROUGH THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN IN JUST A FEW WEEKS THEY
WILL PROVIDE FORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THEIR
RESPECTIVE SCHOOL BOARDS -- EL
CAP AND POSSESSIONS AND KERN TO
LARRY AND FRESNO COUNTIES.
THESE COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCES ARE
PREPARING CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH TO
BECOME THE NEXT GENERATION OF
INCLUSIVE AND ETHICAL LEADERS
WORKING TO COMBAT VIOLENCE AND
APATHY.
INCLUDED IN OUR MANDATE FROM
LAST YEAR'S FUNDING WAS TO
EXPAND STATEWIDE AND WE ARE
WORKING TO ACHIEVE THIS THEM
OKAY HAS LUNCH STATEWIDE
PARTNERSHIPS IN SACRAMENTO SAN
DIEGO AND LOS ANGELES. TO EXPAND
THIS PROGRAM WE ARE REQUESTING
FOR MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS FOR THE
YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
A ONE TIME TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FUNDING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA GENERAL FUND ACHIEVES
THE FOLLOWING.
EXPANSION OF THE INITIATIVE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH DIRECT
SERVICES IN THE FOLLOWING TWELVE
COUNTIES ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA
FRESNO KERN.
LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO
SAN FRANCISCO SAN JOAQUIN SANTA
CLARA TELERI AND YOLO.
SUSTAINABILITY AND STAFF AND
STAFF TRAINING REGIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY TO
FACILITATE YOUTH AND FAMILY
LEADERSHIP AND COMMUNITY IMPACT.
CULTIVATION OF STRONG YOUTH
LEADERSHIP INSURING STATEWIDE
PRESENCE OF A MINIMUM OF FOUR
HUNDRED YOUNG PEOPLE IN YEAR ONE
AND SIX HUNDRED USE IN YEARS TWO
AND THREE PARTICIPATION OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND MEANING
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
A MINIMUM OF THREE STATE JOINT
WIDE PROJECTS SUCH AS THE CENSUS
AND FIFTY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
PROJECTS ADDRESSING LOCAL ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO EACH COMMUNITY.
YOUTH LEADERS WILL PRESENT
CLASSES SEMINARS AND KEYNOTE
SPEECHES AT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STATEWIDE AND REGIONAL EVENTS
INCREASING IN QUANTITY EACH YEAR
REACHING FIFTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR.
LASTLY LEADERSHIP PATHWAY FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO SECURE ACADEMIC
AND EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS.
THIS INITIATIVE IS FOR FILLING
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT CHARTER THAT IS
EMBODIED IN THE LONG STANDING
VOTER MOTOR MANDATE.
THIS MANDATE IF IT ENVISIONS NOT
ONLY THAT PEOPLE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
BUT THAT THEIR CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
WILL BE ENCOURAGED AND SUPPORTED.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT THIS PROGRAM
FITS WELL WITHIN THE MISSION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND WE'RE ASKING THAT
IT CONTINUE TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY THAT DEPARTMENT.
IN CLOSING RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT THAT CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS A
HABITUAL ACTIVITY BY CONTINUING
TO ENGAGE YOUTH AND FAMILIES
EARLY HE THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE
WE STAND TO ENSURE LIFETIMES.
AND GENERATIONS OF PARTICIPATION
IN DEMOCRACY.
THANK YOU AND SEIZE UP WITH THEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE HAVE UPDATED THE THE
REPORT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE WILL
BE ACHIEVING AND THIS THREE YEAR
FUNDING AND WE'VE SUBMITTED THAT
TO YOU IN WRITING THIS EVENING
YOU EACH HAVE A COPY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NEXT SPEAKER.
CAN JOHNSON SOCIAL SERVICES IT
HAS BEEN AN HONOR TO AT PARTNER
WITH AB BOTH ORGANIZATIONS ON
THIS EFFORT.
AND WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM THE YOUTH.
ALL RIGHT YOUTH IT'S EUROPE --
I'M SO I AM SO SORRY I DID IT
AGAIN WE'RE NOT READY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT JUST YET.
THIS SET THE RULES AT THE
BEGINNING A WE GOTTA KEEP THAT.
SEE SO WHEN YOU'RE UP HERE YOU
CAN SAY NO WE'RE GONNA DO A
RIGHT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING -- ON ISSUE FIFTEEN
WITHOUT A DOUBT IF WE'RE GOING
TO LEARN ABOUT -- CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT THE TWO GREATEST
LEADERS MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR AND THE LAW IS WHAT -- TO
WE MAY NOT HAVE DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING WITH US BUT HIS LEGACY
LIVES ON AND WE HAVE OUR
NATIONAL TREASURE WITH THE LOTUS
WITH THAT.
STILL WITH US TO BE ABLE TO
TEACH OUR YOUTH TO BE ABLE TO TO
ENCOURAGE THEM AND TO TO
MOTIVATE THEM.
LIKE NOBODY ELSE CAM AND I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS WHAT IN THIS
AS WELL.
BECAUSE IT WOULD YOU'VE GOT TO
HAVE THE RIGHT LEADERS TO TO
CONTINUE THE LEGACY OF TWO GREAT
GREAT ICONS.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FOR
THIS PRESENTATION.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
AN ISSUE SIXTEEN IF WE CAN GET
THE PANELISTS.
ALL RIGHT WILL BEGIN WITH THE
NATO THE LOGO THOUGH ALSO OLD
OLSON.
SORRY I'M I'M GREEN I DON'T USE
PAPER AS MUCH BUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAD A FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT SO SEND HIS REGRETS
BUT IT'S IN THE LETTER -- AND
I'M SURE IT CAPTURES -- HIS
WISHES VERY WELL SO -- MOVE THE
MICROPHONE CLOSER TO SHARE SOME
BETTER THAT'S OKAY -- WELL GOOD
EVENING I'M GONNA CUT MY REMARKS
DOWN BECAUSE I KNOW HOW LATE IT
IS AND FOLKS WANT TO GET HOME
BUT IT'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHAIRPERSON RAISINS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER -- FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR STAYING HERE
SO LATE IN THE EVENING AND SICK
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO'VE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL THROUGH THE PROCESS --
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE OVER
TIME WILL BUILD UPON THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WE'VE ALREADY HELPS
AND POVERTY.
AND HELP MILLIONS MORE.
AND I MIGHT ADD HELP A LOT OF
THE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO ARE PART
OF THE ADVOCATES YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY THAT WE WORK WITH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
MY NAME IS BENITO DELGADO WILSON
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SUPPLY
BANK DOT ORG IT'S AN
ORGANIZATION WE CREATED UC
BERKELEY SOME TEN YEARS AGO AS A
STUDENT GROUP AS PART OF AN A.
S. YOU SEE.
AN INITIATIVE.
IT'S BASICALLY WHAT YOU WOULD
THINK OF AS A REGIONAL FOOD BANK
BUT FOR EVERYTHING THAT IS NOT
FOOD.
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY WOULD BE
HELPFUL WITH THE CONTEXT OF THIS.
PRIOR TO NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
THE SAME WAY THAT -- CODE DRIVES
BACKPACK DRIVES DIAPER DRIVES
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU HEAR
ABOUT AND I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
HAVE VOLUNTEERED ON I KNOW SOME
OF YOU WHO VOLUNTEERED ON QUITE
WELL.
IS EXACTLY HOW WE TREATED HUNGER
IN THE UNITED STATES WAS JUST
VERY FEW EXCEPTIONS.
BUT IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN A
FORMER BUSINESSMAN IN PHOENIX
ARIZONA THOUGHT WELL WHAT IF WE
CENTRALIZED ALL OF THIS GIVING
FROM FARMERS AND FOOD PRODUCERS
INTO ONE CENTRAL HUB.
IN PUT ALL THOSE RESOURCES OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY YOUR SOUP
KITCHENS YOUR FOOD PANTRIES YOUR
CHURCHES.
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THEY'RE
DOING THE HARD WORK ON THE FRONT
LINES EVERYDAY FEEDING PEOPLE
AND PROVIDING THEM WITH
GROCERIES TO ALLEVIATE HUNGER.
IT WAS A TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN
TEN YEARS LATER THE UNITED
STATES WAS FUNDING EIGHTEEN
REGIONAL FOOD BANKS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE QUITE SIMILAR TO THAT WE
ARE NO WHERE NEAR THAT SCALE
WE'RE VERY HUMBLING COMPARISON.
BUT WE DO WORK WITH FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT INCLUDE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WOMEN INFANTS AND
CHILDREN CLINICS FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTERS.
CAL WORKS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS HOME VISITATION
PROGRAMS.
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT OF OUR FIRST --
FIVE COUNTY COMMISSIONS AS WELL
AS SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES AND
INCLUDE SOME OF THEM HERE TODAY
AS WELL AS OTHERS THAT WE WORK
WITH ALL ACROSS THE PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE APPARATUS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE TAKE THESE MATERIALS AND SEND
THEM OUT THROUGH EXISTING PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
PATHWAYS OUT OF POVERTY FOR
THESE PEOPLE. TO IMPROVE THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS THEY HAVE ALSO TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE BASIC NEED
THAT THEY DESPERATELY NEED AN
OTHERWISE WILL LIKELY GO WITHOUT.
WE'VE HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE
OVER THE YEARS SEVERAL EFFORTS
AROUND MANY OF WHICH WE ARE VERY
PROUD TO SUPPORT AROUND DIAPER
NEED.
IS WELL AS MANY OTHER -- VERY
MERITORIOUS EFFORTS WHERE I'D
MET OUR HUMBLE IN COMPARISON TO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY.
BUT VERY IMPORTANT. TWO WEEKS
AGO MY STAFF AND I WERE IN
WASHINGTON DC AND ONE OF MY
STAFF MEMBERS WHO IS HERE TODAY
PARTICIPATE IN THE NATIONAL
DIAPER BANK NETWORK.
LOBBY DAY ALONG WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER ADVOCATES YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY.
IN I THINK THEY SAY IT BEST WHEN
THEY SAY THAT BASIC NEEDS ARE
NOT BASIC.
IMAGINE GOING THROUGH YOUR DAY
WITHOUT HAVING SHAMPOO OR
DEODORANT OR DENTAL HYGIENE KIT
OR BEING A KID IN SCHOOL ABOUT
SCHOOL SUPPLIES WERE BEING A
MOTHER WHO CAN'T PROVIDE DIAPERS
FOR HER BABY.
THESE ARE ALL THE STRUGGLES THAT
THEY FACE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
BUT WE'RE DOING IT THE SAME WAY
WE DID IT WITH FOOD FIFTY YEARS
AGO BUT WE CAN DO BETTER.
SO WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
INITIALLY WAS SCHOOL SUPPLIES
AND HYGIENE KITS WE'VE EXPANDED
WE'VE CREATED -- THE BABY BRAND
WITH OUR OUR STATE CHILDREN
FAMILIES COMMISSION A LOT OF THE
LOCAL AFFILIATES BUT WE ALSO
MANUFACTURE STATIONARY AND
HYGIENE ITEMS AND LAPTOPS.
FOR OUR CLIENTS IN SCHOOLS AND
ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
REALLY QUITE FUNDING CREATIVE
YOU LEARN A LOT.
BUT IT THE END OF THE DAY WHAT
IS NEEDED IS A CENTRALIZED
FACILITY AND THIS ISN'T MY
CONCLUSION WE PUT TOGETHER.
A PANEL OF EXPERTS THAT INCLUDED
REPRESENTATIVES OF SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES COUNTY
SUPERVISORS.
PHILANTHROPIC LEADERS FROM
THROUGHOUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IS WELL AS LOGISTICS EXPERTS
BECAUSE THAT'S A BIG PART OF
WHAT THIS IS.
AND JUST LIKE IT WAS THE KEY IN
THE CATALYST IN PHOENIX ARIZONA
SOME FIFTY YEARS AGO.
THE CATALYST FOR A SUPPLY BANK
IN CALIFORNIA.
IS A BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITY
WHERE YOU CAN CENTRALIZE
RESOURCES YOU CAN SCALE PROGRAMS
YOU CAN REDUCE THREE PL SORRY AB
PRIVATE LOGISTICS AND
WAREHOUSING COST.
IS WELL AS OTHER THINGS BUT ALSO
CENTRALIZED THE PHILANTHROPY IN
THE GOODNESS THAT'S AND
EVERYBODY.
I KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE THAT
THERE PEOPLE WHO MAY ON A
CONTRACTING BUSINESS AND GET
SIXTEEN TRUCKS AND DELIVER
SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND HYGIENE KITS
STOKELY IN BRENTWOOD IF I ASK
THEM.
TO I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
VOLUNTEERS FROM COMPANIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WILL SHOW UP
EVERY DAY AND VOLUNTEER JUST
LIKE THEY DO WITH FOOD BACKS.
AND I KNOW THAT BECAUSE SOME OF
MY BEST MENTORS ARE THE CEO OF
OUR LOCAL FOOD BANK ALAMEDA
COUNTY WHICH RANKED NUMBER ONE
IN THE NATION.
AND OTHERS FROM SAN DIEGO WERE
INCREDIBLY INNOVATIVE AND DOING
AMAZING THINGS AND OTHERS THAT
WE'VE TALKED TO ENGAGE WITH
ACROSS THE STATE.
SO I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TO BE A
PARTNER. FOR WHAT WE THINK
PHILANTHROPY WILL FILL THE REST
OF THE GAP OF THE PROPOSALS FOR
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. THREE
MILLION OF IT MATCHES WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN CONTRIBUTED BY TWO
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE BAY AREA.
ONE MILLION IS FOR COMMERCIAL
GRADE AND FIRE RESISTANT STORAGE
SHEDS FOR FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
PARTNERS AROUND THE STATE.
THAT'S BASICALLY SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM WITH MORE MATERIALS
AND HAVE LESS DELIVERIES.
BUT IT'S ALSO THERE'S A DISASTER
RELIEF COMPONENT OF THIS.
ONE ADVOCATES HERE COULD
PROBABLY DESCRIBE MUCH BETTER
THAN I COULD HELP POVERTY IS A
DISASTER AND IT'S AN ONGOING
CRISIS BUT WE'RE ALSO ALL
FAMILIAR.
WITH THE RECENT DISASTERS IN
PARADISE IN SANTA ROSA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
FLOODING AND OTHER SMALL TIME
DISASTERS SUCH AS AN APARTMENT
BUILDING FIRE OR A LOCAL CREEK
FLOOD IT DISPLACES FAMILIES.
WHILE POWELL YES I WOULD SAY HAS
DONE AN AMAZING AND SUPERB JOB
OF COORDINATING THE NGOS THROUGH
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE RED CROSS DOES HAVE SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE OF WAREHOUSING.
WORKING WITH THEM AND HAVING MY
PROGRAMS TEAM WORK WITH THEM
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL GAPS.
A SMALL FIRE THAT DISPLACES TEN
FAMILIES AN APARTMENT BUILDING
IS IT GOING TO MAKE THE NEWS
LIKE A REGIONAL DISASTER THAT
IMPACTS ALL OF US IN PARADISE
WOOD.
BUT THOSE TEN FAMILY STILL NEED
THEIR BASIC NEEDS TO BE MET
WHILE THEY'RE AT A SHELTER THAT
THE RED CROSS PROVIDE.
THIS IS THE GAP THAT SUPPLY BANK
DOT ORG CAN FILL.
I WANT YOU TO THINK OF LIKE ALL
THESE HOME VISITATION PROGRAMS
THE REASON WHY WE SPOKE ABOUT
THAT BEFORE.
IS MY PROGRAMS TEAM HAS MET WITH
EVERY CHILDREN FAMILIES
COMMISSION IN THE STATE MINUS A
FEW WHICH ARE SCHEDULED FOR
DECEMBER DINO NEXT WEEK TO BEST
MEET WITH -- MISS SCOTT.
AND A NUMBER OF THEM ARE
PROVIDING THAT SERVICE IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM WHEN WE HEAR
THAT WERE THEIR EXPANDING THE
DIAPER CAN'T PROGRAMMER ASKING
WELL HOW DO WE DO THIS IN YOUR
COUNTY.
THEY SAY THE HOME VISITATION
PROGRAM OR WICK OR NOW FOR SEE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT WILL
STRENGTHEN THOSE RELATIONSHIPS.
SAME THING WITH SCHOOLS WE WORK
WITH BRENDA DADDY WHO RUNS THE
HOMELESS PROGRAM THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS AND ALL OF HER.
AMAZING PARTNERS IN RIALTO AND
SAMBAR NEAR UNIFIED ALL THE WAY
OUT INTO BARSTOW ALL OF THESE
FOLKS.
NEED THESE MATERIALS SO THAT
THEY CAN PROVIDE WHAT'S
IMMEDIATELY NEEDED TO THEIR
CLIENTS AND THEN GET INTO THE
DEEPER AND HARDER ON GOING WORK
THAT ALL OF THE ADVOCATES HERE
TODAY HAVE SO ELOQUENTLY.
STATED OUR NEED OF RESOURCES AS
WELL.
SO THAT'S THE BACKGROUND ON OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME I AM HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
ALL RIGHTS -- YES.
I KNOW LOSING TALKING ABOUT WHEN
HE'S TALKING ABOUT SOMEBODY WITH
THESE TRUCKS AND WILLING TO MAKE
OF THOSE TRIPS.
YOU KNOW I'VE KNOWN THIS YOUNG
MAN FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND WHEN
HE CAME OUT OF BERKELEY AND HAD
AN IDEA.
AND IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
SOCIAL SAFETY NET THAT ACTUALLY
HAS IMPACT.
AND LEVERAGES PHILANTHROPY JUST
THROUGH INSPIRATION ALONE AFTER
THE EFFORT SAID.
HIS GROUP HAS GONE.
AN ACCOMPLISHED AS YOU MENTIONED
THE BACKPACK PROGRAM.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF FOR THE
KIDS IN NEED -- IN THE SCHOOLS.
BUT THIS IS ADVANCED WITH IT
ANOTHER CONCEPT.
AND I THINK THAT IS IMPAIR OF NO --
I KNOW THAT MR BONTA.
FULLY SUPPORTS THIS BUT I AFTER
ALSO STE SHARE MY SUPPORT AND
SEEN.
WHAT THIS IS ACCOMPLISHED?
IN THE SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THAT
THEY'VE HAD THIS COMPARATIVELY
TO OTHER LARGE ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT WHAT A FULL FILLS IN AGAIN.
THE GAP THAT IS PROVIDED THAT WE
AS A STATE CANNOT PROVIDE.
IS ESSENTIAL THESE PEOPLE ARE
PUTTING THIS EFFORT IN THAT WE
SUPPORT THIS GOING FORWARD --
THE MIRACLES THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED.
THE APARTMENT FIRES THE OF JUST
THE NEEDS ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CALL AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
IS A FAMILY IN NEED.
THE GAP IS FILLED [inaudible]
RESPONSIVE.
THOUGHTFUL.
COMPASSIONATE.
BUT ALSO.
HIS SENSUAL AND I CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT THIS ORGANIZATION.
SAW WAS GRASSROOTS HAS GROWN I'M
VERY PROUD OF THIS MAN.
AND HIS ORGANIZATION AND I WHOLE
HEARTEDLY HOUSE THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SUPPORT
THEM AND HELP THEM GROW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN TELL MISTER BONTA IT WAS
OKAY HE WASN'T HERE.
OKAY BECAUSE YOU HAD ANOTHER
STUMBLING MEMBER WHO WAS JUST AS
PASSIONATE I WILL LET HIM KNOW
THAT I HAVE BETTER AIR NEEDS IS --
THAT'S COMING FROM HIM I SAID
NOTHING OF THE SORT.
WELL I THANK YOU SO MUCH -- ALL
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN AND I WILL NOTE THAT
THIS IS THE LAST ISSUE.
AND ON OUR AGENDA.
THE LAST STORE.
IT'S JUST AS IMPORTANT AS THEIR
FIRST DAY ISSUE.
THAT IS WITHOUT A DOUBT WE ARE
HERE BECAUSE WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
HELP SEND THEM THE LONG DAY AND
EVENING WE'VE HAD SO THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND ASSEMBLYMAN
FRAZIER -- FOR HEARING US TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT HOW TO INVEST IN
ACTUALLY STRENGTHENING FAMILIES
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING THAT
PARENTS IN ON THIS IS LAST.
WE ARE THE OLDEST CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION AND FAMILY STRENGTH
NEW ORGANIZATION FOUNDED IN
CALIFORNIA FIFTY YEARS AGO LAST
MONTH.
AND WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT WHAT
EVERYBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT
TODAY WITH THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT
HOW TO SUPPORT FAMILIES HOUSE
SUPPORT -- PARENTS IN PARTICULAR.
IT'S TIMELY THAT MAYBE WERE LAST.
SO WE ARE ASKING FOR IS A FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
EVIDENCE BASED PARENTS ANONYMOUS
SERVICES AND THAT INCLUDES.
THE ONLY EVIDENCE BASED PARENT
PARTNER PROGRAM IN THE STATE OR
IN THIS COUNTRY THAT INCLUDES A
WEEKLY SUPPORT GROUP FOR PARENTS
CHILDREN AND YOUTH NO MATTER
WHAT THEIR ISSUE ARTS WHETHER
THEY'RE AN IMMIGRANT FAMILY WITH
THEIR GRAMMA RAISING A CHILD
WITH THE CHILD HAS ADHD.
WHETHER STRUGGLING BECAUSE THEY
LOST A JOB THEY CAN COME TO
PARENTS RAMIS WEEKLY SUPPORT
GROUP ON AN ONGOING BASIS IT'S
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE THIS
COMMUNITY BASED.
AND IT IS EVIDENT SPACE I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
RESEARCH.
IN ADDITION WE OPERATE THE ONLY
PARENT HELP LINE IN THE STATE
WHERE PARENTS ARE CRYING OUT FOR
HELP.
THEY WHEN THEY CALL US THEY SAY
THANK GOD WE HAVE A HUMAN BEING
TO TALK TO BECAUSE I HAVE NOBODY
TO TURN.
TO I NEED TO CALL YOU BEFORE I
TALKED TO MY DAUGHTER WHO WENT
ON A JOY RIDE WITH MY FOUR YEAR
OLD WE HAVE PARENTS CALLING IN
CRISIS THAT THEIR CHILD IS
SUICIDAL.
AND THE SCHOOL ACTUALLY SENT THE
CHILD HOME IS THAT WE DON'T
THINK IT'S SERIOUS AND THEY
NEEDED TO PROCESS WHAT THEY NEED
TO NEXT WHICH IS GO TO THE GROUP.
THEN THEY WENT TO THE PARENTS ON
THIS GROUP THEY TALKED THE
HEALTH PLAN ADVOCATES IS A TRUE
STORY FOR A MONTH AGO.
AND THEY SAY THAT CHILD'S LIFE
BECAUSE A GROUP SUPPORTED THEM
IN GOING TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
WHEN YOU GO TO THE EMERGENCY
ROOM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOUR CHILD A SUICIDAL YOU
WILL BE IMMEDIATELY REPORTED TO
CHILD WELFARE AND INVESTIGATED.
AND THE PARENTS SAID MY CHILD
SAFETY IS MORE IMPORTANT HE'S
ELEVEN YEARS OLD HE'S NEVER
EXPRESSED ANY DESIRE TO KILL
HIMSELF.
SHE SUSPECTED IT WAS IS ADHD
MEDICATION THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED
THE GROUP CAME TOGETHER AS
COMMUNITY FOR HER.
AND TOOK HER OTHER MINOR
CHILDREN HOME MAKE SURE THEY
WERE CARE FOR SHE WAS FORTY
EIGHT HOURS IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM BEFORE SHE WAS.
TRANSFERRED TO CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ORANGE COUNTY THE CHILD
WAS REMOVED THE MEDICATION
STABILIZE ITS CENTER AND HE SOLD
ALL THE THERAPISTS THERE ALREADY
IN HOW TO MEDITATE BECAUSE THEY
GO TO PARENTS ANONYMOUS EVERY
WEEK.
WE USE ONLY EVIDENCE BASED
SERVICES AND THAT'S A TRUE STORY.
WHAT DOES THE RESEARCH SAY WHAT
WE KNOW THAT THE?
WE HAVE SOME INFORMATION FOR YOU --
ABOUT THAT WE HAVE THE RATE OF
CHILD ABUSE IN OUR STATE IS
RELATIVELY HIGH WE KNOW THE LONG
TERM COSTS NOT ONLY ON OUR BODY
AND OUR BEING.
BUT ON THE ABILITY FOR FAMILIES
TO THRIVE AND CONTRIBUTE THE
GOVERNOR RECENTLY TALKED ABOUT
HIS REASON TO HAVE DEVELOPED
INCREASED DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENING WAS IT HIS MOTHER.
HIS OWN MOTHER COULD NOT GET
HELP FOR HIM HE WAS IN FIFTH
GRADE.
AND HE SUFFER FROM DYSLEXIA.
HIS ONLY FIFTY ONE YEARS OLD SO
THAT WAS ONLY FORTY YEARS AGO
THAT THEY WERE STILL STRUGGLING
AND THAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
IT AND PARENTS ARE SHARING THEIR
STORIES.
HOW CAN I GET HELP HOW CAN I ASK
THIS HELP WHERE CAN I TURN?
WE HAVE PEOPLE CALLING WHO SAY I
HAVE NO ONE TO TALK TO I'M TOO
EMBARRASSED TO TELL MY FRIENDS.
YOU PARENTING IS SUPPOSED TO BE
LIKE COOKING IT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK EVERY TIME EVERY TIME YOU
FOLLOW THE RECIPE.
THERE'S SO MUCH BLAME AND SHAME
OUT THERE FOR PARENTS.
WE ARE TOTALLY FIFTY YEARS AGO
BORN BY A PARENT AND SOCIAL
WORKER.
WE HELP PASS FEDERAL LEGISLATION
WE EXISTED BEFORE THEY WERE
FEDERAL LAWS PARENTS NOMS HAS
THE TOTAL LEGACY.
THE RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
WE MEDICAID ASUS YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH ADVERSE CHILD
EXPERIENCES WELL IN INVESTMENT
IN PARENTS NOMOS IS SAVING US
FROM.
MAJOR HEALTH ISSUES MAJOR MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND ANY RISKY
BEHAVIOR WE HAVE AS ADULTS.
BECAUSE IF WE CAN INTERRUPT BY
BUILDING THE RESILIENCE OF
PARENTS WE CAN [inaudible]
STOP.
THIS HEMORRHAGING OF WHAT'S
GOING ON SO PARENTS BECOME
<c.red>NVOLVED IN INTERESTED IN WHAT</c>
pCHILDHOOD I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOMMENDED THEY'RE GOING TO BE
YOU SCREENING OF EVERY CHILD IN
EVERY ADULT.
WHO RECEIVES MEDICARE OUT IN THE
STATE MY ISSUE IS ONCE YOU FIND
OUT YOU HAVE ASUS AND WITH
CHILDREN WERE PREVENTING FUTURE
ACES WHICH RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES
ON PARENTS ANONYMOUS WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO TO HELP PEOPLE?
SO BECOMING AWARE THAT YOU HAVE
A DEVELOPMENTAL PROBLEM WE NEED
TO WORK WITH PARENTS TO SUPPORT
THEM SO THEY CAN HELP ADDRESS
THE DEVELOPMENTAL PROBLEM THE
CHILD HAS.
NOT LEAVE THEM ON THE STREET
CORNERS OKAY YOUR CHILD OR IS
TWO ACES THEIR RISK FOR THESE
PROBLEMS YOUR CHILD HAS ADHD OR
YOUR CHILD HAS A CONDUCT
DISORDER.
THE PARENT IS SITTING THERE
SAYING WHAT DOES THIS MEAN HOW
CAN YOU HELP ME WHAT'S GOING ON
AND THERE ARE SYSTEMS OUT THERE
BUT THE OVERALL HELP.
REALLY COME THROUGH THE IDEA THE
PEOPLE PICK UP THE PHONE AND
THEY ASK FOR HELP WHICH WE
CONSIDER TO BE A SIGN OF
STRENGTH AND POWER.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
VERY GOOD.
WE LEFT YOUR WHOLE PICTURE HERE
FOR A FROM US TO EXPLAIN THINGS
AND SOME OTHER DOCUMENTS.
KIDS WERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
EVIDENCE BASED CLEARING HOUSE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES CREATED TEN YEARS AGO
WE ARE THE ONLY PARENT PARTNER
PROGRAM.
WITH RESEARCH THAT'S WHAT WE
THINK YOUR HUSBAND'S WORTH WHILE
YES.
AND AGAIN I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR HAVING CA I JUST WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU I'D LOVE TO BE
ABLE.
TO COLLABORATE WITH YOU.
LAST YEAR I HAD A BILL PASSED --
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAS TO TEACH.
SCHOOLS HAVE TO TEACH
APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR -- TO STEM.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
APPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR AND DATING.
FOR ABUSE.
ALSO. THREE OR FOUR YEARS AGO.
THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE WAS THE
FIRST TO SIT DYSLEXIA BILL --
THAT REQUIRES OF PHONOLOGICAL
SCREENING IN ALL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS WOULD LIKE.
TO GET YOU COMBINED WITH SOME OF
THESE GROUPS THAT I WORKED WITH
ABSOLUTELY YOU CAN ACTUALLY HAVE
ADVOCATES.
THEY CAN BE PUT ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE WHAT I'M FINDING OUT IS
THERE'S A LACK OF PROVIDERS.
THAT WILL YOU CAN YOU CAN BE AN
ADVOCATE BUT TO GET THE PEOPLE
OF THE PARENTS.
CHILDREN TO THE THE APPROPRIATE.
INDIVIDUALS TO GET THEM THE THE
THERAPY OR WHATEVER THE PROCESS
IS.
A WE DON'T HAVE THE PROVIDERS
THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR THE HEEL
THE LARGE AMOUNT OF OF NEED IN
IN THE STUDENT POPULATION.
BUT LOVE TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH YOU PARENT LEADERSHIP IS
THE CORNERSTONE OF PARENTS SOME
MYSTERY RUN THE ONLY NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR PARENT
LEADERS IN THE COUNTRY.
AND PARENTS WHAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH THEIR OWN LIVED
EXPERIENCE WANT TO HELP ANOTHER
PERSON BE AN ADVOCATE NOT.
OKAY YOU JUST TOLD ME THIS
DIAGNOSIS -- OVERWHELM WHAT TO
DO AND STANDING UP FOR WHAT YOU
NEED IS SO IMPORTANT SO WE WOULD
LOVE TO PARTNER WITH THOSE
ENTITIES. FOR SCHOOLS AND WE
WORK WITH HUNDREDS OF PARTNERS
BECAUSE THE SCHOOLS ARE CALLING
US ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE ARE
CALLING IS HOW CAN WE GIVE THEM
YOUR NUMBER WE CAN'T MEET THE
DEMAND.
WE HAVE TWENTY TWO MILLION
PARENTS IN CALIFORNIA YOU ADD
THAT TO THE NINE MILLION
CHILDREN THIRTY ONE MILLION
PEOPLE AT MINIMUM OF THE STATE
OR WHO ARE TALKING ABOUT A FACT
MAY CALL THE HELPLINE.
ON BEHALF OF THOSE NINE MILLION
CHILDREN THAT DOESN'T EVEN COUNT.
THE CARE OF RELATIVE PROVIDERS
BECAUSE THE CENSUS BUREAU DOES
NOT COUNT THOSE NUMBERS SAYS
ESTIMATES ARE VERY VERY HIGH.
AND HAVING A HELP LINE IT'S A
BASIC THING.
WHY CAN'T PEOPLE REACH OUT AND
SAY I'M STRUGGLING I'M A CRISIS
YOUR SCHOOL JUST TOLD ME THIS I
DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND WITH ADHD
MEANS WHAT WHAT WHAT DOES IT
MEAN WHERE DO I GO?
MY OWN FEELINGS MIGHT BE IN THE
WAY AND PARENTS TALK ABOUT THAT
AND MY IN THE WAY OF MY KIDS
GETTING THE HELP ONCE I HEAR
THEY NEED HELP OR WHAT ABOUT ME
I NEED HELP.
AND MANY PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT
MANY PROGRAMS TO GET WERE
PARENTS ARE STRUGGLING TO GET
THE HELP THEY NEED ONE WHAT EASY
ACCESS WHAT YOU'RE ALSO SEEING.
IS WHEN YOU HAVE ADHD AND OTHER --
CLINICAL DIAGNOSIS FROM THE
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST THAT.
SOMETIMES THE HEALTH PLANS -- OR
THE DOCTORS REFUTE WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING ANY BOUNCES BACK AND
FORTH SO MANY TIMES.
THAT IT'S IT'S A IT'S ONLY A
MISTY FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL CHILD
AND SO LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS.
ABSOLUTELY AND GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE CAN SAY THERE WAS A
POSITIVE RESULT.
ALWAYS OUTCOMES ALWAYS THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY WE'RE
DOING WE SERVE FIVE HUNDRED
PARENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT
INCLUDING A THOUSAND CHILDREN
ATTACH THEM IN A PREVENTION
PROGRAM THAT WE CALL
STRENGTHENING FAMILY SAN
BERNADINO. FOR GOT TO MENTION
THAT IN MY NOTES BEFORE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT NOW OUR OPENING IT UP.
TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WHEN YOU COME UP WOULD YOU TELL
US WHICH?
OF ITEM YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE
SPEAKING ON AB SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF SCO -- SORRY LET ME SANCHEZ
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN HAVING TO DO WITH THE
CHILD CARE BRIDGE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CNN EPHEMERA CHILDREN NOW ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM FOURTEEN
THANK YOU.
KRISTIN POWER THE EYES FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ITEM FOURTEEN
IN SUPPORT OF AUGMENTATION FEE
EMERGENCY TALCHER BRIDGE.
THANK YOU.
LILY COLBY CALIFORNIA COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM FOURTEEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ELATION MENDOZA IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM FIFTEEN BECAUSE
IT HAS SHOWN ME THAT THERE IS
VALUE IN MY VOICE.
LOVE IT THANK MEANT THE BONA AND
I'M SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE BECAUSE THROUGH THIS
INITIATIVE WE HAVE SEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE LEADERSHIP MODEL THAT
THIS HAS BROUGHT TO OUR
COMMUNITY IN AN
INTERGENERATIONAL AN INTERRACIAL
WAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I'M SO FEE ABOUT TISA I'M A
STUDENT AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE BECAUSE IT
IS TAUGHT ME THAT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO BE A LEADER.
BUT TO CREATE LEADERS TO IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO BE THE FIRST BUT
TO MAKE SURE NOT THE LAST
WHETHER IT'S GRADUATING COLLEGE
HIGH SCHOOL OR ONE DAY RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI DIANE IS A MAIN GUYS ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF
LOS ANGELES AND TO THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER.
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE FOURTEEN TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
THE EMERGENCY CHILDCARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM MY AGENCY THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER HAS SERVED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO RESOURCE
FAMILIES.
AND TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
FOSTER CHILDREN IN SAN
BERNARDINO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES THROUGH THE BRIDGE
PROGRAM OVER THE LAST SEVEN
MONTHS.
THE BRIDGE PROGRAM HAS ALSO
ALLOWED OUR NAVIGATORS TO WORK
WITH FAMILIES TO DEVELOP
INDIVIDUALIZED LONG TERM CHILD
CARE PLANS.
DUE TO THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF
FUNDING INITIALLY PROVIDED SOME
COUNTIES HAD TO NARROW THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILD CARE
VOUCHERS THIS PROPOSAL HOPPUS.
GET CLOSER TO THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATIVE INTENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING EVERYONE -- MY NAME
THE SITES OF LOW.
AND I'D LIKE TO SORT OF FIRST BY
SAYING THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU
FOR SETTING ALL THESE HOURS AND
LISTENING TO WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY --
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE -- BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT YOUTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DESERVES THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
INVOLVED IN TO KNOW THE POWER OF
THEIR VOICE AND THEIR ACTION.
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU DON'T
KNOW ACTUALLY I KNOW THE IMPACT
OF IT.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WE HEAR THAT YOUTH OUR
FUTURE AND THAT CHILDREN ARE
FUTURE WHEN IN REALITY IF YOU
LOOK AROUND THE ROOM.
WE'RE HERE RIGHT NOW.
AND WE ARE THE NOW IN ALL WE
NEED IS AN OPPORTUNITY AND WE
NEED GUIDANCE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS YOU'D LET.
WE NEED THE STRENGTH AND THE
KNOWLEDGE OF OUR ELDERS AND WE
NEED THAT ENERGY OF OUR YOUTH TO
CARRY ON AND YOU KNOW THE THIS
INITIATIVE WOULD REALLY GIVEUS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELL LET ME KNOW WHAT IS THE
MATTER IT'S A BLESSED IS THAT I
GET GHOST IS SO DEEP THAT.
YOURS THEY LEARN TO GET A LITTLE
EACH -- UP WE'LL LANDED DIVA
OKAY.
BERGEN ISABEL MONEY IT IS IN A
CHECK ONLY DOES GET US YES ALLEN
IS A DIVA YOUR OPINION ABOUT THE
THE THE THIS IS COOL.
COOL HOLDING IT UP THAT IN FOR
THE PERSON AS YOU GUYS IS IT
ALLEN IS AT THE LIKE JORDAN
ELABORATELY THAT.
THEY COULD LOOK AT MOST BUT AS
SOON AS YOU DATA -- I SAN DIEGO
AND THE YEAH -- THIS TO THE NTH
IS LOOKING A LITTLE SYSTEM WITH
ALL OF THE S. WOULD ADDRESS AS
WAS A TEMPLE GOOD ASK YES.
HI MY NAME IS SHARP.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING OUT HERE
TONIGHT.
THIS INITIATIVE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT TAUGHT ME.
HOW TO SPEAK UP AND HOW TO
COMMUNICATE TO PEOPLE ON THE
THINGS LIKE?
HI THANK YOU GUYS FOR STILL
BEING HERE WITH SUCH SMILES TOO
THANKS A LOT -- I'M HERE IS THE
NEW YEAR COMING UP TO SPEED.
YEAH I'M HERE AT THE POWER OF
THE YOUTH AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
BEHIND ME AND JUST A PERSONAL
STORY LIKE I COME FROM A FAMILY
OF FIRST GENERATION IMMIGRANTS
ON THE FIRST ONE TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
REALIZED AS WE HAVE SO MANY
FAMILIES.
HERE AND SEE SOME ISSUES BUT
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ENGAGE.
AND OFTEN TIMES THEY FEEL
DISEMPOWERED AND INTIMIDATED
I'VE PERSONALLY SEEN HOW THESE
FAMILIES COME TOGETHER IN A HOME
VISIT WHEN WE'RE SITTING DOWN
AND TALKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES
AND THEY COME IN FULL SUPPORT.
OF THE STUDENTS AND I WANT THAT
FOR SO MANY MORE LEADERS I
REALLY DO AND I'M REALLY EXCITED
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
CAN LUIS REPRESENTING A SPIRIT
NIGHT IN SUPPORT OF THE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE BRIDGE
PROPOSAL AM ESPECIALLY BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE COUNTIES THAT WE
SERVE AND THEY ACTUALLY NARROWED
ELIGIBILITY FOR OUR FOR OUR
FOSTER YOUTH IN THE PROGRAM AND
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO BE SERVED
IN SOME OF THE FAA.
PROGRAMS AND I'M FROM MY
PARTNERS AT THE LA COUNTY WANTED
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT AND I
COULDN'T STAY HERE TONIGHT SO
THANK YOU.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TONIGHT MY NAME IS VALERIE
SANCHEZ AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
BEFORE THIS INITIATIVE I HAD
NEVER GONE CAM THE SEEING I
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT PHONE
BANKING WAS I HAD NEVER BEEN TO
A PRESS CONFERENCE FOR THE
CENSUS.
BUT DUE TO THIS OPPORTUNITY I
HAVE HAD THAT CHANCE TO GET
CIVIC CLEAN GAUGE AND IT HAS
GAVE ME.
A GREAT IN POWER MEANT AND IT
HAS BEEN IN LIGHTNING AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT I WANT TO GIVE
BACK TO FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS DANIELLE
CUMPLE.
AS A YOUTH PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
THE YOUTH AND FAMILY CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE I'M HERE.
TO TO SHOW MY SUPPORT I HAVE
WITNESSED THE SELF
TRANSFORMATION THAT YOU'D HAVE
UNDERGONE NOT ONLY FOR
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS WE KNOW PART OF
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
IS -- HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL HOURS SO WE
PROVIDE ARE YOU A SPACE FOR THEM
TO NOT ONLY LEARN BUT TO ALSO
CONNECT WITH EACH OTHER.
ARE YOU THE COM THEY OFTEN SAY
IF IF IT WASN'T FOR THIS PROGRAM
I WOULD BE HOME I WOULD BE HOME
BORED WATCHING TV DOING NOTHING.
I WOULD REALLY I I REALLY WANT
TO CONTINUE THIS SO THAT WE
DON'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM OUR
YOUTH AND SO THAT WE EXPAND THIS
TO OTHER REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE.
YOUTH ARE AND IF THE GROUP
POPULATION BACK UNDER GHOST SO
MANY TALENTS SO MANY CHANGES
BIOLOGICAL.
AND OTHER SOCIAL CHANGES AND
HAVING THIS SPACE IS REALLY.
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO GROW
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MULLIN HAS THAT OTHER MAMMALS
JANET THANK YOU UP OIL AND HE'S
AT THE VA BUT CAME ELEMENT JUST
SUPPORTING AT IS THE DISEASE
THAT AMONG DIFFERENT IS TO THAT
IS.
YOU WANT THIS NO CLOSE YEAH BUT
OKLAHOMA A ONLY THEIR OWN UP BUT
TO ME THAT.
IS.
IN LANSING OUTCOME OF THAT I'M
POLITICAL YOU WANT THIS TO ME
CLASS HAVEN'T MADE OUT OF IT ONE
SOUND LIKE.
YOU'RE ON OKAY I'M LET I WAS
JUST.
YOUR SOMEBODY AND THEY SAID I'M
AS AROUND LOOK AT ALL OF THAT.
THE ROYAL MENACING YELLOW I HAVE
THAT E..
YOU PRAY TELL ME WILL SAFE WITH
A AND POLITICAL PARTY AT THEM
AND GET US A ROOM COM GO AND
CALL ME THAT.
IT HAS GET DELIVERY HE'S DEBORAH
OBAMA.
LOCAL NOT LOVE LOOK ON IT BUT A
PERSONALMENTE BETTER LEVY ON THE
LOVE YOU CAN LET ME KNOW AND I
THINK ONE AND SEE.
YEAH YES YES.
HI EVERYBODY I'M MY NAME IS
GOVERNOR ELEVEN ON THIS AND I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS SUPER
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I GOT INVOLVED
REALLY YOUNG I'M AT THE AGE OF
ELEVEN AND WHERE YOU CAN GO
REGISTER TO VOTE YOU DON'T LEARN.
ANYTHING ABOUT WHO TO VOTE FOR A
LOT OF THE TIMES THE THE TELL
YOU GOAL REGISTER TO VOTE BUT
THEN THEY SEE THE BALLOT THEY
SEE PROPOSITIONS AND YOU GET
REALLY CONFUSED.
I THINK THIS PROGRAM REALLY
ALLOWS THE FIRST GENERATION --
STUDENTS TO REALLY JUST BE HERE
UNDERSTAND GOVERNMENT UNDERSTAND
HOW TO LOBBY UNDERSTAND THAT
SACRAMENTO IS A PLACE WHERE THEY
ARE WELCOME.
AND I THINK THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
THAT TINY AND BETWEEN COMMUNITY
AND GOVERNMENT AND I REALLY
ENJOY -- BEING HERE AND SPEAKING
TO YOU ALL AND I REALLY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PORSCHE BROWN
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
YOUTH AND CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE -- I'VE BEEN WITH THE
INITIATIVE FOR A VERY SHORT TIME
AND I REFERENCE THE TIME BECAUSE
I CANNOT EXPRESS HOW INSPIRING
THAT TIME HERE HAS BEEN TO SEE
OUR YOUTH.
PEACE SO ENGAGED AND BE SO
EMPOWERED AND BE SO
KNOWLEDGEABLE SO ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORTED I THINK IT'S A
BEAUTIFUL THING AND IT LIGHTS A
FIRE INSIDE OF YOU TO BE WITHIN
THIS COMMUNITY ITSELF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CASA VENTURE I
GO TO MONTH TERM MIDDLE SCHOOL I
SUPPORT THE INITIATIVE BECAUSE
IT HELPS EMPOWER MYSELF AND
OTHERS TO HELP STRENGTHEN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WHAT WAS THE BEST THING THE TWO
WHAT IS THE BEST THING YOU LIKE
ABOUT IT -- I'LL LIKE WHEN --
OUR CLASSES WE HAVE.
YOU GET TO MEET A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE.
WERE YOU SHY BEFORE MY FIRST
TIME YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT -- ANY
HEARING US ALL TONIGHT AS WELL
MY NAME IS KIANA PURCELL RUSE I
ASKED SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE.
AND FIRST AND FOREMOST I'M A
MOTHER THAT WAS ACTUALLY. ONE OF
MY SENDS ANOTHER WHAT'S COMING
UP AND YOU KNOW THIS INITIATIVE
REALLY EMPOWERS AND UP LIVES AND
YOU KNOW TRAINS ARE USED TO BE
MORE CIVIC WE INVOLVED AND
ENGAGED I MEAN LIKE.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE OUR YOUTH HERE
THERE'S A LOT AND I'M NOT A LOT
OF YOU TO GET THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THINGS JUST AS THE BEING
HERE RIGHT NOW IN THIS ROOM.
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS
INITIATIVE DOES IT YOU KNOW IT
BRINGS THEM.
AND YOU KNOW IT AROUND AND YOU
KNOW KNOWING THAT THEY CAN ONE
DAY YOU KNOW.
BE IN YOUR SEATS RIGHT HERE AND
SO -- AND IT'S NOT TODAY.
EXACTLY EXACTLY AND YOU KNOW
WITH YOU KNOW EVEN HAVING MY
SON'SA PART OF THIS INITIATIVE
YOU KNOW I FEEL LIKE IT'S
DEFINITELY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
KNOW OTHER STUDENTS OTHER USE
OTHER FAMILIES.
ARE INVOLVED LIKE I DIDN'T
REALLY GET INVOLVED IN.
SO I WAS IN MY LATE TWENTIES AND
THAT'S A REALLY LONG TIME TO GET
YOU KNOW GET INVOLVED IN SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU GUYS SUPPORT OUR
INITIATIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS NEITHER
ROSE AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH AND FAMILY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVE.
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GROWING UP
AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE FACING
INCREASING CHALLENGES CHALLENGES
THAT ARE DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT
FROM PREVIOUS GENERATIONS
ALTHOUGH SIMILAR.
OUR WORLD IS GROWING SMALLER OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO
INCREASINGLY COMPETE WITH THE
PEOPLE OF THE WORLD.
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GROWING UP
IN A TIME WHEN PUBLIC EDUCATION
IS CHANGING AND THE PURPOSE OF
IT IS CHANGING AND THE
DISTRACTIONS AND DIVERSIONS THAT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FACING.
FROM IPHONES TO A VIDEO GAME
STATIONS INCREASINGLY ADDICTIVE
DISTRACTIONS AND DIVERSIONS ARE
UNIQUE AND THEY REQUIRE UNIQUE
APPROACH AND INCREASED
INVESTMENT IN CIVIC EDUCATION
AND IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT THINK.
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN BRING IT DOWN SOME MORE.
OF HI MY NAME'S ARMANI SURVEY JR
I AM SUPPORTING THE INITIATIVE
BECAUSE IN OUR CLASSES IT HAS
BEEN HELPING ME WITH MY SPEAKING
AND RESPECTING PEOPLE WHEN THE
SPEAKING.
THANK YOU.
BUT HOW OLD ARE YOU.
A LEVIN TURNING TO OF LIKE.
TWENTY FIVE HOW OLD WERE YOU
WHEN YOU STARTED.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN IN IT
NINE PROBABLY?
VERY GOOD DO YOU LIKE IT.
YES VERY GOOD SO WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO BE WHEN YOU GROW UP.
PRESIDENT THE UNITED STATES.
I KNOW [inaudible]
AB.
MAYBE OUR OUR WOULD.
GOVERNOR ALL RIGHT LET'S KEEP
YOU IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE AND
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
BE HERE WITH YOU I AM MY NAME IS
KAY I'M I'M OUT ON THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER AND SUPPORT.
THE INITIATIVE BECAUSE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT HAS TRANSFORMED MY
LIFE TO SEE THAT OUR VOICES
MATTER AND THAT DEMOCRACY
REQUIRES OUR VOICES TO BE A PART
OF IT.
AND EVERY DAY WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE THAT THE
VOTE DOESN'T COME EVERY TWO
YEARS EVERY FOUR YEARS IT COMES
WHEN WE CHOOSE -- TO THERE WATCH
NETFLIX ALL DAY OR YOU KNOW GO
TALK TO OUR GRANDMA OR READ A
BOOK OR DO SOMETHING THAT'S A
PART OF SOMETHING BIGGER THAN
OURSELVES AND I THINK WITHOUT
THAT -- I'M MYSELF I KNOW I
WOULD BE VERY DEPRESSED AND VERY --
IN DESPAIR SO I'M COMING HERE --
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE
INITIATIVE AND ALSO THE THANK
YOU FOR FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
SEE SOMEBODY HAD THANKED ME FOR
MY SERVICE.
OUR CHILDREN ARE GROWN AND I
SUPPORT THE THE MONEY.
MORE MONEY FOR THE PROGRAM A
WHAT DO YOU LIKE ABOUT THE
PROGRAM.
HE NINE THREE IS SO SHY AND HELP.
BUT I CAN SAY WHATEVER IS ON THE
LINE AND NOT BE SCARED TO DO IT.
AND IS YOUR IS YOUR VOICE
IMPORTANT IS THAT WHAT YOU DO
YOU FEEL YOUR VOICE IS IMPORTANT.
IT'S POWERFUL ISN'T IT NO.
YES IT IS YOUR VOICE IS POWERFUL.
TELL US YOUR NAME AGAIN.
CHINA.
CHINA THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING -- MY NAME IS NOT
HI I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
INITIATIVE.
USING FUNDING -- SEEKING IS
MEANT TO BE SHARED IF WORKING
FOR THE INITIATIVE FOR SOMETIME
NOW.
I CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE --
COMPARING WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
AS THE STATE'S.
WE LOG BEHIND IN TERMS OF
SEVERAL CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INDICATORS.
WE REALLY NEED TO EXPAND OUR
WORK BECAUSE HI YOU SEE HOW.
OUR STUDENTS HAVE CHANGED SINCE
THE DAY I START WORKING AND I
MYSELF SEE.
I SEE MYSELF I THE STUDENT I
MYSELF PERSONALLY CHANGE IN
TERMS OF GETTING SEVERAL SKILLS
THAT ENABLED ME TO SPEAK UP.
HAVE CONFIDENCE AND BECOME
RESPONSIBLE CITIZENS.
AND THIS WAY -- FOR SPECIALLY
FOR YOU USES.
THAT ENABLES THEM -- TO BECOME
RESPONSIBLE AND VOTING THE
FUTURE AS WELL AS THE HAPPY.
IN THEIR SOCIETY THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING.
MY NAME IS SIERRA AND I AM FULLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE -- BEING CYNICALLY
ENGAGE HAS EMPOWERED ME TO USE
MY VOICE.
TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT THINGS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT.
AND INSPIRE MY COMMUNITY.
YOUNG PEOPLE DESERVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE IMPACTFUL IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHNNY -- I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT THE YOUTH AND
FAMILY CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
INITIATIVE -- AS A FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN -- YOU KNOW
I WAS -- ABLE TO ACTUALLY GO
AWAY FOR COLLEGE AND MY
EXPERIENCE IS THERE ARE YOU KNOW
EXTRAORDINARY.
I WAS SO BLESSED TO BE ABLE TO
GO AND I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
BRING BACK -- THE SAME WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I GREW UP WITH --
AND OPPORTUNITY THAT THEN THIS
IS HAS ALLOWED ME TO IS YOU KNOW
EDUCATE INSPIRE AND EMPOWER
THESE USED. TO YOU KNOW BECOME
THE LEADERS OF TOMORROW AND
DEFINITELY IN THE SHORT TIME
THAT.
THIS PAST FISCAL YEAR HAS
HAPPENED YOU KNOW THESE YOUTH
HAS REALLY.
INSPIRED ME AND EDUCATED ME MORE
ON ISSUES THAT THEY FELT SO -- I
HOPE YOU WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SIMON I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
BEING HERE IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY --
WE'RE WE'RE JUST HERE THESE ARE
MY BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN -- AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THIS PROGRAM
AS YOU CAN TELL IT REALLY DOES
CHANGE THE LIVES OF NOT ONLY THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE AND
AND AND AND THOSE WHO ARE NOT
HERE.
BUT THEIR FAMILIES THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND SOCIETY -- AND
AS YOU SAID EARLIER -- THEIR
VOICE MATTERS AND WHAT WE DO IS --
LET THEM KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HEAR THAT MESSAGE RIGHT --
FROM OTHER PLACES AND THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT GIVES -- THEM HOPE --
AND SO I I I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
SUPPORT US THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SHE SUPPORTS -- TO BRING HER
BACK LET HER SAY SOMETHING.
WHAT IS YOUR NAME WHAT'S YOUR
NAME?
SIMONA AND SHE SUPPORTS THE
PROGRAM AND ITS HER BIRTHDAY.
IT'S NOT REALLY.
JUST BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND OUR
ORGANIZATION IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
HAS TO BE PART OF ANY.
AND MEANINGFUL ANTI POVERTY
EFFORT AND SO WE'RE REALLY
HONORED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO WANT TO
THANK.
MY NAME IS ON OUR TIME WITH THE
OF W. FOUNDATION IN BAKERSFIELD
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CIVIC YOUTH ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU --
AND THOSE WHO DID THE LAST
PRESENTATIONS AND THOSE WHO
STAYED TO SUPPORT. FOR THE YOUTH
WHO ARE HERE I WANT TO THANK YOU
BECAUSE YOUR VOICE ABSOLUTELY
MATTERS.
ABSOLUTELY MATTERS WHATEVER IT
IS THAT YOU DECIDE TO DO YOU
HAVE LOTS OF PEOPLE WHO WILL
SUPPORT YOU.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL COUNT
ON US -- YOU HEARD RIGHT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM FRAZIER ALSO
WE ARE HERE TO TO SERVE YOU AND
TO SERVE THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED